COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BEGIN
MEMBERS IF YOU COULD PLEASE A
MEMBERS HELLO. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COME TO ORDER SINCE THIS
IS AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING WE
DO NOT HAVE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO WE WILL NOT BE DOING
A ROLL CALL. AND IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING IN FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL BUT SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THOSE
SENATORS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
WOULD YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES NOW. CENTER MEN.
SENATOR STERN IS HERE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT- SENATOR EGGMAN
IS ALSO PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
THE XI'AN YET. FOR WE CAN COME
BACK TO THE. SO I CAN PROCEED.
RIGHT SO IT IT SENATOR EGGMAN
STERN AND MEN THAT WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY ONCE A
SENATOR EGGMAN JOINS US WE CAN
HAVE HER- INDICATE SO WE ALSO
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WHO WILL BE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. AND FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS BECAUSE
pFEEDBACK. CAN I ASK THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM.
AND THEN WHEN I RECOGNIZE YOU
TO SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU'D LIKE TO
A MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ARGUED
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON YOU WHEN YOU HAVE COMPLETED
SPEAKING. AND ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE ALLOWING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FROM THE HEARING ROOM BUT WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. SO FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING BY TELECONFERENCE
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE
IS. THREE THREE SEVEN TWO SEVEN
SEVEN THREE. AND IF YOU NEED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW IT WORKS
LOOK AT THE SENATE AND OR OR
BUDGET COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND
IN ORDER TO HEAR. YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FREE
BACK. EVERYONE HAS TO MUTE
THEIR DEVICE THAT YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING FROM OUR
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING S.
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. AND WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND IS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENTS ARE ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. NOW WE
WILL BEGIN OUR OVERVIEW HEARING.
SO THIS IS OUR FIRST OUR FORMAL
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING OF THE
YEAR AND OUR PURPOSE IS TO HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE LA- ON THE PROPOSAL
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD ISSUED AS
PER THE CONSTITUTION
REQUIREMENT FOR THE- TWENTY.
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET NOW THAT
BUDGET AS EVERYONE KNOWS IS ONE
THAT WE WILL BY CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION ADOPTED BY JUNE
FIFTEENTH HOWEVER THERE ARE
ITEMS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S.
WOULD LIKE US TO ACT ON EARLIER
SO THOSE WILL ALSO BE ADDRESSED
JUST AS INFORMATION NOT WE WILL
NOT BE TAKING VOTES TODAY SO WE
WILL GET AN OVERVIEW NOT ONLY
ON THE FULL BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT
ON THE- EARLIER SO IMMEDIATE
ACTION AND- SHORTER TERM ACTION
ITEMS THAT THE- GOVERNOR WOULD
LIKE. HAS PROPOSED. SO
ADDITIONALLY THIS OUR BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEES WILL BEGIN THEIR
HEARINGS EARLIER THAN NORMAL
AND THE REASON THEY ARE DOING
SO IS BOTH BECAUSE WE ARE
CONSTRAINED IN TERMS OF
COMMITTEE ROOM SPACE SO WE ARE
ADVANCING THE PROCESS WE CAN
MAKE SURE TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW
OUR SUBCOMMITTEES TO HAPPIER
HEARINGS BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE
HAVETHESE EARLY ACTION ITEMS
AT THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST IT SO
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ANSEM
COMMITTEE FOR WILL HAVE. ARE
SCHEDULED TO HAVE HEARINGS NEXT
WEEK OUR OTHER SUBCOMMITTEES
WILL START THEIR REGULAR WORK
IN FEBRUARY. NOW THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT HE ISSUED LAST ON
FRIDAY REFLECTS THAT THE
REVENUE COLLECTIONS IN OUR
STATE TO DATE. ANY UPDATED
FORECAST FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER.
THAN WAS FORECAST WHEN WE THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET LAST JUNE.
SANDY ARE PROPOSAL FOR BOTH THE
FULL TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
MORE IMMEDIATE ACTIONS THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDING TO
QUICKLY DEPLOY RESOURCES FOR
EXAMPLE TO. SAFELY REOPEN
SCHOOLS PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND NONPROFITS SUPPORT RENTERS
PUT AND PUT ADDITIONAL MONEY IN
THE POCKETS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND ENHANCE AND
ACCELERATE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE. ARE PARTLY MOTIVATED
FROM THE FACT THAT WE DO HAVE
THESE- THIS ADDITIONAL REVENUE
THAN WAS EXPECTED WHEN WE
ADOPTED IN JUNE. NOW ONE ISSUE
WE WILL BE CONSIDERING IS HOW
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ALIGN
WITH THE NOT ONLY THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
BUT ALSO THE RECENT ACTION IN
DECEMBER OF CONGRESS FOR A
ECOND. CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE
AND RELIEF SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS ACT THAT'S THE
LAST TIME TO SAY ALL THOSE
WORDS I'M GONNA JUST SAY CURES
ACT FROM NOW ON- SO FAR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WILL BE
PRESENTING TO US IN THIS
OVERVIEW HEARING SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT WE WILL
BE EXPECTING TO RECEIVE FROM
THAT RECENT FEDERAL CARES ACT
SO THAT WE CAN CONSIDER IT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE OTHER
EXPENDITURES WE'RE BEING ASKED
TO MAKE USING JUST STATE FUNDS.
ON THEN I WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT WE MEANING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS IN THIS CURRENT
AND GOOD FISCAL POSITION
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF REALLY
HIGH PERFORMANCE OF THE STOCK
MARKET. AND THE ECONOMY
FUNCTIONING A LITTLE BETTER
THAN WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
PREDICTED BECAUSE OF THE FIRST
FEDERAL CARES ACT ACTION WHICH
PUT DOLLARS DIRECTLY INTO THE
HANDS. OF FAMILIES AND ALSO
MANY BUSINESSES. ADDITIONALLY
THOUGH CALIFORNIA STATE
REVENUES ARE IN GOOD FISCAL
SITUATION BECAUSE FOR THE LAST
DECADE WE THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND VOTERS HAVE
PUT INTO PLACE MANY VERY.
EFFECTIVE AND VALUABLE MEASURES
SUCH AS THE DIFFERENT RESERVES
THE REQUIREMENT TO BUILD THOSE
RESEARCH. ON THE PAYING DOWN
STRUCTURAL DEBT OVER THE LAST
X. AMOUNT OF YEARS AND SOME TAX
CHANGES AND THOSE ARE. A AND
THOSE WERE ALL DONE IN RESPONSE
TO THE RECESSION AND HAVE
HELPED US GREATLY AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HELP US GREATLY. NO
NOT WITHSTANDING THIS IMPROVED
FISCAL POSITION AS THE GOVERNOR
HIGHLIGHTED IN HIS INITIAL
PROPOSAL WHICH WE WILL AGAIN
HERE TODAY. THE RECOVERY IS ALL
OF US KNOW HAS BEEN AN EQUAL.
AND HAS EXASPERATED EXACERBATED
INEQUALITIES IN OUR STATE
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING POVERTY.
SEVERELY IMPACTING MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WITH THE LATEST
DATA STRONGLY POINTING TO WOMEN
AND WOMEN OF COLOR ESPECIALLY
BEING THE MOST HARD HIT
ECONOMICALLY. SO AS WE-
DELIBERATE ON NOT ONLY THE LONG
TERM BUDGET ACTIONS BUT THE
SHORT TERM I THINK WE WANT TO
BE THINKING ABOUT HOW TO SERVE
THOSE WHO REALLY NEED
ASSISTANCE TO SUSTAIN THEM
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC. BUT TO
ALSO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
RESILIENT AND VIABLE ECONOMY
GOING FORWARD- SO. AS IS OUR
PRACTICE WE WILL HEAR FIRST WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THEY'RE BOTH
PROMOTE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
SO BEFORE WE GO TO THEM TO
PRESENT LET ME TURN TOWARD VICE
CHAIR. SENATOR NIELSEN AND SEE
IF HE HAS ANY COMMENTS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. GLAD TO HAVE YOU ALL
SERVING ON THIS HARDEST WORKING
OF ALL THE COMMITTEES AND THE
LEGISLATURE. AND UNDERSTAND IT
IS A HUGE RESPONSIBILITY. IN
THE BECAUSE OF TRAILER BILLS
AND OTHER MATTERS SO MUCH
POLICY IS NOW DONE IN THE
BUDGET. SO WE HAVE A DUAL
RESPONSIBILITY AS POLICY AS
WELL AS BUDGETARY
CONSIDERATIONS. IT'S A BUDGET
THAT IS FOCUSED ON SOME
OPPORTUNITY. THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY. IT IS ALSO A
BUDGETS GOING REQUIRE CAREFUL
SCRUTINY. AND CARE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD COULD NOT BE BUILDING
AT THE BASE. BECAUSE I WOULD
ARGUE. OUR EXTRA MONEY I DON'T
WANT TO CALL IT SURPLUS. IS
TENUOUS WE'VE EXPLAINED WHY I
SUPPOSE WITH THAT THE CHAIR HAS
IN TERMS OF- AND THEN ANALYZING
WHAT THIS SO CALLED EXTRA MONEY
MAY BE. BUT AS IN PREVIOUS
YEARS. WE'VE GOT TO BE
CAUTIOUS. AND AGAIN THE
FUNDAMENTAL KEY. IS TO FOCUS ON
BUDGET BUILDING BASE BUILDING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING OFF TO A- GOOD
START. THANK YOU. FOR NOW WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BY ERICA LEVY WHO IS THE
NEW CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MISLEAD CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND WELCOME TO OUR
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M GOING TO GET THE
PRESENTATION UP SO THAT WE CAN
ALL SEE AT. OKAY GOOD MORNING
JERRY SKINNER AYE STERN NIELSEN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM ERICA EACH THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- IN THANK YOU FOR THAT
THE OPPORTUNITY
OVERVIEW OF THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
I'M SORRY THE CHAIR GAVE A
PREVIEW OF. THE FIRST PART OF
MY PRESENTATION- SO I'LL GO
THROUGH THAT QUICKLY THE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC OUTLOOK
HAS DRASTICALLY CHANGED SINCE
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
AND IMPROVE REVENUES ENHANCE
OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND TO THE
COMMON NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. AND MAKE INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SUPPORTS A BROAD BASED
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND PROPOSES
ACCELERATING MANY INVESTMENTS
INTO EARLY ACTION TO CREATE
JOBS AND EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS THE
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN MOST IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. THE COMPANY IS DOING
WELL RIGHT NOW BUT NOT EVERYONE
IS DOING WELL WE HAVE REVENUES
UP DRAMATICALLY- AT THE PARK
THE BUDGET FORECAST A HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT BILLION WHICH IS UP
TWENTY NINE BILLION FROM THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT. AND
UNEMPLOYMENT HAS. COME DOWN
FROM A PEAK OF SIXTEEN POINT 4%
BACK IN APRIL AND MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY DOWN EIGHT POINT TWO
PERCENT- WELL THIS IS GOOD
OBVIOUSLY THAT PRETTY RECESSION
RATE WAS THREE POINT NINE
PERCENT- AND AGAIN FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. ARE STILL
RECEIVING SOME FORM AND YOU AYE
BENEFIT AND LESS THAN HALF OF
THE JOBS THAT WE'VE LOST SINCE
FEBRUARY HAVE BEEN RECOVERED.
IMPROVE REVENUE. THE BIG
IMPROVE REVENUE PICTURE IS
REFLECTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- THE TOTAL BUT THE TOTAL
BUDGETARY EXPENDITURES ARE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN BILLION OF
WHICH A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
BILLION IS GENERAL FUND- WE
FORECAST A ONE TIME SURPLUS OF
FIFTEEN MILLION- THE L. A. O.
CALLS THIS WINDFALL- FOR EXTRA
MONEY AS VICE CHAIR NELSON HAVE
SIDE- BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ALSO BUILD BUDGETARY RESILIENCY
SO WE'VE SET ASIDE TWENTY TWO
BILLION IN TOTAL RESERVES AND
THAT REALLY HELPED TO PROTECT
THE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND
OTHER SERVICES LEADING INTO THE
RECESSION WAS HAVING A STRONG
RESEARCH. AND PRUDENT MEASURES
THAT WERE TAKEN PRIOR TO- THE
COBIT RECESSION IN ADDITION-
THE BUDGET PROPOSES AN
ADDITIONAL THREE BILLION
TOWARDS STATE RETIREMENT
LIABILITIES AND THAT SIX POINT
FIVE BILLION OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS- IN RECOGNITION OF
IMPROVE REVENUES WE HAVE
SCHEDULED PROGRAMS EXPANSIONS
THAT ARE DELAYED BY A YEAR- AND
YOU KNOW THIS IS WEEK WE DO WE
ARE FORECASTING OUT HERE
OPERATING DEFICIT SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE SPENDING- ONE TIME VERSUS
ON GOING- SO WELL WE DO HAVE A
SURPLUS IN. THE BUDGET YEAR
WE'RE LOOKING AT- I HERE
OPERATING. DEFICITS STARTING IN
TWO TO THREE ABOUT POINT SIXTY.
AND GROWING TO TWENTY FIVE OVER
ELEVEN BILLION BY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE- SO AS I MENTIONED
OPERATING DEFICITS WILL
CONSTRAIN I'M GOING SPENDING SO
MANY OF THE PROPOSAL THAT ARE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS
WELL AS- OR INCLUDING THAT.
FIFTEEN BILLION SURPLUS- ARE
ONE TIME. AT THIS POINT I'D
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE BUDGET
DOES PROJECTS- THAT THE STATE
APPROPRIATION LIMIT WILL BE
EXCEEDED- BY A MODERATE AMOUNT
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWO MILLION
DOLLARS- ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT. THESE ARE NOT FINAL-
PROJECTIONS WILL HAVE FINAL
REVENUE AND EXPENDITURES IN THE
SPRING AND WILL COME BACK TO
THE BODY. WRITTEN A REVISION
WITH UPDATED CALCULATIONS.
THIRTY INCREASE REVENUES ARE
DUE LARGELY TO THREE FACTORS AS
THE CHAIR STATE AND- THE LESS
SEVERE DOWNTURN IF IT IS A LOT
OF THEIR DOWNTURN. LARGELY
INTACT- BECAUSE OF FEDERAL
STIMULUS THAT WAS PROVIDED
EARLY LAST YEAR- ALSO THERE WAS
A SIGNIFICANT ON EQUAL SPREAD
OF WAGE NOT WAITING JOB LOSSES
WHERE YOU SAW A LOT OF HIGHER
INCOME WORKERS- WERE ABLE TO
PASS THAT AND MOVE TO TELEWORK.
AND LOWER INCOME WORKERS WERE
NOT THE HIGHER WAGE WORKERS- IN
OUR STATE PAY MORE IN TAXES
THAN THAT REALLY HELP TO BUFFER
THE REVENUE LOSSES THAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW. BLACKARACHNIA BOXES
AND THEN THIRDLY THE STOCK
MARKET JUST HIT RECORD HIGHS
AND THAT HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
CAPITOL RECORDS CAPITAL GAINS.
AGAIN BENEFITING HIGHER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS SO I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT- THERE HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS- I LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
AND THE BUDGET REALLY LOOKS TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL ACCELERATE. AND JUMPSTART-
ECONOMIC GROWTH WITH A FOCUS.
ON THOSE MOST IMPACTED. GET OUT
A LOT BECAUSE I IS A EIGHTEEN
IN THIS BUT- I OF COURSE
SPEAKING TO SOME OF THOSE
PROPOSAL ARE ONE OF YOUR TIME
TO THIS. SLIDE WHICH HIGHLIGHTS
COST ESTIMATES INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET FOR KOBE NINETEEN OR
MERGING FEAR RESPONSE WERE
ESTIMATING ABOUT FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION IN ADDITIONAL
COSTS SINCE THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET- IT. AND THIS IS FOR
EFFORTS THAT INVOLVE VACCINES
TO TESTING CONTACT TRACING FOOD
BANKS- HOUSING COMMUNICATION
AND OTHERS. THE BUDGET FOCUSES
ON AN EQUITABLE AND BROAD BASED
RECOVERY STARTING NOW AND AS-
CHURCH GUNNER SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASKING FOR
IMMEDIATE BUDGET ACTION. AND
THESE ARE THE FIVE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE- WE WOULDASK FOR
IMMEDIATE CONSIDERATION- SOME
OF WHICH YOU. OR ALL OF WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD OF- IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS- SO I'LL JUST
QUICKLY GO THROUGH THEM. THE
FIRST IS TO TYPICALLY REOPEN
SCHOOLS- REOPENING SCHOOLS FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IS A
PRIORITY TO MITIGATE A LOT OF
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS THAT HAVE
HEARD. DURING THE PEP PANDEMIC
ON STUDENTS BUT PARTICULARLY
LOW INCOME STUDENTS- ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS STUDENTS IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS IN
FOSTER CARE. STUDENTS THAT ARE
HOMELESS AND YOUNG STUDENTS
THEY HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED AND
THESE BONDS ALONG WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDS WE-
WILL BE RECEIVING. TO THE LAST
FEDERAL STIMULUS PACKAGE WILL
ASSIST SCHOOL DISTRICTS ADDRESS
SAFETY CONCERNS- DOLLARS CAN BE
SPENT ON USES THAT WILL
SUPPORT. FEEDING KIDS AND
TEACHERS BACK SAFELY AS THE
CLASSROOM AND THAT COULD BE
ANYTHING- AROUND TESTING PP
CLEANING VIOLATION AFTER
CLASSROOMS. AND THE FEDERAL.
THE SECOND- PROPOSAL IS THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS THIS IS A
TO GET RELIEF INTO- PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY IT'S A ONE TIME SIX
DOLLAR TAX REFUND HELLO INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS- SPECIFICALLY TO
TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA YET
KISI RECIPIENTS AND TWENTY
TWENTY- K<c.cyan> I. T. V. I.</c>
TEMPLARS. THIRTY RECOGNITION
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE ALSO
BEEN A SEVERELY IMPACTED AND
THAT THEY ARE REALLY ENGINES OF.
I MAKE GROWTH IN OUR STATE ARE
WE REALLY WANT TO SUPPORT AND
PROVIDE BELIEVE FOR THEM SO WE
HAVE GRANTS OF UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS- THROUGH-
A FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION TOTAL ASKED. WE ALSO
ARE ASKING FOR- THE RELIEF FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
HEAVILY IMPACTED AND THOSE
INCLUDE- UNDER THOSE INCLUDE A
LICENSE THAT LICENSE FEES UNDER
THE BOARD OF BARBERING
COSMETOLOGY AS WELL AS- BARS
AND RESTAURANTS. AND THEN
LASTLY IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
IMMEDIATELY ADDRESSED THE
EVICTION MORATORIUM EXTENSION-
AND DISCUSS THE WAYS OF GETTING
OUT THE TWO POINT SIX BILLION
WERE EXPECTED TO RECEIVE FROM
THE FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT SO
THOSE THE FIVE IMMEDIATE BUDGET.
AN OBVIOUS THERE MAY OTHER-
THERE ARE THERE ARE THERE'S
ANOTHER PACKAGE OF EARLY ACTION
ITEMS THAT WILL BE ASKING FOR
AS WELL AND I'LL QUICKLY GO
OVER SOME OF THOSE IN THE NEXT
FEW SLIDES THEY WANTED TO
REALLY PREVIOUS IMMEDIATE
BUDGET ACTION FOR YOU. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WOULD ACTION
THE BUDGET INCLUDES A SUITE OF
PROPOSALS. PROBLEM OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGH A JOBS
INITIATIVE. ADD TO THE OVERALL
ASKING FOR SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION- OF WHICH
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION WILL BE REQUESTED FOR
EARLY ACTION- AND THIS IS
REALLY SUPPORT. BY WAY OF
GRANTS CREDIT MICROGRAMS LOAN
GUARANTEES. AND SALES AND USE
TAX WAIVERS- THIS. IS ALIGNED
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER-
EARLIER. IMMEDIATE ACTION ON
THE PREVIOUS SLIDE IN THE
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES MANY
PROJECTS- MANY OTHER PROPOSALS
THAT ARE JOB CREATING. PROJECTS
SUCH AS THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS THIS IS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TOWARDS. LOCAL GRANT GRANTS TO
LOCALS THAT WILL BASICALLY-
ALLOW THEM TO JUMP START
PROJECTS THAT OUR FUTURE LONG
TERM HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS. ON
THIS TO BE LIKE LIGHTING AND
SEWERS AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE- THAT IS
NECESSARY FOR HOUSING. BOB WHAT
WE ALSO HAVE. OUR THAT AN OURS
YOU'RE A MISSION HERE. AND
WILDFIRE FORCES PACKAGES- THAT
WILL LIKELY START. GROWTH AS
WELL AS ADVANCE TO STATE
SCHOOLS TOWARDS CLEAN AIR. AND
DEAL WITH THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AS- THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE PACKAGES AT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION- OF
WHICH WILL BE ASKING- TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE MILLION FOR
EARLY ACTION. I PUT THAT IN RED
TO DENOTE THE DIFFERENCE- THE
ONE BILLION WOULD BE EAST OF
THE CHARACTERIZATION OF FUTURE
VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEES TO
ALLOW FOR CONSTRUCTION OF
CHARGING STATIONS- HENCE THAT
THE JOB GROWTH RATE THERE- AND
THEN FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION WILL BE FOR INCENTIVES.
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO THE US.
WHAT ARE THE WILD FIRES FOR A
RESILIENT PACKAGES REALLY
IMPORTANT AT- AND MINDS. IT
THEN HE OF THE WORST FIRE
SEASON EVER WITH OVER FOUR
MILLION ACRES- BURNED IN TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN TO ADDRESS THE
SCALE AND URGENCY OF WILDFIRE
RISK THE BUDGET INCLUDES A
BILLION. ONE BILLION TO SUPPORT
THE FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK
FORCE'S. WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN- AND
THAT'S REALLY IT WILL JUMP
START PROJECTS AROUND FOREST
MANAGEMENT SECURING FUEL
BREAKS. AND HARDENING. AND HAS
UNDER. THE OF WERE DEVELOPMENT
PARTICULARLY AS SOME OF THE
FACTORS ARE BEING RESHAPED
ENTIRELY BY THE RECESSION- AN
EXAMPLE IS THE LEISURE SECTOR-
SO THE- BUDGET INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION- TO
IMPROVE LINKAGES BETWEEN HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTES AND
EMPLOYERS. AND WE'RE WORKING ON
PROPOSALS IN REGARDS- HIGHER
EDUCATION HAS SEVERAL
APPRENTICESHIPS AND WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES TOTALING
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION AND HEN
ARE HIGHER IS TRAINING PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE EXISTING PROGRAMS-
INCLUDE INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET
IS TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
WHICH WERE ASKING EARLY ACTION.
AND THEY COVER THE FOLLOWING-
AREAS CONSTRUCTION FORESTRY AND
ASK HEALTHCARE TRAINING
LOGISTICS AND IT AND BASED ON-
ARE A REVIEW OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
THIS DOLLAR AMOUNT AMOUNTS TO
ABOUT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED JOBS.
SO MOVING ON TO EDUCATION-
INCREASES IN REVENUES HAVE LED
TO SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE
AND- WE'RE SEEING THE HIGHEST
LEVEL EVER OF THE FUNDS GO
TOWARDS PROP NINETY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH SIXTY BILLION
OF THAT IS GENERAL FUND- WE'VE
ALSO BEEN ABLE TO INCLUDE THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT WHICH
FULLY FUNDS THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AT TARGET
LEVELS. THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL
TWO BILLION- WE ARE- PROPOSING
TO PAY OFF A MAJORITY OF THE .
TWELVE DEFERRALS THAT WERE IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET THAT
WAS TWELVE POINT NINE BILLION.
IN TOTAL AND WE'RE PROPOSING A
PATH OF NINE POINT TWO BILLION.
AND ADDITIONALLY ARE PROPOSING.
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION ON TOP
OF THE PROP NINETY EIGHT- SO
THIS IS MORE MONEY TO SCHOOLS.
AND THAT INCLUDES A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT OF TWO
POINT THREE BILLION AND-
RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTION RATE
BUY DOWN A ONE POINT ONE
BILLION. SOMEONE WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME ON THIS NEXT SLIDE-
THE EXTENDED LEARNING TIME
FLIES. AND THIS IS- OUR LARGEST
EARLY ACTION PROPOSAL OUTSIDE
OF THE IMMEDIATE ACTION AND IT
BUT IT DOES COMPLIMENTS THAT
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO BILLION
PROPOSAL OF REOPENING SCHOOLS-
AGAIN JUST SORT OF JUST
ACKNOWLEDGING THE HUGE
DISRUPTIONS. THAT STUDENTS HAVE
HAD TO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM WE AE PROPOSING FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE IMPACTS AND THE
IDEA IS TO ASK FOR EARLY ACTION
ON THIS TO ALLOW TIME FOR THE
DISTRICTS- AND TEACHERS TO WORK
ON PLANS TO HELP- MITIGATE
WHAT'S- WHAT'S OCCURRED SO FAR
AND TARGETED INTERVENTIONS
COULD INCLUDE COMMUNITY
LEARNING HUBS- THIS SUMMER
SCHOOL BEFORE OR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. AS EXAMPLES. IN
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THEIR
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES- FOR ALL
THE SEGMENTS WHICH HAVE BEEN
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC I'M STARTING WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE HAVE
BASIC CREASES OF A HUNDRED
ELEVEN MILLION FOR THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ON PROPOSAL FOR
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID AT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION- AT THIS
POINT LEAVE UP THERE ARE
REPORTS THAT THERE IS ABOUT AN
8% DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT FCC
FEES WHICH IS VERY UNUSUAL
DURING RECESSIONS USUALLY-
PEOPLE END UP GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL BUT DID 8% DECREASE IN-
INVOLVEMENT. IS CONCERNING
BECAUSE OF POTENTIAL LOSSES OF
PEOPLE TO COMPLETION AND
COMPLETING- THERE HIGHER END
PLANS- SO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IS INCLUDED A HUNDRED
MILLION FOR EARLY ACTION AND
SORRY I DIDN'T SAY THAT THERE
SHOULD BE. A RED HUNDRED
MILLION NEXT YEAR REGENCY
FINANCIAL AID- AND THEN THE CSU
AND UC SYSTEM OF EACH- WE'RE
PROPOSING A 3% BASE INCREASE
FOR EACH OF THOSE AND ON TOP OF
THAT THERE ALSO- OTHER ONGOING
AND ONE TIME DOLLARS. BEING
INVESTED. AND LASTLY- THE PLAN
AID- THIRTY FIVE A THREE FIVE
MILLION FOUR NINE THOUSAND NEW
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT. I
HOMELESSNESS- BUT WE HAVE A
LARGE PROPOSAL ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION IN GRANTS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ACQUIRE
HOUSING- THAT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- IS FOR ABOUT-
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FOR THEIR
HUNKY- UP PROGRAM WHICH THEY
STOOD UP IN THE FALL VERY
QUICKLY AND I USED ZERO DOLLARS
FOR THAT A CROWD OF BUYERS
REALLY FUND DOLLARS- THEY'RE
ASKING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN EARLY ACTION THERE
SO THAT- WE CAN. ADDRESS
IMMEDIATELY ADDRESSED-
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES IN
ADDITION- SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION WILL GO FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO EXPAND COMMUNITY-
CONTINUING CONTINUING CARE
TREATMENT AND THIS IS REALLY TO
EXPAND THE TYPES OF- UNITS THAT
WERE BEING REQUIRED SO THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS. INDIVIDUALS WITH
MORE Q. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
AND LASTLY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES- FOR MOBILE
SENIORS IN THIS IS THIS WOULD
BE ADDING TO THE SUPPLY OF.
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME SENIORS.
AND ON THE HEALTH FRONT-
COVENANT PANDA HAVE ALL
UNDERSTOOD THE TAKES. COVERAGE
AN INCREASE AFFORDABILITY OF
HEALTH CARE FOR AFTER ALL THE
STATE MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN THE PAST AND
THIS BUDGET CONTINUES THAT WITH
THE PROPOSAL TO OPENED- THE NEW
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY- TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND COST AND
QUALITY AND DEVELOP COST
TARGETS FOR THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY. AS WELL AS IN FORCE
COMPLIANCE- IT IN THAT INDUSTRY.
THE PANDEMIC IS OBVIOUSLY TAKEN
A TOLL ON EVERYBODY'S MENTAL
HEALTH- BUT PARTICULARLY
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SO WE
HAVE A PROPOSAL OF THE FORTY
FIFTY MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION PROPOSAL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO CREATE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH OFFICES AND SCHOOLS TO
BETTER TO BETTER- IDENTIFY AND
PROVIDE EARLY INTERVENTIONS
FOR. YOUNG STUDENTS. AND LASTLY
I'M SORRY CAL AIMED. AT
REINTRODUCING CAL AIM TO
SUPPORT COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS AND REALLY
TRANSFORM THE DELIVERY YSTEM-
IN REGARDS TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES TO IT SO WE'RE
BETTER CONNECTING THE SERVICES
THAT PEOPLE NEED WITH- THESE
INDIVIDUALS- AND LASTLY HERE IS
THE INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL-
WHICH IS A PILOTS- AND THE-
WHAT. HURT ME THERE IS A- LONG
LIST OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BEEN REFERRED BY TRIAL COURTS
TO- GO TO A STATE HOSPITAL- AND
OTHER AWAITING PLACEMENT THERE
THEY'RE IN JAIL SO THIS
PROPOSAL- BASICALLY LIKE THAT
HOW POLITICAL HOW COUNTIES CAN
PROVIDE. STREAMLINED CARE FOR
THEM TO IMPROVE THEIR OUTCOMES.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST IS THE
FLIGHT ON CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION THE
BUDGET PRIORITIZES STUMBLE
CLIMENT PROPOSALS OF THE VIEW
OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE OUR
FIRST IS THE CAP AND TRADE PLAN
AT ONE POINT FOUR BILLION AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR OF THE AND EARLY
ACTION. THAT REALLY HELPED
ADVANCE THE STATE'S PARTIES ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CLEAN AIR
AND WATER- WE HAVE A TOXIC
THANK CLEAN UP- PROPOSAL. OUR
TEAM VALERI CLEANUP OF
CONTAMINATED PROPERTIES IN
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES THREE
HUNDRED MILLION OF THAT WILL GO
TOWARDS- ABOUT AN ASSESSMENT OF
GENERAL- OR CONCISE AND LOOKING
AT A HEALTH BASED CRITERIA
DECIDING WHICH ONES WILL GET
CLEANED UP FIRST. AND THIRTY
ONE MILLION OF THE. THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE IS FOR THE
EXIDE CLEANUP. I'M LASSES
INTEGRATE PEST- PROJECT THAT I
REALLY IS LOOKING. REDUCE THE-
USE OF TOXIC PESTICIDE- IN- IN
OUR AGRICULTURE- PROGRAM. SO
WITH THAT THAT IS- A LOOK AT.
THE A QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- I AM HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS OF THE
PRIMARY TIME ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU S. ERICA- CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTORATE I DO F.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE GO TO
QUESTIONS OR DO YOU F. I THINK
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE
ELADIO THERE PRESENTATION IS A
BIT BRIEFER. BUT THAT WAY WE
CAN OPEN UP OR QUESTIONS TO
BOTH ELIO AND DLF. SO IF THAT-
WORKS- THE N. AS I MENTIONED IN
THE OPENING IN ADDITION TO AN
OVERVIEW ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL. R. ELIA WILL
GIVE US AN OVERVIEW OF THE
FEDERAL SUPPORT THAT WAS JUST
APPROVED IN DECEMBER. MR
PADDOCK WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU LOOK FOR
TIER OVERVIEW. OKAY- EXCELLENT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND SENATORS FOR
INCLUDING OUR OFFICE IN TODAY'S
HEARING MY NAME IS GAMEPAD IT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND- AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED I WILL PROVIDE
SOME OVERVIEW REMARKS OPERATES
OUR OFFICES INITIAL ASSESSMENT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THEN I'LL BE HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE AND ALSO I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE OFFICE-
SEVERAL OF THEM WERE JOINED IN
AS WELL AND SO THEY CAN- ALSO
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS OF SCIENCE
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. TODAY MY
REMARKS WILL BE OUTLINED BY THE
HAND OUT WHICH YOU SHOULD HAVE
BEEN YOUR MATERIALS. AND
HOPEFULLY I'M SHARING MY SCREEN
AND YOU CAN SEE IT THERE AS
WELL. FOR ANYONE. THAT FOR
ANYONE ELSE YOU CAN FIND THE
HAND OUT AT OUR WEBSITE WHICH
IS L. A. O. DOT CA DOT GOES.
AND I'LL JUST MENTION. THAT WE
ALSO HAVE OUR OUR REPORT ON THE
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THAT WAY- PUBLISHED ON-
SUNDAY EVENING AND SO THAT CAN
ALSO BE FOUND ON OUR WEBSITE
FOR THOSE THAT ARE INTERESTED.
OKAY SO WITH THAT I WILL JUMP
INTO THE FIRST PAGE. OF THE
HANDOUT. AND HERE YES WE
CALCULATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REFLECTS ABOUT A FIFTEEN
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME SURPLUS. WHILE THIS IS
QUITE LARGE IT IS NOTICEABLY
DOWN FROM THE TWENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLAR. WINDFALL THAT
ARE NOVEMBER FISCAL OUTLOOK
IDENTIFIED WERE ESTIMATED. WE
REFERRED TO IT AS A WINDFALL I
KNOW THIS IS BANNED THERE'S
SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT TO
CALL IT WE DID REFER TO IT AS A
WINDFALL. WE THOUGHT THAT HELPS
EMPHASIZE THE ONE TIME NATURE
OF THE SURPLUS AND ALSO IT'S
SORT OF CONVEYS THE SENSE THAT
IT'S MORE A FUNCTION OF
REVENUES. NOT CLIMB JEAN IN THE
WAY THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT THIS YEAR AND- MORE
THAN IT DOES ANY KIND OF- YOU
KNOW SEARCH ABOUT THE HISTORIC
TRENDS SO. THAT'S THE- GOOD THE
REASON WE CALL IT A WINDFALL
AND- IT ONE OTHER THING IS
NOTABLE ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE OFFICES OUR OFFICE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATE OF THIS ONE FALL IS
THAT WE HAVE VERY SIMILAR
REVENUE ESTIMATES. IN FACT OVER
THE THREE YEAR BUDGET WINDOW
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS HIGHER
THAN OUR OFFICE BY ABOUT ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS. REVENUES IN BUDGET.
SO THAT LEAVES THE QUESTION AS
WELL WHAT IS CAUSING THE
DIFFERENCE AND I THINK THERE
ARE THREE MAIN REASONS FOR YOU
TO CONSIDER THE FIRST IS THAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION- HAS HIGHER
CAPITAL GAINS RELATED TAX
REVENUES AND ALSO HAS A
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATION OF THE
RULES FOR WHEN A DEPOSIT OR A
TRUE UP DEPOSIT UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF PROPOSITION CHIU
FOR THE STATE'S RAINY DAY FUND
AND DEBT REPAYMENT REQUIREMENTS
AND SO AS A RESULT. OF THOSE
pGAINS AND THE- DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION OF WHEN A TRUE
UP- DEPOSIT IS REQUIRED. BERMAN
A FINANCE HAS A FIVE POINT SIX
BILLION- YEAH AND- USE THEIR
WHICH DETRACTS FROM THE SURPLUS
THROUGH THE WINDFALL. THE
SECOND DIFFERENCE IS THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ABOUT TWO
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS AND
HIGHER COLLUDED RELATED
EXPENDITURES THAN WE HAVE IN
OUR- HAD IN OUR FISCAL OUTLOOK.
AND THEN THIRD THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS AROUND TWO
BILLION YEN HIGHER HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE RELATED EXPENSES
PRIMARILY THE CASELOAD DRIVEN
PROGRAMS. OKAY SO. MOVING TO
THE NEXT SLIDE HERE THE TWO
FIGURES ON THIS SLIDE- IT OFFER
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO
THINK ABOUT HOW THE GOVERNOR IS
ALLOCATING THE WINDFALL- THE
TOP FIGURE THE USE OR THE DONUT
SHAPED FIGURE- PROVIDES A BREAK
OUT IN THE FOLLOWING WAY THE
GOVERNOR HAS EIGHT POINT ONE
BILLION. WHAT TOWARD ONE TIMER
TEMPORARY PURPOSES THAT'S ABOUT
52% OF THE WINDFALL. HE HAS TWO
POINT NINE BILLION IN
DISCRETIONARY RESERVES
PRIMARILY TO STATES THAT
SPECIAL FUNDS FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY. TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION IS USED FOR REVENUE
REDUCTIONS WHICH IS LARGELY THE
TAX REFUNDS FOR LOW INCOME
TAXPAYERS- THE GOVERNOR
ALLOCATES ONE POINT THREE
BILLION TO NEW ONGOING
SPENDING. AND THEN HE HAS
AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION OF
ADDITIONAL DEBT AND LIABILITY
HEY MAN BEYOND WHAT THE
EXISTING LAW WOULD REQUIRE. THE
SECOND FIGURE BELOW. NOT TO YOU
KNOW REALLY REPEAT WHAT. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE SAID BUT
EACH THERE ARE SHOWING THE
DIFFERENT- ALLOCATIONS OF THE
WINDFALL UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BY KIND OF PROGRAM
AREA SO THE DARK BARS SHOWING
THE ONE TIME IN THE LATER PARTS
OF THE BAR SHOWING THE ONGOING
PORTION. ONE THE NEXT FLIGHT AS
WAS MENTIONED- DUE TO A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE. THROUGH THE
IN THE BUDGET WINDOWS CELL FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THROUGH.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE STATE HAS
NINETEEN POINT ONE BILLION
AVAILABLE FOR NEW SPENDING ON
K. THROUGH FOURTEEN EDUCATION.
AND THIS SLIDE. SUMMARIZES BY
THE MAJOR AREAS WHERE THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO
ALLOCATE THESE RESOURCES. THE
FIRST IS- WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
EIGHT POINT FOUR BILLION THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING FOR
DEFERRAL PAID DOWN SO THAT
WOULD BE ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
THAT TOTAL- DEFERRALS THAT WERE.
UTILIZED IN THE JUNE. TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET PACKAGE- IT WOULD
LEAVE AROUND FOUR BILLION OF
DEBT DEFERRALS ON THE BOOKS
AFTER THE CURRENT YEAR- BUT
AFTER THE BUDGET YEAR. AND THE
GOVERNOR ALSO IS REQUESTING SIX
POINT SIX BILLION IN FUNDING
FOR ONE TIME GRANTS FOR SCHOOLS
TWO BILLION OF THIS IS THE
FUNDING THAT WOULD PROVIDE
INCENTIVIZE INCENTIVIZE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO RESUME IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. AND THEN FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION OF IT IS FOR
THE EXPANDED EXPANDED- ACADEMIC
SUPPORT- OFFERINGS. THE TICKET
WERE REALLY AIMED AT SOME OF
THE STATE'S HIGHER NEED
STUDENTS. AND THEN LAST THE
THERE IS TWO POINT TWO BILLION
TO US FUND THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. OUR OUR OVERALL
VIEW OF THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT PROPOSALS THAT IT DOES
REFLECT A VERY REASONABLE NEXT
OF ONE TIME AND ONGOING
PROPOSALS. IN PARTICULAR THE
SIGNIFICANT SHARE OF- ONE TIME
AS PER ONE TIME SPENDING
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR. IS
PRUDENT BECAUSE IT PROVIDES A
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION. IN THE
SENSE THAT IN THE EVENT THAT
THERE IS A FUTURE VOLATILITY IN
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE AND THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT DROP IN IT IT
WOULD INSULATE- PROGRAMS FROM
HAVING TO BE CUT SO SOON SO- WE
THINK THAT THE PROPOSAL IS
GENERALLY- FINDING ABOUT THE
RIGHT MIX OF ONE TIME VERSUS
ONGOING. OKAY ARE MOVING TO THE
NEXT SLIDE HERE IS WHERE WE GET
INTO A DISCUSSION OF THIS THE
STATE'S PROPOSAL IN LIGHT OF
THIS GENERAL RELIEF PACKAGE AS
THE TRIGGER MENTION MENTION.
AND WE JUST KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
DEVELOPED- BEFORE YOU YOU KNOW
INHERENTLY WAS DEVELOPED
BEFORE- THAT'S THE MOST RECENT
FEDERAL RELIEF PACKAGE WAS
ADOPTED. AND SO IN LIGHT OF
THAT WE DO THINK THAT YOU MAY.
WANT TO CONSIDER OR DETERMINE
HOW BEST TO TARGET STATE
RESOURCES. SO THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
LINE TO ALREADY RECEIVED A
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. AND
SECONDLY KIND OF RELATED TO
THAT. WE WOULD SAY. YOU KNOW
THE U. S. AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
IN THIS PROCESS THAT THE STATE
WOULD WANT TO BE CAREFUL TO
COMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL RELIEF
PACKAGES RATHER THAN A
DUPLICATE THE FEDERAL EFFORTS.
SO S. AS WAS MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR IS ASKING FOR YOUR
APPROVAL IN THE LEGISLATURE
SOME MAJOR SPENDING PROPOSALS
TO BE TAKEN ON AN IMMEDIATE
BASIS OR AND EARLY ACTION
BASIS. THE SOME OF THE USERS
AROUND TWELVE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS WITH FIVE
BILLION OF IT BEING IN THE
IMMEDIATE ACTION CATEGORIES.
AND CATEGORY AND WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERN ABOUT IT A COUPLE
OF THESE- MENTION YOU KNOW THEY
THE TWO BILLION FOR A
RESUMPTION OF IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION TO THE SCHOOLS.
REYES IS A BIT OF CONCERN
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
CERTAIN THAT THE DISTRICTS
WOULD BE ABLE TO MEET THE
VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY
WITHIN THE TIME LINE AS
PROPOSED AND YOU KNOW THE
CONCERNED THEY'RE BEING WE
WOULDN'T WANT TO DISSUADE SOME
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS FROM
PARTICIPATING BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE.
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THE MILESTONES
NECESSARY SO THAT'S A CONCERN
WE HAVE ON THAT ONE. ON THE-
TAX REFUNDS FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AGAIN YOU KNOW
THIS WAS DEVELOPED. BEFORE WE
HAD THE FINAL SHOULD RELIEF
PACKAGE AND SO YOU KNOW THE
UNDER THAT PACKAGE MOST
TAXPAYERS IN THE COUNTRY WILL
RECEIVE A SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
STIMULUS CHECKS AND THAT'S THE
AMOUNT OF THE- GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS PROGRAM AND SO. YOU
KNOW YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
WAYS TO TARGET THOSE FUNDS TO.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
RECEIVING THAT KIND OF STUFF US
FEDERAL SUPPORT. BUT THEN WHEN
IT COMES. TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
AND NONPROFIT THIS IS GROUP.
AND THE FEE WAIVER- WE THINK
THOSE ARE. REASONABLE YEAH-
WORTH YOUR YOU KNOW WORTH YOUR
CAN- WHEN IT COMES THE EARLIER
FROM. WHICH SOME TO ROUNDS
POINT DALY DOLLARS. YOU KNOW
HERE THE LEGISLATURE HAS A BIT
MORE TIME TO CONSIDER THEM IN
SO WE COULD FORWARD FOR YOU IS-
A FRAMEWORK FOR THINKING ABOUT
THEM REALLY IN THE FORM OF FOUR
QUESTIONS WHICH ARE ARE-
QUESTIONS LIKE- DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDED
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE OF IT. YOU
KNOW PANDEMIC RELATED PROBLEM
IS THE PROBLEM REALLY
EXPLICITLY TIED TO THE PANDEMIC.
SECONDLY IS THE PROPOSAL YOU
KNOW REALLY TIME SENSITIVE OR
IS ALL OF THE FUNDING BEING
REQUESTED TIME SENSITIVE IT IF
SO. AND THEN FINALLY IS THERE
SUFFICIENT DETAIL IN THE
PROPOSAL. ENABLING THE
LEGISLATURE TO- ASSESS THE
POTENTIAL FOR SUCCESS OF THE
PROPOSAL- SO THAT'S KIND OF A
UNUSUAL SIGHTS ON- HOW TO THINK
ABOUT THOSE- EARLY ACTION
REQUEST- THE OTHER THING WE
JUST ALSO WANT TO JUST TAKE A
MOMENT IN CONCLUSION AND POINT
OUT IS THAT. AS WITH THE OUR
OFFICE IS NOVEMBER FISCAL
OUTLOOK WHERE WE IDENTIFY THE
OPENING OF A NEW A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT IN THE COMING YEARS.
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
IDENTIFIES TO THE EMERGENCE OF
A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN FUTURE
YEARS AND SO- YOU KNOW WE JUST
PUT THE FACT THAT YOU WILL WANT
TO KEEP THAT IN MIND. AS YOU
CONSIDER HOW TO ALLOCATE THIS
WINDFALL IN THE VARIOUS CHOICES
THAT ARE BEFORE YOU WE DO THINK
YOU'LL WANT TO KEEP IN MIND-
PLEASE OUT YOUR FISCAL
PRESSURES AS YOU DELIBERATE-
LET'S SEE THE OTHER BEING WHO
ARE. SORRY HELLO STARTED. WE
ALSO PROVIDED ON THE FINAL TWO
PAGES OF YOUR HAND OUT WE HAVE-
SUMMARIZED AND PUT IN TWO MAJOR
CATEGORIES THE MOST RECENT
FEDERAL PACKAGE SO WE PROVIDE
HERE- THE MAJOR TYPES OF
ASSISTANCE INTO THE INTO THE
CATEGORIES OF ASSISTANCE. THEN
WE'VE ALSO PROVIDED ESTIMATES
OF THE AMOUNTS OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WILL COME AND FLOW
THROUGH TO CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
LASTLY WE PROVIDE A BRIEF
SUMMARY OF THESE AND SO. THIS
THIS INFORMATION ON THE FINAL
TWO SLIDES IS REALLY FOR YOUR
INFORMATION AND TO KIND OF.
HELP PROVIDED. ORGANIZED WAY TO
LOOK AT THE FEDERAL PACKAGE. SO
WITH THAT I'M- HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO QUESTIONS YOU YOU MAY HAVE.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MR PADDOCK FOR
PRESENTING THAT AND- MEMBERS WE
WILL OBVIOUSLY NOW TURN TO
QUESTIONS TO BOTH- L. A. R. D.
O. F. AND- BEFORE I CALL WHEN
YOU I WOULD TAKE THE
PREROGATIVE OF THE CHAIR. Q. A-
ASK A FEW OVER ARCHING- SO AS
WE'VE HEARD REVENUES ARE HIGHER
AND- THE END AND THEY'VE BEEN
HIGHER IF YOU WE IF WE LOOK AT
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. AT
LEAST OUR STATE REVENUES FROM
THAT DO YOU ARE PROJECTED HAVE
BEEN HIGHER EACH YEAR FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS THEN- THEN THE
BUDGETS WE ADOPTED SO. WHAT I'M
MY QUESTION IS. GIVEN OUT OF
OUR ACTUARIAL I WOULD SAY WELL
THIS AND THAT- INDICATE THAT WE
MIGHT HAVE SIMILAR FORECASTS
HOWEVER BOTH BELIAU INDIA WEF.
SAY THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
HAVING REVENUES AT A SLOWER
RATE- CAN YOU BOTH GIVE US YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON WHY YOU ARE
PREDICTING FOR US THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE SEWER RATE
REVENUES. HI MADAM CHAIR CAN I
TURN THAT QUESTION TO J.
CHAMBERLAIN AND AT FINANCE SURE.
I GOOD GOOD MORNING- SO YOU'RE
YOU'RE CORRECT WE ARE
PROJECTING SLOWING GROWTH OF
REVENUES OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS THE REAL REASON IS THAT-
HELLO I TAKE THE MAYES THERE'S
TWO REASONS I GUESS. THAT I
WOULD THAT WOULD POINT TO FIRST
OF ALL- CAPITAL GAINS IS
EXPECTED HIT A PEAK IN THE
CURRENT CALENDAR YEAR SO IN THE
END OF THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALENDAR WE EXPECT CAPITAL
GAINS TO PEAK. AND EXPECT THEM
TO BE DROPPING OFF AFTER AFTER
THAT AND THIS IS BASED ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE STOCK
MARKET. IS GOING TO BE IS
HIGHLY VALUED AT THIS POINT AND
THAT IT COULD- THE STOCK MARKET
SHOULD GROW ONLY SLOWLY OVER
THE COMING YEARS WITH IT WHICH
I THINK IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT. THE L. WAS ME ON THE
OTHER THING IS THAT- AS AS
ERICA HAS POINTED OUT. WE HAD-
HELLO OF THE A LOT OF THE PAIN
THAT FELT THIS. IN OF AMERICAN
PAIN WAS AT THE WAS BY LOW WAGE.
SO THAT- THE WAGE GROWTH ARE
YOU ARE THE WAY TO CLIENTS THAT
WE SAW WERE WAS REALLY. A FOCUS
ON LOW WAGE EARNERS WHICH MEANT
THAT- THE DISTRIBUTION OF
INCOME BECAME OF MORE HAVE.
BECAME MORE EXAGGERATED AND
THAT THE- BETWEEN HIGH INCOME
LOW INCOME DURING THIS PERIOD
WE EXPECT SOME OF THAT- WIND
AND OVER THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
AS HAS A LOW WAGE EARNERS- WE
HAVE RETURNED TO THEIR JOBS AND
SO LONG THE WAGE GROWTH. OR
LISA DID- SOMEWHAT HIGHER
PERCENTAGES OF WAGE GROWTH IN
COMING YEARS WILL BE LOW INCOME
SO THOSE TWO FACTORS ARE GOING
TO MEAN THAT- THAT WE WILL HAVE
DROPPED A DROP IN CAPS GAINS
AND WAGE GROWTH WE DO GET. IS
GOING TO BE TAXED AT A LOWER
RATE AND SO OVERALL- WE EXPECT
REVENUES. TO GROW FAIRLY SLOWLY.
I'M L. A. O. D. YOU WANT TO
THAT- I'D BE TO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. SIMILAR TO. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I THINK IN OUR-
MULTI YEAR OUTLOOK WE HAVE
RELATIVELY GRADUAL APPRECIATION
IN THE STOCK MARKET CERTAINLY
THAT COULD BE. PROVEN TO BE
WRONG IT COULD BE HIGHER- YOU
COULD BE LOWER BUT WE SAT THE
BEST THE BEST ESTIMATE IS TO
KIND OF GO FROM WHERE WE ARE
AND EXT EXPECT CUTS SOME
GRADUAL APPRECIATION ONE THING
WE DID IN OUR NOVEMBER FISCAL
OUTLOOK IS ASKED A QUESTION.
HOW MUCH ADDITIONAL REVENUE
WOOD MISSTATED ORDER TO NOT
HAVE THESE STRUCTURAL. DEFICITS
EMERGE AND WHAT WE DETERMINED
IN THAT EXERCISE WAS THAT WHILE
YOU UNDOUBTEDLY WILL BE WRONG
TO SOME DEGREE AS WE TRY TO
FORECAST REVENUES BY THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT WE WOULD HAVE
ENOUGH NATURAL REVENUE GROWTH
TO ELIMINATE THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT JUST KIND OF ON THE
NATURAL. WORLD IS UNLIKELY KIND
OF OUTSIDE OF THE BEYOND THIS
YOU KNOW STANDARD DEVIATION
THAT WE WOULD EXPECT. AND
EXPECT AS AS POSSIBLE OR LIKELY-
THAT BEING SAID ONE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS WAS
TO. RETHINK THE SCAR STATUARY
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT TO SCHOOLS
AND THAT WAS A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT SO THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT WOULD BE SMALLER NOW
THAN WHAT WE WERE EXT YOU KNOW
FORECASTING IN NOVEMBER. SO AS
A RESULT OF THAT IT MIGHT BE
SOMEWHAT- MORE LIKELY THAT ARE
REVENUES WHICH OUTPERFORMED OUR
BASELINE EXPECTATIONS ENOUGH TO
ELIMINATE THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT- BUT- YOU KNOW. BY AND
LARGE I THINK- THE OTHER
COMMENTS- BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FINANCE PROBABLY ARE- IN LINE
WITH IT THE WORK THAT YOU THAT
WE WOULD HAVE AND I COULD OFFER
THEM I DON'T KNOW IF MY
COLLEAGUE BRIAN DEALER WHO
OVERSEES OUR REVENUE
FORECASTING- EFFORTS IT'S. IF
HE WOULD WANT TO ADD ANYTHING.
YEAH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
GRANULAR WITH THE ALIEN JUST
REAL QUICKLY JUST. TO GET A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT ON WHY WE
MIGHT BE EXPECTING SOMEWHAT
SLOWER ECONOMIC AND REVENUE
GROWTH FOR THE FOR THE OUT
YEARS. I THINK THE SIMPLE STORY
IS THAT WE SEEN. A LARGE KIND
OF DISLOCATION BOTH IN THE
STATE'S LABOR MARKETS AND IN
OUR- OKAY A SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND THE- WELL WE'VE
SEEN THAT. RECOVER FASTER FROM
THE DEPTHS OF THE TENDER EARLY
PANDEMIC RECESSION THAN WE
MIGHT HAVE EXPECTED THERE STILL
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE EMPLOYED
THERE STILL ARE A LOT OF.
BUSINESSES THAT ARE FACING
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE LOSSES AND
IT WILL TAKE A NUMBER OF YEARS
FOR- THOSE ARE FACTS TO CORRECT
AND FOR US TO GET BACK TO KIND
OF PRE PANDEMIC ECONOMIC LEVELS.
THANK YOU. I'M I NOTE THAT MR
PADDICK IN YOUR SLIDES YOU
REFERENCED A THAT IN THE
NOVEMBER FORECAST YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE STRUCTURAL. ACTED
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT WHICH OF
COURSE HAS BEEN REPEATED AND I
DON'T NEED AN ANSWER NOW AND IT
COULD HAVE BEEN IN THAT
DOCUMENT I CAN LOOK BACK BUT I
THINK THAT AT SOME POINT WE ARE
GOING TO WANT TO HEAR
CONCRETELY WHAT RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE MIGHT BE HAVE. TO DO OUR
BEST TO AVOID THAT STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT BUT DON'T ADDRESS THAT
NOW I'M JUST PUTTING THAT OUT
IS AND- KIND OF. NOTE I HAVE
TWO MORE QUESTIONS ONE IS THAT-
THE PROPOSAL FROM THE FROM THE
US FROM THE GOVERNOR INCLUDES A
TRUE UP. TO OUR RESERVE STORE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
AND THAT'S THREE POINT TWO
BILLION. NOW WE SUSPENDED LAST
YEAR BECAUSE OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WERE IN
FISCAL EMERGENCY AND WE MIGHT
BE IN A DEFICIT WE SUSPENDED.
PUTTING THE DEPOSIT IN. ARE WE
LEGALLY REQUIRED TO MAKE A TRUE
UP DEPOSIT IN THIS CURRENT YEAR.
MADAM CHAIR- I BELIEVE I READ
IS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE THAT
TRIP AND I AM GOING TO PASS
THIS TO POLICE EMERGENCY FOR
SOME MORE DETAILS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. RESEARCHERS INCLUDES
PART IN A FINANCE. I'M SORRY
CAN YOU HEAR OTHER YEAH- YES SO
WE ARE READING THE LAW IS THAT
IT WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE LAW AS IT
STANDS ON SO WE BELIEVE IT'S A
REASONABLE. EXPECTATION TO PUT
THE OUT THIS TRANSFER INTO THE
S. NINE AND IT'S FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION IT WAS A BILLION FOR
THE NINETEEN TWENTY TRUE UP AND
FOR THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TRUMPETS THREE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR A TOTAL OF
FOUR POINT TWO BILLION. THROAT
THIS NOTE WE HAVE NOT- WE HAVE
NOT- LIFTED THE ACTION ON A
FISCAL EMERGENCY AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO RESPOND BUT IT WOULD
SEEM TO ME THAT THE LEGAL READ
M. WOULD HAVE TO BE BASED ON.
THAT FACT THAT THE REASON WE
DID NOT HAVE TO PUT THE DEPOSIT
IN LAST YEAR'S BECAUSE WE
SUSPENDED BASED ON IF IT'S
GOING TO EMERGENCY WE'VE WE
HAVE NOT ACTED TO DISMANTLE
THAT DECLARATION BUT I'LL LEAVE
THAT AGAIN IS JUST. A POINT- I
WAS GOING TO ASK A QUESTION
ABOUT- THE- B. CARES ACT MONEY
AND THE FACT THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF IT SIX
POINT SEVEN BILLION FOR SCHOOLS
AND- JUST HOW THAT OVERLAPS
WITH WHAT THE GOVERNORS ASKING
FOR EARLY ACTION BUT I IMAGINE
OTHER MEMBERS WILL WANT TO GET
INTO THAT IN MORE DETAIL SO
I'LL LEAVE IT. AND LET THEM AND
LET ME ASK MY LAST QUESTION
WHICH IS THAT OUR- ACTION IN
JUNE ON THE BUDGET FOR THIS
CURRENT YEAR SUSPENDED SOME
PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF OUR CONCERN
THAT WE WOULD HAVE WE WOULD
HAVE INADEQUATE REVENUES AND
THESE SUSPENSIONS. IF THEY HAD
IF THEY WERE HAD ACTUALLY GONE
INTO EFFECT OR CUTS TO VERY
CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
SUCH AS BY H. S. S. OR IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES ARE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
PROVIDER PAYMENTS ARE MEDICARE
PROVIDER RATES- ON VARIOUS
THINGS LIKE THAT. ALL OF WHICH
OF COURSE DURING A PANDEMIC ARE
UNDER GREATER NEED THAN EVER-
BUT WHAT I NOTE IS THAT AT THE
SAME TIME THAT THIS WELL WE ARE
NOT ACTING OR RATHER THIS
PROPOSED BUDGET WOULD NOT
SUSPENDED PROGRAMS IT DOES
PROJECT SUSPENDING THEM IN THE
YEAR FOLLOWING HOWEVER THE
BUDGET THAT YOU AFTERWARDS
GOVERNOR'S PRESENTED ALSO
INCLUDES ESTABLISHING CAL TEAM.
WHICH I INTENDED TO RETHINK
AND ENHANCE MEDIC CAL BUT IT
HAS A SIGNIFICANT ON GOING COST
SO I WOULD LIKE TO JUST GET
FROM D. O. F. WHY DOES THE
ONGOING BUDGET STRUCTURE
SUPPORT CAL AIMED. HOWEVER
WOULD CONTINUE TO MAKE THE CUTS
TO THE CRITICAL PROGRAMS THAT I
REFERENCED. KAREN THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION MADAM CHAIR- I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT IN IN LIGHT
OF THE IMPROVE REVENUES WE DO
DELAY- THE SCUTTLED SUSPENSIONS
I THINK THEY ARE DELAYED RATHER
THAN- TAKEN OFF- THE TOP TAKEN
OFF THE TABLE BECAUSE OF THE
OPERATING DEFICIT THAT WE
FORESEE. IN THE FUTURE AND SO
THAT THEY ARE A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION AND- LIKE OTHER
THINGS- THINGS WHICH THAT THE
REVENUE PICTURE WILL CHANGE
COME MAY AND AT THE MAY
REVISION IT WILL TAKE A LOOK TO
SEE WHAT'S WHAT IS AVAILABLE-
BUT ASK YOUR SECOND POINT CAL
AMES CAL AIM IS ONE OF FEW
ONGOING EXPENDITURES THAT WE DO
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET. AND
WHAT WE SEE THIS AS SOMETHING
THAT IS REQUIRED NOW SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE ON GOING SAVINGS IN
THE FUTURE TO HELP REDUCE BOTH
INCREASE THE QUALITY AND REDUCE
THE COST. OF TAKING CARE OF
POPULATION SO THAT IS WHY YOU
SEE- KELLY. IN AS A PRIORITY IN
THIS BUDGET. CERTIFIED OR STAND
SO MY QUESTION ACTUALLY INTO
PARTS IT WAS ONE AND THAT WAS
THAT YES YOU DO DO YOU DO YOU
CONTINUE THE PROGRAM
SUSPENSIONS THERE JUST DELAYED
FOR THE MOMENT HOWEVER YOU
RECOMMEND. A BRAND NEW PROGRAM.
WITH EIGHT GF EXPENSE G. AT
HIGHS G. OF COST. AND WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THE ANSWER IS THAT
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT CAL AIMS WILL
REDUCE COSTS OVER TIME DID I.
CATCH THAT CORRECTLY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT- FIVE COURSE
LIKE ALL MEMBERS HAVE MILLIONS
MORE QUESTIONS BUT I WAS HOLD
MYSELF AND- I DID NOT START A
LIST SO LET ME SEE WHO- I SEE
MR LAYERED MISTER DALI MISTER
ROSS SO- MR AND CORTESE. OF ME
SEE IF I HAVE ANY HANDS U ON
MY- OF MY REMOTE PEOPLE. NOT
YET- SORRY MR MCGUIRE- MISTER
NIELSEN. MISTER WACO SKI. ALL
RIGHT SO WE WILL- WE WILL START.
WITH- FIVE YES AND SENATOR MEN
AND SENATOR STERN. WE'LL START
WITH SENATOR LAYERED GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE END
OF I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR
FINANCED IT YOU CAN. RESPOND TO
OFFLINE AND THAT IS A NUMBER OF
US ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
MONEY THAT IS IN THE BUDGET FOR
WILDLAND FIRE AND WE WANT TO
KNOW. FROM WHERE OUR LOCAL FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS WHETHER THEY CAN
APPLY WORDS JUST GOING THROUGH
OTHER GOVERNMENT INSTITUTIONS
AND THEY'RE AT MERCED UC AND
CAL POLY THERE'S RESEARCH ON
WILDLAND FIRE WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE SO
OFFLINE IF YOU COULD JUST LET
US KNOW WHO'S ELIGIBLE FOR THAT
MONEY OTHER THAN THAN CAL FIRE.
BUT THE QUESTIONS THAT I WANT
TO ASK MORE ABOUT EDUCATION AND
THE CHAIR JUST TEED UP MARCH
FIRST QUESTION PERFECTLY AND
THAT IS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET IN THIS IS TO
FINANCE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET THERE'S TWO
BILLION FOR SCHOOL RE OPENING
AND THEN THERE'S FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION FOR ACADEMIC SUPPORTS
WHICH AMAZINGLY ADDS UP TO SIX
POINT SIX BILLION. AND THEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM THE
CARES ACT A COUPLE OF DAYS
AFTER THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED HIS
BUDGET- ALLOCATED SIX POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS TO K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA A TO FINANCED YOU
CONTEMPLATE. OF THIS OF
PLANTING SOME OF THE MONEY THAT
YOU RECOMMENDED. FOR SCHOOLS
HOW DOES IT FIT TOGETHER. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. SENATOR AND I
STATED EARLIER- WE DID NOT-
INVISION OR INCLUDED THE
FEDERAL STIMULUS AS PART OF-
THE BASELINE FOR THE BUDGET.
BECAUSE OF TIMING AND THAT THE
TWO BILLION A FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION- SUPPORT CREATED
OBVIOUSLY NINE. I'M TIRED OF
KNOWING WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD SEND. STATES
LET ALONE SENT TO CALIFORNIA
SO- IT IN WE HAVE HEARD FROM
MANY SCHOOLS THAT THE TWO
MILLION ISN'T ENOUGH FOR THE
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION IS ISN'T
ENOUGH AND I THINK THAT AT THIS
POINT. HOW WE SEE IT IS THAT
THEY WOULD BE. COMPLEMENTARY SO
ANY DOLLARS THAT THE STATE
WOULD SPEND WOULD- ALSO BE.
SUPPORTED BY FUTURE FEDERAL
DOLLARS- AND THAT NUMBER JUST
COINCIDENCE COINCIDENTALLY IS
VERY SIMILAR BUT YOU'RE NOT
CONTEMPLATING AMENDING YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS BASED ON THIS
SIX POINT SEVEN BILLION
ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT'S COME IN
SINCE YOU PROPOSED. AGAIN I
WOULD SAY THE THIS WAY THE
VISION WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT THE
FED GOVERNMENT WOULD BE FUNDING
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
SPEND SOME TIME TO LOOK TO SEE
WHAT- RESOURCES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS PROVIDING SO THAT
WE CAN TAILOR THAT WITH OUR
PROPOSAL- NOW AND INTO THE
FUTURE WELL WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT- YOU OF ASK THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. TO DO EARLY ACTIONS
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE US UNDER
YOUR SCHEDULE TO ACT WITHIN THE
NEXT TWO OR TWO AND A HALF
WEEKS AND IT SEEMS TO US THAT
THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO HAVE. BEFORE WE
WERE ASKED TO COMMIT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS SO I HOPE YOU WOULD
JUST TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT-
THE NEXT QUESTION I HAD- FOR
FINANCE. IS THAT THERE WERE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
DEFERRALS TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
K. THROUGH TWELVE IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET AND YOU PROPOSED
PAYING OFF ROUGHLY TWO THIRDS
OF IT. OF WHAT WAS YOUR NOW
ASSISTS IN DECIDING HOW MUCH TO
PAY OFF AND NOT TO ENTIRELY PAY
OFF THE DEFERRALS. SURE AND I
THINK THAT THE IDEA WAS TO PAY
OFF AS MUCH AS WE COULD TO
SUPPORT SCHOOLS CATER FOURTEEN.
BUT ALSO TO ALLOW FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL FINES SO UNDER
PRESSURE PRIORITIES COULD BE
ADDRESSED AS WELL. AND ARE YOU
AWARE. OF DISTRICTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE DEFERRAL
PROD- PROCESS THAT. THIS MIGHT
NOT BE TAKEN CARE OF BY HOW
MUCH YOUR- RECOMMENDING THAT WE
PAY OFF IN THE DEFERRALS. I'LL
I'LL DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES IN
EDUCATION UNIT AND IN REGARDS
TO SPECIFIC CONDITIONS OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. HI YES- THIS
IS JESSICA HOMES WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION SENATOR
LAYERED. SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
TRACKING- WITH THAT WITH THE
NEW TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO DEFERRAL- THAT WOULD REALLY
REPRESENTS A JUNE TO JULY
DEFERRAL- AND WE BELIEVE THAT
BECAUSE OF THE- QUICK REPAYMENT
OF THE FUNDS THAT IT WOULD NOT
BE. OVERLY BURDENSOME FOR MOST
ELEAZAR. I'M ON THE K. TWELVE
FIVE. COULD NOT ADJUST UP IF
THERE ARE WE CONSIDER THAT THE
BUDGET PROCESS AT THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE STRUGGLING.
AND THEN IN HIGHER EDUCATION
BEFORE GET TO SCHOOL RE OPENING-
THERE IS SOME CONTEMPLATION
AND- UCCS YOU SIDE ARE WITH
EXPECTATION TO ONLINE OFFERINGS
AND THEN IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SIDE THERE SO. ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR BLOCK
GRANTS FOR ONLINE SUPPORT AND
THEY'VE HAD IN ROMAN DROPS DID
ARRANGE A DATE RANGE FROM 10%
TO THE L. A. COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO EIGHTEEN AND 20% AND OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ARE YOU
CONTEMPLATING THAT THIS
RECOMMENDATION FOR ONLINE IS TO
HELP THEM STRUGGLE WITH WHAT
HAS CAUSED OUR ENVIRONMENT
DROPS. I HAVE A QUESTION ON TO
CHRIS FERGUSON AT- WHEN MY
COLLEAGUES. SURE SENATE EARLIER
CRACK CHRIS FERGUSON WITH THE
GAS DEPARTMENT FINANCED. CHAU
THE PROPOSAL IS FOR THE UC CSU
AND PCPS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
ONLINE COURSE OFFERINGS
ABRUPTLY TEN PERCENT- TEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER THAN
THEY WERE PRE PANDEMIC. WE DO
KNOW THAT WHILE THERE ARE SOME
STUDENTS THAT HAVE STRUGGLED-
IN AN ONLINE ENVIRONMENT
OTHERS- HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
BEING IN AN ONLINE ENVIRONMENT
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT. THE
ONLINE ENVIRONMENT CAN PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR. YOU GUYS
STUDENTS WHO HAVE OTHER
FAMILIAL OBLIGATIONS OR
EMPLOYMENT OBLIGATIONS- SO
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO MAINTAIN A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF BUT WE ARE
NOT ASKING- A NECESSARILY THAT
THE COLLEGES. MAINTAIN ALL OF
THEIR COURSES ONLINE. AS WELL-AS WE DO KNOW THAT THIS ALSO
PROVIDES FOR FURTHER ACCESS-
FOR STUDENTS. A. N. N. ALSO THE
BUDGET CONTEMPLATES NO INCREASE
IN TUITION AT CSU IN. HAND YOU
SEE AND ALSO- THERE SOME
REFORMS FROM THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THAT MIGHT BETTER
GET FINANCIAL AID TO PEOPLE-
ARE DO YOU HAVE SOME CERTAINTY
WITH NO TUITION INCREASES AND
YOU HAVE A POSITION ON THE
REFORMS OF THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION ON. ON ASSISTANCE IN
THIS TOUGH TIME WITH THE
PANDEMIC. THE BUDGET OUTLINED
EXPECTATION THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY MAINTAIN THEIR-
TUITION IN BE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO ACADEMIC YEAR. AT CURRENT
LEVELS I'M SO THAT WOULD NOT BE
AN INCREASE IN TUITION FROM
THIS YEAR TO NEXT YEAR- SO
CERTAINLY I THINK THAT THAT IS
ONE OF THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE
BASE AUGMENTATIONS THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. IN REGARDS TO-
FINANCIAL AID PERFORMED I THINK
WE WERE CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT. WHAT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION IS BRINGING
FORWARD I THINK THERE'S YOU
KNOW SEVERAL COMPONENTS TO
THEIR A PROPOSAL THAT- WARRANT
FURTHER INVESTIGATION OR
UNDERSTANDING- ANOTHER
COMPONENT I WOULD ADD IS THERE
ARE RECENT CHANGES IN THE
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF BILL. THAT
ALTER THE ELIGIBILITY AND THE
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION
CALCULATIONS FOR FEDERAL PELL
GRANTS ONE OF THE UNDERPINNINGS
OF WHAT THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION HAD BEEN LOOKING AT
WHAT'S A LINING CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY WITH FEDERAL
ELIGIBILITY SO WITH THAT CHANGE
IT MAY TAKE SOME TIME TO. WORK
THROUGH THAT. AND SEE WHAT
THOSE IMPACTS WOULD BE. OKAY
THANK YOU MUCH AND THEN. ON TO
THE OTHER MAJOR TOPICS-
PROPOSAL TO REOPEN SCHOOLS AND
I WOULD JUST SAY THE GOVERNOR
SHOULD BE SALUTED FOR FORCING
THE ISSUE AND THE FACT THAT.
THERE ARE KIDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS FOR FOSTER KIDS OR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
RATHER THAN- FALLING BETWEEN
THE CRACKS OF IT WE ALL
STIPULATE THAT IN PERSON
EDUCATION IS MUCH BETTER AND SO
IT'S GOOD TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DOING THIS BUT AS WE HEARD.
FROM THE L. A. O. JUST A MOMENT
AGO- THEY SAID IN THEIR
PROPOSAL THAT THAT THEY HAD
CONCERN ABOUT ON FEASIBLE
TIMELINES ARE WITH REGARD TO
THE RE OPENING PROPOSAL AND
JUST IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS. WE'VE HAD SOME BIG
DISTRICTS INCLUDING THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED THAT SAID THEY
WILL NOT APPLY TO RE OPEN UNDER
THE EXISTING DEADLINES I KNOW
IN MY HOME COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ
IS THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
ANNOUNCED THAT NONE OF THE
DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTY FEEL
THAT THIS WORKS FOR THEM AND
THEY WILL NOT BE APPLYING. SO I
WAS GONNA ASK FINANCE GIVEN THE
L. A- SAYING THAT THEY THINK
THAT DEADLINES ARE UNREASONABLE
AND THE START OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE
SAYING THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
APPLY ARE YOU CONTEMPLATING
ADJUSTING THE DEADLINES TO MAKE
THIS PROGRAM WORK. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION AND THE
QUESTION THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
QUITE A QUITE A BIT LATELY- I
THINK THE TIMING OF IT IS
OBVIOUSLY TO GET. KIDS BACK
INTO SCHOOL TEACHERS BACK IN
THE SCHOOL PRIOR TO THE END OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR AND ULTIMATELY-
HAVE. HAVE SIGNIFICANT TIME IN
THE CLASSROOM- BUT IN REGARDS
TO- THE ACTUAL TIMING OF THAT
THAT'S ALL I WILL PASS THAT
QUESTION TO JESSICA HOLMES. THE
WHOLE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
WE'VE RECEIVED FEEDBACK FROM
MANY MANY ALLIGATORS YOU CAN
IMAGINE ON THE PROPOSAL. AND I
THINK THAT THE FEASIBILITY
QUESTION AND IT'S REALLY
DEPENDENT UPON THE DISTRICT.
HOWEVER I WOULD ALSO BECAUSE IT
THAT FIRST TIME I THINK WHO ARE
PLANNING ON NOT APPLYING IT AND
NOT AS MUCH OF THE TIME LINE
ISSUE AS THERE ARE SOME OTHER
ISSUES THAT THOSE DISTRICTS ARE
FACING AND WE'RE CERTAINLY-
TALKED WITH THEM TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT THEIR
CONCERNS ARE. BUT BUT IN TERMS
OF PINING WE DO HAVE TWO
OPTIONS FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT ONE
OF AN APPLICATION BY FEBRUARY
FIRST THE OTHER THING
APPLICATION BY MARCH FIRST IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT IT
WILL TAKE. A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME TO GET THE THINGS IN PLACE
THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
REOPEN. I THINK THE OTHER THING
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS.
YOU KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT
MONEY ENSURE THAT FOLKS ARE
OPEN FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION-
YOU KNOW. NOT ONLY IN THE
FISCAL YEAR BUT IN THE FALL.
THAT NEITHER EARLY AGE REALLY
NEED TO START MAKING THOSE
PLANS AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO NOW-
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
DEPEND ON MAKING GOING TO IT'S
GOING WE'RE GONNA BE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE VALUES ARE PREPARED
WELL SO WE ARE ALL. I'M HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FOLKS
WHO REACHED OUT TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERN BUT
ALSO TO ENCOURAGE THEM. BACKING
A REGARDLESS OF WHEN YOU THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO RE OPEN NOW
IT'S TIME TO START PLANNING FOR
THAT TO ENSURE THAT KIDS CAN
ACT WITH THAT. YOU KNOW IN THE
CURRENT YEAR IN THE FALL. BUT
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL JUST. A
CONTEMPLATES RE OPENING IN THE
NEXT TWO MONTHS AND- ISN'T
NECESSARILY REWARDING PEOPLE
THAT MIGHT BE MAKING SURE THEY
RE OPEN IN THE FALL AND I
THINK. ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT'S COME UP. IS THAT.
TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WANT TO BE VACCINATED
BEFORE THEY GO IN THE
CLASSROOM. AND RIGHT NOW THE
SCHEDULE DOESN'T SYNC UP
TOTALLY WITH THE ABILITY TO BE
VACCINATED. SO IF THESE
TIMELINE SLIP TO MAKE SURE THAT
SCHOOLS DO IT IT ALSO ALLOWS.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE FOR IRAQ.
AND THAT IS VERY AND- JUST SO
THE I DON'T. THIS ONE LINE
QUESTION. AND THEN THAT HAS TO
DO WITH THE TIME LINES THAT YOU
JUST SAID BECAUSE ANECDOTALLY.
IT APPEARS THAT SCHOOLS THAT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO APPLY RIGHT
AWAY. OR MORE WELL TO DO FOR
AFFLUENT AND A LOT OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT REPRESENT
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS OR OR
REPORT DISTRICTS. OR THE ONE
THAT THEIR FARTHER BACK IN LINE
AND WOULD GET LESS MONEY UNDER
THE CURRENT THINGS EVEN IF THE
DEADLINES HOLD. THE GOVERNOR
SAID AT HIS PRESS CONFERENCE
THAT HE WANTS TO MAKE SURE.
NOBODY IS DISADVANTAGED BASED
ON THEIR ECONOMIC STATUS AS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THIS
PROCESS. HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT'S TRUE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING. SO AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND I AND
I THINK- WHAT THE GOVERNOR WAS
REFERRING TO AND WHAT WE HAVE
DONE. BUILT INTO THE LANGUAGE
AROUND. IS REALLY AROUND AND
COUNTY FOR THEIR HIGHER RATE
THE TRANSMISSION SO CURRENTLY-
COOL CAN OPEN. FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IF THEY'RE ABOVE A
CERTAIN AGE- TRANSMISSION LEVEL
IN THEIR IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- AND THAT WOULD
BRING THAT WOULD REMAIN UNDER A
PROPOSAL FOR COUNTIES AND WILL
TELL YOU CN COUNTY THAT ARE
ABOUT TWENTY PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOWEVER- WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING IS THAT THOSE. COULD
APPLY FOR THE FUNDING-
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE ABLE TO REOPEN- IN IN
THE SPRING AND USE THOSE FUNDS
TO HELP THEM IN THE FALL- IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
MANY OF OUR ALLEVIATE THAT ARE
SERVING OR ARE LOOKING TO
COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO IN AREAS
WHERE TRANSMISSION RATES ARE
HIGHEST. SACRAMENTO. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. ON INJURY IN
THE FUNDING AS WELL TO PUT
THEMSELVES IN THE BACK OF THE
TO RIO. YOU IF THAT MEANS THEY
ARE REAL SEVERAL MONTHS INTO
THE FUTURE. SO THERE IS THAT-
BACKS ALLOW WITH THE LANGUAGE.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER
OF THE QUESTION AND IT JUST
REFLECTS. SORT OF A MENU OF BIG
CONCERNS WE HAVE ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND GOD. YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING NEXT WEEK TO GO INTO
MORE DETAIL SO LET ME I'M GOING
TO TURN TO OUR VICE CHAIR
SENATOR NIELSEN I SHOULD HAVE
TURNED HIM IN AND- LET ME LET
HIM ASK SOME QUESTIONS AND THEN
I'LL I'LL TELL YOU I'VE GOT ON
THE LIST- MISTER ALSO MISTER
DALI MISTER CORTESE MISTER
MCGUIRE MR MAKOWSKI SENATOR MEN
SENATOR STERN AND SENATOR
RICHMOND HAD CENTERED EMAIL
SINCE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND FIRST THIS BILL QUESTION TO
FINANCE. NOTHING MUCH HAS BEEN
SAID ABOUT THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT THE
BUCKLE. AT THIS IS A MASSIVE
HISTORIC CONSEQUENCE. AND FOR
EXAMPLE WE ARE PROVIDING SOME
MONEY TO. HURT CALIFORNIANS I
THINK SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS IS
PROPOSED. YOU KNOW THAT'S GOING
TO BE HELPFUL BUT ONE THING
THAT CERTAINLY WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO THE CANS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
AGREED TO BY THE INABILITY OF
EDT TO DO ITS JOB.
NOTWITHSTANDING WHATEVER HAS
BEEN ATTEMPTED SO FAR. I DIDN'T
SAY DONE I SAID IT KEPT IT. TO
FIX THAT DEPARTMENT WE ARE
STILL GETTING THE ALMOST THE
SAME VOLUME OF COMPLAINTS FROM
OUR CITIZENS. AND UNEMPLOYMENT.
IS SOMETHING THAT IS A DIRECT
AMOUNT OF MONEY INTO THE
POCKETS. BUT MAYBE CALIFORNIANS.
AND DEPENDING ON FEDERAL HELP.
IT'S KIND OF A HOLLOW PROMISE
SO THE QUESTION TO FINANCE WHAT.
KIND OF CHANGES BY BEING
PROPOSED. WITHIN EIGHTY DAYS.
HELLO THIS SPECIFICALLY GIVEN
EXAMPLE WHAT'S PROVOKED A LOT
OF MY ANGST HERE. EARLY ON THE-
REMEDY WAS TO TRANSFER NOW FROM
OTHER AGENCIES AND TO. EIGHTY
DATE. BUT THAT DIDN'T HELP MUCH
BECAUSE THEY FOUND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAD TO BE TRAINED.
AND TO TRAIN THEM. THEY HAD TO
TAKETHE INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK
TRAINED OFF THEIR DUTY. THE
BILL TRYING. THAT HAS CERTAINLY
BEEN A FRUSTRATION TELL TO THE
QUESTION THAT WHAT WHAT KIND OF
CHANGES TOP TO BOTTOM IN THAT
ORGANIZATION. ARE GOING TO BE
PROPOSED. AND I SUGGEST THAT WE
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD IN OUR
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS. MAKE THE
MORE SPECIFIC IN ALL AREAS. OF
SPENDING PLEASE. FINANCE THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR
NIELSEN AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
PAIN POINT FOR MANY MANY PEOPLE
AND A SERIOUS ONE AT THAT- TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE. THANKS OF
YOUR QUESTION. WELL IT WAS
OVERWHELMING AND I THINK THAT
EDT AND UNEXPECTED- THERE WERE
A LOT OF THINGS THAT WERE DONE
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO BEEF UP
THE U. I. PROGRAM INCLUDING THE
REDIRECTION OF RESOURCES AS YOU
MENTIONED INCLUDING HIRING- AND
BORROWING OF SMOKE FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS- THE EXPANSION OF
THE CALL CENTER HOURS EXPANSION
OF CALL CENTER DAYS AND I'M
STILL THERE THERE'S A WAITLIST
SO UNDERSTANDABLY THIS IS A- IT
WAS A DIFFICULT SITUATION. AND
NO EXCUSES BUT THE WORKLOAD WAS
CRASHING- SINCE THEN THERE HAVE
BEEN- THERE'S A FRAUD- HONESTLY
IN IN THE PEE WEE PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THAT IT'S STRUCTURED- AND THERE
HAS BEEN MEDIATED MANY
MITIGATING- EFFORTS PUT INTO
PLACE TO CHECK AND VERIFY IDEA
FRONT AND VERSUS HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THAT ON THE BACK AND ON
THE BACK AND WE ALSO HAVE HELLO
YES AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ATTEMPTING TO INVESTIGATE AND
PROSECUTE- BASICALLY THOSE WHO
ARE ABLE TO DO. THE SYSTEM- AND
IN REGARDS TO POTENTIAL R. OR
SORRY PERSPECTIVE RESOURCES-
THE BUDGET DOES INCLUDE A JUDGE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
RESOURCES- BUT THERE ARE THERE
ARE ISSUES THAT AS THE NEW
DIRECTOR- IS FACED WITH AND I
THINK AS SHE ENTERS- THAT THAT
POSITION MORE CONVERSATIONS
NEED TO HAPPEN WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION IN REGARDS TO.
THE RESOURCES THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY- OBVIOUSLY THEIR I.
T. SYSTEM IT WAS- HAVE HAMPERED
PROGRESS AS WELL AND SO- THE
GODS STREET TEAM THAT LOOKED AT
THEIR FUNCTIONS OF PROGRESS-
AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF NINETY
SYSTEM- PUT A PRICE ON THAT FOR
NOW SO THAT THEY COULD DEAL
WITH THE CURRENT PROBLEMS BUT
MORE OBVIOUSLY NEEDS TO BE DONE
BOTH ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THEIR I. T. SYSTEM AS WELL AS
ON THE PROGRAM SITE AND THE
MANAGEMENT OF. THE OF THE
PROGRAM ITSELF BUT WE LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE HAVING KIND. WE
KNOW IT'S GOING TO UP-
LEGISLATURE. DETERMINED BILLS-
ARE BEING. AND SOME OF THE THAT
ARE PROPOSED. THE MEDIA IS
ALREADY ATTEMPTING TO DO SO AS
TO RUN- ALLEGED. LIST AGAIN.
THE CROSS CROSS- DOES DOUBLE
CHECK A INELIGIBLE SUCH. IN MAY
POPULATE- SO THINGS ARE BEING-DONE IN REAL TIME BUT OBVIOUSLY
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE. WELL
WHAT I'M ASKING OF DVD THEN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS TO PROVIDE
OUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES. THERE
OR THEY HAVE. R. PONDRE I THINK
IT'LL BE PRO WANT TO BUT SAID
SOME VERY SPECIFIC PLANS NOT
GENERALIZATIONS BUT VERY
SPECIFIC PLANS. FOR EXAMPLE ONE
OF THE GREATEST OUTRAGES OF THE
CITIZENS HAS BEEN FINDING OUT
THE INMATES IN PRISONS WERE
BEING SOUGHT OUT. AND PROVIDED.
CHECKS ONE DAY THAT CITIZENS
COULD NOT EVEN CONTACT ANYBODY
AB DE. THAT WILL TRANSITION
EIGHT TO THAN OTHER POINT WHICH
HELP BRING IN THAT'S MORE BROAD
THE NEEDY BUT A FLEXIBLE TO IT
MOST ASSUREDLY AND THAT IS. I.
T. THE OFFICE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY BEEN AROUND A LONG
TIME AND THE ONLY BIG THING
IT'S DONE OVER THE YEARS IN MY
OPINION IS CHANGES NAY. BUT TO
REALLY. GET CALIFORNIA WHAT WE
CAN HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WORKS OF
APPLYING NEW TECHNOLOGY. WE'RE
THE LAUGHING STOCK OF AMERICA.
HARDLY ANY OF OUR MAJOR
PROJECTS AND IT LOOKS LIKE
THAT'S WHERE FISCALES HEADED
NOW. COME IN ON BUDGET. BORON
TIME. SO WHAT WILL THE
GOVERNOR'S. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE PROVIDING US WITH
SUGGESTIONS OF HOW WE'RE GOING
TO IMPROVE THE EXCESSIVE
EXTRAVAGANCE. BUT VIçT IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
APPLICATIONS IN ATV. YES THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- AT A
HIGH LEVEL- THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY- THAT HAD THEIR
RESOURCES IN THE BUDGET TO
CONTINUE TO BEEF UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN
REGARDS TO ITS OVERSIGHT- OF-
I. T. PROJECTS AND- YOU'RE
RIGHT IT OFTENTIMES- THE
DEPARTMENT HAS HAD TO COMMENT
ON THE BACK END. AND- HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS CLEAN UP CERTAIN I.
T- EFFORTS. AND THIS PROPOSAL
REALLY LOOKING TO PROVIDE FOR
PREVENTATIVE. ADVISORY UP FRONT
SO THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY CAN PROVIDE ITS
EXPERTISE TO DEPARTMENTS AND
THEIR IT AND BUSINESS-
INDIVIDUALS TO BUILD TO PLAN TO
BUILD OUT- BETTER TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL PROVIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
REALLY- GET TO WHAT WE DON'T
CARE ABOUT IS THE PROGRAMS- AND
IF IN CASES WHERE THERE ARE
BENEFICIARIES THAT BENEFITS
ARE. ARE TIMELY AND ACCURATELY
LIKE IN IN EDIE'S CASE- PROVIDE
SO I WOULD TURN OVER THIS
QUESTION TO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR MORE SPECIFIC
DETAILS IN REGARDS TO WHAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET FOR. THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS EVELYN
SEES FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE BUDGET PROPOSES ELEVEN
POINT FOUR MILLION IN- GENERAL
FUND- BUT TOWARDS. CDPS EFFORT
TO TARGET CRITICAL SERVICES-
DAY WOULD PERFORM ASSESSMENTS
OF VITAL AND AT RISK SERVICES-
DEVELOP REPORT CARDS JUST- DR
INTERVENTIONS AND IMPROVEMENTS
AND IDENTIFY KEY SAFE
SAFEGUARDS- BELIEVES THAT.
THESE RESEARCH ARE ASKED AND
WOULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE-
CURRENT- EFFORTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO HELP. WITH THESE
DEPARTMENTS. WELL I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU WOULD THE
CONTACT MY OFFICE AND LET'S
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE MORE
SPECIFIC ELEMENTS OF WHAT THIS
IS GOING TO BE. MY FUNDAMENTAL
POINT AND IT FLIES TO ALL
AGENCIES IT IS THE LEGISLATURE
CANNOT BE PASSING THIS BUDGET.
AND NOT BE VERY INSTRUCTIVE AND
EXPLICITLY SO IF YOU WILL
MANDATING OF THE ADMINISTRATION
TO DO THIS THAT OR THE OTHER
THING IN OTHER WORDS I DON'T
WANT TO GIVE A BUNCH OF MONEY
FOR FIRE. PREVENTION AND LET
THE AGENCIES FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SPEND. WE FOUND THAT THAT DID
NOT WORK WHEN WE HAD THE FIRE
TAX YEARS AGO. THE MONEY DIDN'T
GO WHERE IT SHOULD HAVE. IT WAS
A FAILURE. IT WAS NOT RENEWED
BECAUSE IT WAS A FAVORITE WE DO
A LOT OF IN THAT PATH AGAIN SO-
LET'S JUST TRY TO GET BACK AND
TALK SOME VERY SPECIFICS ABOUT
THIS SO WE CAN DEAL WITH THAT
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO MORE
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO TAKE
TOO MUCH OF. ALL THE OTHER
MEMBERS TIME I MAY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS LATER THE- LET'S TALK
ABOUT EDUCATION JUST A MINUTE
NOW. IT WAS A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TALKING
ABOUT DISTANT EDUCATION. AND
FOR SOME OF OUR CILDREN THAT'S
GOOD FOR SOME OF OUR CHILDREN
THAT'S BAD. WHAT I'VE HEARD. IS
THAT FOR MOST CHILDREN IT'S BAD.
AND AT LEAST WE SHOULD BE
GETTING BACK INTO OUR SCHOOL
FACILITIES AS SOON AS WE CAN
AND CERTAINLY THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS IN CVS DOMINATING
IN THE HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN
IS MOST IMPORTANT. BUT I DON'T
THINK DISTANCE LEARNING IS THE
WAY WE NEED TO GO IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE ARE A CONSTRAINT AS MUCH
AS WE CAN. FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THIS DISTANT LEARNING
I WOULD IMAGINE IS GOING TO
REQUIRE SOME CAPITAL OUTLAY
EXPENDITURES. FOR NECESSARY
EQUIPMENT. CAN ANYONE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TELL ME
HOW THAT IS BEING PLANNED TO BE
ACCOMMODATED AND PROVIDED.
MEETING RESOURCES. FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING. BUT THEN ANOTHER
SPECIFIC QUESTION AND NOW THIS
WEEK TO THE SPECIFIC OTHER
QUESTION IS IT YOUR PLAN THAT
SCHOOLS TRANSITION NOW FROM IN
CLASSROOM LEARNING. THE
DISTANCE LEARNING FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS. I'M SURE THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR-
NIELSEN- THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION THAT WE ARE PROPOSING-
COULD GO TOWARDS SCHOOLS- THAT
WANT TO PAY FOR EXAMPLE MOVED
INTO ANOTHER CLASSROOM SO IT'S
NOT QUITE THE CAPORALI QUESTION
THAT YOU ASKED BUT THAT IT
SUPPORTS MORE CREATIVE AND
DIFFERENT KINDS OF- CLASSROOM
STRUCTURES- THAN CURRENTLY
EXIST SO THERE'S THAT- IN
REGARDS TO CAPITAL OUTLAY AND
I'LL TURN IT TO WHEN MY
COLLEAGUES TO SEE WHAT IS
INCLUDED IN IN REGARDS TO THE
OVERALL CAPITAL OUTLAY. THANK
YOU. AT IMAGE HOME DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- YOU THINK YOU
SENATOR NEAL SO- THE- FIVE
THREE BILLION THAT WE- AND ROCK.
FUNDS IN THE TWENTY BUDGET ACT
AS WELL AS THE ONE FROM ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION WENT OUT
AFTER. AND SCHOOLS AND TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT ALL AVAILABLE
FOR SCHOOL TWO YEARS- FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING COMPUTERS-
CONNECTIVITY ALL OF THAT. IN
ADDITION AND TO BE SCHOOLS WILL
BE RECEIVING ANOTHER- SIX
BILLION DOLLARS AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THAT PROCESS
PRETTY QUICKLY HERE. AND IN THE
SECOND ROUND AFTER- THAT CAN BE
USED FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
CLASSES WHILE. I'M IN TERMS OF
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT AND WE ARE. AIMING IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION THE FALL AT
THIS POINT YES WE ARE SPINNING.
AND THAT WILL BE TRANSITIONING
TO AN IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
MODEL AND THE FALL HOWEVER WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE SITUATION
RIGHT NOW IS REALLY FLUID.
NEUBERGER MONITORING
TRANSMISSION RATES AS WELL AS-
YEAH THE PROGRESS ON THINGS
LIKE VACCINATION- AND THAT YOU.
COMPLIANCE WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND ALL OF THAT I'M
AS WE AS WE LOOK. AT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AT ALL. THE
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THE THAT
DISTANCE LEARNING HAS OTHER TOP.
THOUGH EEDED. FOR A- ARE
SCHOOL MEALS PRO. PRACTICES AND
LUNCH. INCLUDED TO KNOW ABOUT
THAT SO. THAT IS NOT A QUESTION
THAT'S JUST AN OBSERVATION
MANAGER ALL DIFFICULT TO ONE
MORE FOR NOW AND THEN I'LL
YIELD MAYBE I'LL HAVE SOME MORE
LATER. ABOUT TO. I'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT THE IMMUNIZATION.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE.
TERRIFYING AND ELEMENT OF HOPE
DYNAMIC THROUGHOUT OUR LAND
TODAY. THE RORY BENSON PROBLEMS
IN CALIFORNIA. AT ANOTHER STAGE
BIGGER PROBLEMS EVEN. AS YOU
SUBMIT THE BUDGET THIS YEAR
FINANCE WILL YOU BE PRESENTING
US A PLAN FOR THE DISTRIBUTION.
AND THE STORAGE. OF THESE VERY
NEEDED IMMUNIZATIONS. YES THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- I WAS
THE VACCINES ARE TOP. AND OTHER
MORE- DETAILED QUESTIONS- I'M
GONNA TURN THIS OVER TO RYAN
MILLER. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON RYAN MILLER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YEAH I
THINK I THINK THAT- IN THE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION CLEARLY IS-
KIND OF MOVING- AS QUICKLY AS
WE CAN TO CHANGE- THE GUIDANCE
THAT WE'VE OFFERED TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE MORE FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT WE DON'T WASTE VACCINES
AND YOU KNOW YOU'VE YOU'VE
LIKELY SEEN NEWS THIS WEEK
ABOUT- YOU KNOW THE SORT OF
MEGA CENTERS LIKE FOR EXAMPLE A
DODGER STADIUM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SET UP WITH FOR
COUNTIES AND- AND- WE'VE BEEN
IN CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH
THEM- ENTER. OF- A OF A- YEAH I
THINK- THIS IS KIND OF
OCCURRING NOW AND SO- YOU KNOW
I WE WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
ENGAGE I THINK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WAS STAFF MEMBERS I
KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN. A
BRIEFING CALLS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT- TRYING TO BALANCE THAT-
YOU KNOW CLEARLY WITH THE
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE TO. TRY TO GET THE
VACCINES OUT AND YOU KNOW AS
THE GOVERNOR WOULD STAY OUT OF
THE FREEZERS AND INTO PEOPLE'S
ARMS- SO YOU KNOW BAPPI
DISPENSARY FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
BUT- IN TERMS OF THE OF THE
PROPOSAL- YEAH I DON'T I DON'T
THINK THAT WOULD HAVE A
PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET. THAT
NECESSARILY. WELL WILL BE
KNOCKING ON YOUR DOORS AS WE
PROCEED. I'M NOT WILLING TO
VOTE FOR SUBSTANTIAL MONIES FOR
THIS WITHOUT A PLAN. ACTUALLY
FOR MOST. ALL OF THIS. WITHOUT
A PLAN. SO FUND. WE'RE GONNA TO
BE A LOT MORE SPACE. AS BUDGET
PROGRESS. AND ANOTHER ISSUE IS
THAT THERE JUST ISN'T TRUST. NO
TRUST IN THE AGENCIES AND PER.
AMONGST THE PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE
TO REPRESENT AND DEAL WITH THEM
HERE THEIR FLIGHT OUT THERE.
THEY ARE IN TROUBLE THEY ARE
UNHAPPY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I'LL PROBABLY COME BACK A
LITTLE LATER FOR SOME MORE
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON WILL
NOW TURN TO SENATOR DRAWS SO
AND MEMBERS I THINK I'VE
CAPTURED ALL THOSE WHO HAD
THEIR HANDS UP IN YOUR ON THE
LIST SO- WE WILL PROCEED GO
AHEAD SENATOR DERISIVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT OVERALL I APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR- MAKING AS A
GENERAL PRIORITY HOW TO RESPOND
TO THE PARTICULAR NEEDS OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN HARDEST HIT- AND IT'S
KNOWLEDGES THAT THE RECOVERY
HAS BEEN UNEQUAL- THAT'S A-
TRUE IN DISTRICTS LIKE MY OWN.
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THINGS
LIKE THE E. I. T. C. A AND A
FEW OTHER THINGS ARE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THAT POINT-%
LOW PAID WORKERS WORKING IN-
CRITICAL ECONOMIC SECTORS LIKE
AGRICULTURE ENVIRONMENT AND
HOSPITALITY AND SERVICES HARD
HIT. FOR MANY OF THEM THERE'S
NO SAFETY NET. THE MAJORITY ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THESE LOW
PAID JOBS- PLAN IMPLIED BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T WORK FROM HOME-
HARDEST HIT BECAUSE THEIR
CHILDREN DIDN'T HAVE THE
CONNECTIVITY IN THE DEVICES-
AND THEN MY PARTICULAR- THERE
ARE SAID TO BE ONE OUT OF THREE
EVENTUALLY KNOWS. WHO ARE
POSITIVE. HOMELESSNESS GROWING
ENORMOUSLY AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS. OF RENTERS WHO RUN
THE RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
BUT THERE'S ONE IN PARTICULAR
ONE GROUP IN PARTICULAR- THAT
WORRIES ME THE MOST AND MANY OF
US THE MOST AND THAT IS OUR
SENIORS. MOST VULNERABLE WHEN
THEY CAME TO THE PANDEMIC MOST
VULNERABLE WHEN IT COMES TO
THEIR LEVEL OF POVERTY. AND
MOST VULNERABLE IF THEY ARE
UNDOCUMENTED- IN C. JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY. THE GOVERNOR HAD
IN THE PROPOSED INCLUDING
MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS THAT LOW
INCOME UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS WHO
HAVE BEEN. CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
ECONOMY AND TO OUR STATE FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND- BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC THAT WAS TAKEN OFF
THE TABLE. AW AND SO MY
QUESTION IS BECAUSE OF THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC IN
PARTICULAR ON SENIORS- HOW DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION EXPLAIN
LEAVING THESE VULNERABLE. THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THOUSAND
ACROSS THE STATE WITH OUR
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. OF AND
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CONCERN FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND BECAUSE WE HAD-
HE HAD MADE THE COMMITMENT TO
THIS EXPANSION TO INCLUDE THEM
UP PRIOR I UNDERSTAND AND I
SOMEWHAT EXPECTED I DON'T MEAN
TO PUT WORDS IN ANYBODY'S MOUTH
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT-
I DO EXPECT THAT IT'LL BE THAT
UP COMMITMENT TO. ON GOING
EXPENSES IS NOT SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE DOING THAT SAID REP
CENTER BUT THERE ARE AS I
UNDERSTOOD. ONE POINT THREE
EIGHT. BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
ERA- THE NEW EXPENDITURES
ONGOING NOT ONE TIME. SO I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO HEAR FROM.
A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND OR-
R. LA- TO. EXPLAIN THAT- ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR- YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK
THAT SOME OF WHERE WE COME FROM
IS TO MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR THE FOR THE
BUDGET AND I'M GOING- PROPOSALS
ARE DIFFICULT- AT THIS TIME
DESPITE HAVING A SURPLUS IT IS
ONE TIME AND WE ARE LOOKING FOR
MORE ONE TIME- INVESTMENT- AND
I. SAID THE GOVERNOR'S BY IS
THE STARTING POINT FOR
CONVERSATIONS- WE WANT TO
ENGAGE THE LEGISLATURE ON YOUR
PRIORITIES AND DISCUSS- AND
COME TO UNDERSTANDING. AND
AGREEMENT AT THE END- THAT
REFLECTS- OUR OVERALL-
PRIORITIES SO- THAT IS MARGIN
STATE I THINK BUT- IN LINE WITH
WHAT YOU SAID IT THIS IS NOT IS
A NEW. AND THERE WILL BE BACK
IN AND I'M THEIR MANY. THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO- SUPPORT THAT WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO SUPPORT AT THIS
POINT. WELL I THINK IT A MATTER
OF WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE AND
I UNDERSTAND SO I THINK THE
QUESTION THE CONVERSATION WILL
BE ABOUT- WHAT ARE THE- WHAT
MAKES YOU DECIDE THAT CERTAIN
THINGS ARE PRIORITY OVER
SOMETHING ELSE LIKE I SAID
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO. OUR
SENIORS- WHO NEED THAT
PREVENTATIVE PRIMARY CARE SO
THAT THEY AREN'T THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND HIT THE HARDEST-
I THINK ANOTHER AREA THAT THE-
PLAN MINISTRATIONS- PROPOSAL-
IS- EMPHASIZING IS JOB
CREATION. AND I JUST WANT TO GO
TO THE ISSUE OF THE CHALCONE
PETE'S TAX CREDIT- EXPANSION-
IT YOU KNOW IT MIGHT. UNDER IS
OF RECENT KALKA BEATS TAX
CREDIT RECIPIENTS ARE HIGHLY
CAPITALIZED COMPANIES SUCH AS
LUCID MOTORS HONDA NORTHRUP.
GRUMMOND THAT DON'T NECESSARILY
NEED THE MONEY. SO HOW DO WE
TARGET OR PRIORITIZE A TAX
CREDIT FOR COMPANIES FOR
EXAMPLE THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH
LAYOFFS AND THEREFORE. THEY
WOULD BE BRINGING BACK WORKERS
OR COMPANIES THAT ARE COMMITTED
TO GOOD PAYING JOBS BECAUSE
LORD KNOWS THAT IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE. MILLIONS OF LITTLE.
PAID NO WAY PAID JOBS AND THAT
DOESN'T OUR ANY GOOD WHAT'S- WE
HAVE TO A- BIG YOU KNOW THE OUT
HOW TO SUBS. THE EMPLOYER IN
THOSE CASES- SO I ONE- TO THE
IF YOU COULD ADD THAT. HOW DO
WE SURE THAT THESE TAX CREDIT
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING TO EXPAND
IT- FOUR TO A HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS. HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO DO SOME GOOD. WITH
THOSE TAX DOLLARS. YES AND AS
YOU MENTIONED THE CAL COMPETE
EXPANSION IS FOUR NINETY
MILLION IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
ANOTHER NINETY MILLION BUDGET
YEAR THERE'S ALSO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION AND A NEW GRANTS
PROGRAM THROUGH CAL COMPETE.
THAT SHOULD REALLY OPEN UP THE
FIELD SO THAT MORE BUSINESSES
THAT WOULD NOT OTHERWISE NOT
HAVE APPLIED- CAN IT NOW
BECAUSE THESE OF THE STATE THEY
HAD LITTLE TAX PLAY- AMONG
THINGS AND SO THE IDEA IS TO-
REALLY X. THE CREDITS AND THE
GRANTS THAT ARE- OUT THERE SO
THAT. BUSINESS CANNOT TO SUCH A
YOU MIGHT YOU- WHO MAKE ARE THE
SMALLER- ALL ARE MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES- BUT FOR MORE DETAIL
I LIKE TO TURN. OVER TO. MY
COLLEAGUE AT- CLINTON CUT
MCALLEN. RIGHT ON OF FINANCE- I
THINK. THERE TWO COMPONENTS THE
CHARACTER EACH THEIR BEEN NO
TAX CREDIT- THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING TO IS I THINK THAT
JUST OUT. IN THE GRANT COMPOSED-
KHALKHIN HE SAID BOTH THESE
HAVE PROPOSED ARE STE OR-
EXPAND. AND- RETAINING BUSINESS
AND HOW AND ALSO TO. COUNCIL
YEAH AND I CAN TALKING GENERAL
IS INTEREST IN THE SABBING A
CREATING MORTGAGE JOB- IN THE
NEXT IS COME TO MAKING THAT
WORK- MOVING FORWARD AS A- I
THINK I WOULD ALSO OUT THERE A
COUPLE- TAX CREDITS TO. THE
MEANS SMALL BUSINESS TAX. THAT
I THINK- OUR MORAL TO CERTAIN
YOUR POINT HERE ABOUT THE THAT
HAD THE FOLKS OFF OR EXPAND TO
REACH FOLKS. WE ALSO HAVE A ONE
POINT ONE TO IN SMALL BUSINESS
THAT ARE OUT- IN CAN GIO WITH
ALL THE RECENT FEDERAL RELIEF
ABOUT- PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO
THE TV. PRO IN THE TYPES OF THE
SO I THINK THAT THEY'RE TALKING
HE DEFINITELY OF ANY. SORT OF
RECOVERY TOOL- WHERE AS SOME OF
THE DEGREE. AND OTHER PRO THAT
ARE AND- ARE TRYING PROVIDE AN
RELIEF TO THOSE BUSINESSES-
MOST IN- YEAH AND I AM SIX. BE
IN A MY- MANY YEARS A
EXPERIENCE ON THESE ISSUE-
UNLESS WE HAVE SOME VERY STE.
REQUIRE FOR THE GOOD JOB
CREATION. IN THE CONTRACTS WITH
THE STATE. OR IN A- FOR SUB.
IT'S REALLY DIFFER TO- YOU JUST
VERY BROAD SAY. WELL WE'RE
GOING TO GOOD JOBS THAT DOESN'T
MEAN ANYTHING. ON IT IS MORE
SPECIFIC- AND UNLESS WE SAY
THIS IS WHAT'S EXPECTED QUALITY
TRAINING HIRING EQUITY FOR
EXAMPLE- YOU KNOW WHAT WE-
MAKING SURE WE KNOW THAT THEIR
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES. IN WHICH-
LIKE THE TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
WHERE IT IS- PREDOMINANTLY
ESPECIALLY AS YOU GET HIGHER UP
THE RANKS WHY AND MALE. ALL
WELL HOW DO WE BREAK THROUGH
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMPANIES THAT WE'RE GIVING OUR
TAX DOLLARS TO. REALLY ARE
RESPECTING EQUITY REALLY
RESPECTING DIVERSITY WHEN IT
COMES TO A JOB A CAREER THAT
PAYS WELL. WE KNOW THAT THE
LOWER THE ON THE TOTEM POLE THE
DARKER THE SKIN THE LOWER THE
PAY. THAT'S VERY COMMON IN A
LOT OF A LOT OF THESE COMPANIES
AND JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT OUR TAX DOLLAR ARE USED
FOR REAL RECOVERY. WE TALK
ABOUT THE POVERTY WE TALK ABOUT-
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES BUT HOW
DO WE USE OUR TAX DOLLARS MAKES
ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
WORLD- AND I. INTEND TO- AT THE-
PROPOSAL- ON A COW. JOBS WE I
REALLY WOULD- J. ONE WORKER THE
ADMIN- TWENTY CORP INTO THE
FRAY. WHETHER IT'S A- US
SPECIALLY GROUND- IN THE
ALLOCATE PRODUCT UP. TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR- ARE YOU. ALL
FOUR WERE. BOB GOOD JOB
CREATION- SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE ON THAT
BUT THE. DEPARTMENT FOR. YES I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT IN SOME AND
THEN CAL COMPUTER THERE ARE
SOME SPECIFIC- REQUIREMENTS IN
REGARDS TO JOB CREATION- BUT
YOU'RE- IN THAT THE I IS TO
REALLY- RELIEF TO BUSINESSES
THAT NEED IT AND I WOULD JUST
ECHO MY WHO MENTIONED THE SWEET
WE HAVE A SUITE OF PROPOSAL- A
SOME OF WHICH MORE TAILORED HIS
SMALL BUSINESS- OPENED
DEFINITELY HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN REGARDS TO EQUITY-
AND REALLY PROVIDING THE
SUPPORT THAT THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED.
REALLY NEED THANK YOU AND JUST.
MY LAST. COMMENT MORE THAN ANY
I I'D KNOW MY CALL FROM SO CRUZ.
OF TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE AGE
OF. I EVER A LOT HOW THE
FUNDING FOR THE- VERY FIRST OR-
FIRST. TO INCENTIVIZE. OF
PROPOSALS FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR YOUTH TO. GO BACK TO- IN
PERSON LEARNING- BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT ARE. ALL
WE'RE DOING THERE IS ADVANCING
THE MONEY WE'RE NOT REALLY
ADDING TO THE POT OF MONEY- AND
WHAT OUR SCHOOLS NEED- THEY
WANT TO OPEN UP. OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ONE OPEN UP THEY WANT
OUR CHILDREN TO GO BACK TO FACE
TO FACE BUT THEY WANTED TO IN A
SAFE WAY. THAT TAKES A LOT MORE
MONEY THAN WHAT IS. THE NORMAL
BUDGET HERE AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ALL LOOKING FOR AS
WELL WE CAN COMPETE. IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO DO HAVE
THE FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO. GO
BACK TO OF FACE TO FACE
LEARNING. SO I JUST WANT TO ADD
THAT THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS WE HAVE
DOLE AND ALL OF A SENATOR CASE.
THANK YOU A MAN CHAIR- WELL
MEMBERS I. JUST ONE AND A HALF
TO MAKE A FEW KEY TO WITH- IT'S
REALLY NICE HAVE A- THE- FORMER
SECRETARY RESOURCES- HERE SO-
I'M NOT GONNA TALK ABOUT FIRE
I'M SURE. ALSO THE SENATOR FROM
THE SECOND DISTRICT WILL COVER
THOSE ISSUES BUT I WANTED. TO
SAY THAT YOU KNOW THE BUDGET IS
A- IS WHERE OUR PRIORITIES ARE
AND WE LAID OUT AND THERE'S
BEEN THERE'S BEEN FOR I'M THE
FOR SPEAKER TODAY AND THE THREE
BEFORE ME. HAVE A COMMON THEME
THAT I PICKED UP ON AND THAT
IS. THE FACT THAT- WE MORE
DETAIL AND I WANT TO BRING THAT
UP I WANT TO TALK ABOUT I'M
GONNA BRING UP TWO ISSUES- TWO
ITEMS THAT I. BELIEVE OR AT
LEAST THE HOTTEST ITEMS IN IN
THAT I'VE HEARD IN MY DISTRICT
AND NUMBER ONE I KNOW THAT- THE
VICE CHAIR BROUGHT UP THE EDT
BUT I WANT TO SHARE THAT YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN TEN MONTHS. AND
IS PANDEMIC. OKAY AND- I CANNOT
TELL YOU THE THOUGHT AND
DOLLARS OF CALLS I HAVE GOTTEN
IN MY OVER THE D. AND WE'RE
STILL RIGHT WILL WRAP SO I WANT
TO ASK A COUPLE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THAT- WASN'T BROUGHT
UP BY THE VICE CHAIR- MANY
BUSINESSES OUT THERE- AS YOU
KNOW- THOSE OF US WHO ACTUALLY
DO A PAYROLL EVERY TWO WEEKS-
AND HAVE EMPLOYEES THOSE THAT
ARE LEFT IN CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
STILL DOING BUSINESS- HAVE TO
PAY. FOR THIS- THE IN BENEFITS
THE WE HAVE TO PAY THEM BACK
THEIR STIR TO MY KNOWLEDGE. FOR
EIGHT POINT THREE BILL DOLLARS
AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- HAS
GIVEN TO CALIFORNIA. AND I'D
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT OF THAT. ARE
WE RECOVERY GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO PAY THAT BACK AS WE
DID IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
IT TOOK US SOME ALMOST TEN
YEARS TO GET THAT PAID BACK SO
THAT'S A QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
ALSO. A FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON
THAT ALSO IS THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF FRAUD AT- THERE WAS ALREADY
THERE IS A- THE. THE TV. THIS
MORNING AND- OUTLET THE TALK
ABOUT TO BE. DOLLARS AND I
THINK THAT. MAY BE LOW MAY A
BILL SO. ARE WE GONNA BE. TO
BACK THE EIGHT DOLLAR OR TWO
DOLLARS FOR SURE. AND THEN WHAT
ABOUT THE FORTY EIGHT POINT.
THREE THAT'S MY FIRST- QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
SENATOR- SO IN REGARDS TO. THE
BORROWING WHEN STATE FARM FROM
THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND- IT IS-
BASICALLY A- THAT WOULD WILL BE
REPAYING THAT STATE WILL. ANY
INTO. ON THAT AND SO WE
ACTUALLY DO HAVE INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- AN
AMOUNT OF- OH FIVE FIFTY FIVE.
MILLION TO REPAY THAT ON THE
LAW. HOWEVER THAT THE NOT TAKE
COULD. THE NEW DATE THAT- WAS
IMPLEMENTED REGARDS THE FEDERAL.
SO THAT WILL BE A- AS MARAVICH.
BUT- GENERALLY HOW WORKS IS THE
EMPLOYER ARE PAYING INTO THIS.
FOR ON BEHALF OF THEIR- AND SO
THESE ARE. DE THAT HAVE BEEN-
TAKEN OUT BE REPAID- THROUGH
FUTURE- EMPLOYER. KIND ON
BEHALF OF THEIR. YES I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WILL PAYING
AND I'M PART OF THAT. WAS WHAT
ABOUT THE FROM I MEAN THERE
BILLIONS OF FRAUD. AS I BE
PASSED ON TO THE BUSINESS. I
MEAN I HAVE A QUESTION I TO MY
CALL DANIEL. HI DANIEL BRANDED
WITH THE OF THANK YOU SENATE
DOLLY FOR CLASS. AND WE ARE
STILL LOOKING INTO YOUR- WHAT
CAN BE DONE- I'M NOT A THE
TOPIC FRANKLY EDT RECKONS AS
DISCUSSION I CAN TAKE YOUR-
QUESTION BACK- PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL DURING THE HEARING. OKAY
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA TO MAKE
A COMMENT ON THAT. YOU KNOW
LOOK IF I'M NOT GONNA TALK
ABOUT THE BIZ SECTION THERE'S
SOME BIG RELIEF BUT IF YOU WANT
TO GIVE A BIT SIMILAR- THAT
WOULD BE A GREAT. YOU TO STAR
IS NOT. REQUIRE THEM TO PAY.
DEFINITELY NOT THE FRAUD BUT
THERE ARE MANY BUSINESSES GOING
THAT ARE NOT BEEN ANYMORE SO
THAT PUT THE BIRD EVEN. SO ON
THOSE REMAIN BUSINESS AND CAL.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE I THANK GOD
FACT THAT HAVE. MAKE IT
NATIONAL. A WORLDWIDE CAL.
BASED IN CAL. WE WOULD NOT THIS
NGUYEN. IF WE'RE RELYING ON THE-
DEVAS. SMALL THAT ARE THAT BEEN.
JUST DESTROYED BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. WE WOULD BE IN VERY
TOUGH SHAPE TODAY. WITHOUT I
WANT TO MOVE ON TO MY NEXT
QUESTION- AND I'VE HEARD ABOUT-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE FOLKS THAT
ARE IMPACTED THE MOST BY THE-
THE- THIS PANDEMIC. HAS BEEN
ELDERLY WHICH I BELIEVE IS
TRUE. BUT WE ALSO HAVE OUR
YOUNG FOLKS WHO. HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED AND I THINK THAT. THE
AS A FATHER OF. THREE CHILDREN
THAT ARE STILL ATTENDING TO IN
COLLEGE AND ONE. IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL. THE HEALTH IMPACTS THAT
WE'RE SEEING- MENTALLY- AND WE
NEED TO GET THESE KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL NO DOUBT THEY NEED TO BE
IT. LEARNING IN SCHOOL- BUT ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
WITH DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SUCH AS- THE A BIG PART OF MY
DISTRICT IS. BROADBAND NOW I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF FEDERAL
MONEY. THAT HAS BEEN- ALLOCATED
TO BROADBAND BUT- AND WE'VE
DONE LEGISLATION I'VE ACTUALLY
WORKED ON IT MYSELF. BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY- IT IS A QUICK
ENOUGH. THE BY THE TIME YOU
BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE- TO
GET WHERE WE'RE GOING THESE
WE'VE LOST THESE KIDS- SO I
WOULD I WOULD JUST. SHARE THAT
I THINK THERE'S MAYBE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES AND MAYBE A
VOUCHER PROGRAM OR ACTUALLY
HELP SOME OF THESE. PARENTS PAY
FOR THEIR INTERNET- SO THEIR
KIDS CAN ACTUALLY DISTANCE
LEARN IN THESE AREAS WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE. A PERSONAL THEIR
DISADVANTAGE IN THIS IS NOT
JUST FOR RULERS. THIS IS FOR.
PEOPLE THAT ARE. EVEN HAVE
ACCESS DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO. PURCHASE IT WE SHOULD LOOK
AT A VOUCHER PROGRAM- MAYBE RUN
IT THROUGH THE SCHOOL SO THAT
WE CAN. ALLOW THESE. STUDENTS
TO A DISTANCE LEARN SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THT I.
REALLY WOULD THINK WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON. AS OUR IS THAT
BROADBAND- BECAUSE THE LONG
TERM BROADBAND FIXES IS YEARS
TO GET THE INFRASTRUCTURE OUT
THERE BUT THERE ARE MANY THAT
HAVE THE IT JUST HAVE A
STRUCTURE THAT CAN'T- AFFORDED.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT-SENATOR AND- BROADBAND
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE BROWN BET
BROADENING. HAS BEEN- UNDER
HIGHLIGHTED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AS BOOKS HAVE BEEN
MOVING TO TELEWORK AND KIDS TO
TELL THE SCHOOL AND- TELEHEALTH-
AND WE- TO ENGAGE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS ISSUE. WE
THINK IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT
AND NOW IS THE TIME TO DO
SOMETHING- AND I. YOUR YOUR
VOUCHER I'LL PLAN IS WELL TAKEN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE WILLBE. THERE THERE MAY BE SOME
CITIES NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
FAMILIES SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE
THE CONNECTIVITY NO MATTER
WHERE THEY ARE. SO LOOKING
FORWARD TO MORE DISCUSSIONS ON
THAT WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO MAKE
ONE LAST COMMENT- IN THE AREA
IF WE BURN. FOUR MILLION. ACRES
LAST YEAR. AND I TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT. SIX HUNDRED FORTY
ACRES IS A SQUARE MILE SO YOU
CAN DO THE MATH ON HOW MANY
MILLIONS OF SQUARE MILES OF
CALIFORNIA WAS BURKE LAST YEAR.
I JUST WANNA SHARE THAT I THINK
THAT PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IS THAT TOO
MUCH MONEY GOES THE AGENCIES
AND NOT ENOUGH TO. THE FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS AND THERE'S A LOT
OF OTHER AVENUES THAT WE COULD
DISTRIBUTE THIS MONEY. MORE
EFFICIENTLY QUICKER AND GET
MORE DONE ON THE GROUND BECAUSE
WE'RE UPPING ITS CLOCK WE ARE
DEFINITELY IN A DROUGHT-
SHOWING SIGNS OF DROUGHT RIGHT
NOW A FOR THIS NEXT FIRE SEASON
AND WE NEED TO GET THIS MONEY
DISTRIBUTED AND GET THESE
PROJECTS TAKING CARE OF SO
THAT'S JUST A- AN IDEA. THAT
YOU MIGHT WANT TO INCORPORATE
IN- IMPLEMENTING THE FUNDS
THAT- YOU'VE ALLOCATED. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY WILL NOW GO TO
SENATOR CORTESE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THE COUPLE QUESTIONS IN A
COUPLE AREAS- ON THE LANDLORD
TENANT SIDE. DO WE HAVE
INFORMATION YET OR THEY CAN BE
SURE TO US- REACHED BETWEEN NOW
AND WHEN SUBCOMMITTEE START TO
MEET ON. ESSENTIALLY ON THE ON
THE APPROPRIATIONS ROUTING.
FROM FEDERAL STIMULUS. INTO THE
STATE'S. AND OR THE COUNTIES-
AND- HOW MUCH DISCRETION THE
STATE'S GOING TO HAVE OVER THAT
PROCESS THAT'S MY FIRST
QUESTION- AND A SUB PART OF
THAT- THE QUESTION IS. DO WE
KNOW HOW PRESCRIPTIVE THE USE
OF THAT THOSE DOLLARS. IS SURE
THAT'S THE BOOK IS
UNDERSTANDABLE REFLECTED IN
THIS PROPOSED. OBVIOUSLY I
THINK ANYBODY I WOULD ASSUME
ANYBODY AND- A RASH ON RATIONAL
MINDSET WOULD SAY THAT 90% OR-
THE BULK OF THOSE DOLLARS NEEDS
TO GO TO CASH PAYMENTS DIRECTLY
TO RENT IN ALL CASES BUT WE'RE
SEEING ALREADY PROJECTIONS OF
SHORTFALLS BETWEEN LANDLORDS
AND TENANTS THAT ARE GONNA
REMAIN UNRESOLVED. AND I'M
WONDERING. WHETHER OR NOT. THE
DOLLARS ARE GONNA COME
PRESCRIBED IN SUCH A WAY THAT
ANY PART OF IT CAN BE USED. TO
SUPPORT LANDLORD TENANT
MEDIATION PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE
TO HELP RESOLVE- THOSE
ALTERNATELY THOSE LANDLORD
TENANT. DEFAULTS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION THE SENATOR AND
AT THIS POINT WE'RE EXPECTING
TWO POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
FROM FEDERAL RELIEF TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA OF WHICH- ONE POINT
FOUR OR ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
WILL COME STRAIGHT WILL COME TO
THE STATE- AND ONE POINT THREE
THE REMAINDER WILL GO STRAIGHT
TO LOCALITIES WITH. POPULATIONS
OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND OR
MORE- IT EVERY DAY I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S MORE INFORMATION THAT'S
PROVIDED- AND FOR THE DETAILS-
I GET HANDED OVER CALLING
ANIMAL BUT I MONEY TO ALSO THAT-
YOU KNOW THIS IS IN TERMS OF-
HOW IT STRUCK- WE DO WATCH.
ALSO ABOUT A YOU KNOW THE-
LET'S JUST THE DOLLAR THAT'S
FOR IS NOT NECESSARY- WHAT IS-
NEEDED A OUT THERE AND I THIS
IS NOT A THE PROPOSAL NOT A TO
FOR THAT. BUT IT IS TO PROVIDE-
SO RELIEF TO LAND- ENTER- AND
IN REGARDS TO YOUR MIND- WELL
THERE WAS SOME DOLLARS. FOR
LANDLORD AND TENANT- MEDIATION
AND I ADD THAT WE DO HAVE SOME
MONEY- IN YEAR'S FOR THAT- FROM
THE NATIONAL MORTGAGE THAT. AND
AGAIN HAVE A MORE FROM MICHAEL
BUT JUST WANTED TO MENTION THAT
AS WELL AS THERE'S MILLION IN
IN THE CURRENT BY FOR. THE
COURTS IN HER CAR TO- SMALL
CLAIM ISSUE THAT WILL COME UP
AS A OF THE THIRTY FIVE EARLIER
IN THE FALL SO I HAVE THAT OVER
ONE OF COLLEAGUES SOME MORE.
THANK YOU. THE STATE- OBVIOUSLY
CONVERSATIONS- ARE CONTINUING
AND FLUID RIGHT NOW- WE'RE
HAVING WITH- YOU KNOW. THE THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW BEST TO
APPROACH THAT AND IN ADDITION
TO YOU KNOW AN EVICTION-
MORATORIUM EXTENSION- WERE
EXPLORING WAYS IN WHICH- BUT
ONE OF OUR GOALS OBVIOUSLY ONE
IS TO PROVIDE THOSE PROTECTIONS
FOR THE RENTERS BUT ALSO
GETTING THESE- CRITICAL-
SUPPORTS TO THE TEN AND-
LANDLORDS- AS THE- FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE FLOWING TO THE STATES
SO. WE SHARE A COMMON GOAL OF
GETTING THOSE DOLLARS OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND THEY
COULD START TO COME TO THE
STATE AS EARLY AS THE END OF
THE MONTH- ALSO I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT- YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
IN COMMUNICATION WITH- THE SACK
IN THE LEAGUE OF CITIES TO
EXPLORE AND TO UNDERSTAND HOW.
THE LOCALS HAVE RESPONDED TO
USING THEIR DOLLARS AND OTHER
SIERRA DOLLARS- TO SUPPORT
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS AND SO.
IT'S OUR GOAL TO- NOT ONLY- TO
SUPPLEMENT EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND NOT RECREATE THE WHEEL HERE
BUT ALSO PROVIDE. OPTIONS FOR
THE SMALLER JURISDICTIONS IN
THAT THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
STAND UP A PROGRAM BUT WE CAN
PROVIDE THEM SOME STRUCTURE TO
QUICKLY PIVOT. AND TO PROVIDE
THE SUPPORTS THE TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS- ALSO I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT AS PART OF THE- THE
FEDERAL GUIDANCE- THE BULK OF
THESE DOLLARS ARE ARE TARGETED
TOWARDS- COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
EIGHTY OR BELOW AT AREA MEDIAN
INCOME- WITH THE EMPHASIS ON
50% A. M. I. IN ADDITION- THERE
IS A HEAVY EMPHASIS ON THOSE
AREAS- FOR. PAYING THOSE RAGES
SEVENTY TWO YEAR POINT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PAYING
THOSE A RESURGENCE IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING THOSE
CLEANED OFF THE BOOKS AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE BEFORE WE START
FOCUSING ON THE- PERSPECTIVE
PAYMENTS. FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
AND SO MANY OF THESE SUPPORTS
ARE GOING TO BE GOING DIRECT-
TARGETED DIRECTLY TO THE
LANDLORDS. BUT ALSO- THE
PROGRAM IS FLEXIBLE ENOUGH-
THAT THE GUIDANCE FROM THE FED
IS FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO THE
EXTENT THAT LANDLORDS ARE
MOVING FORWARD. WITH REQUESTED
THESE DOLLARS THAT THE TENANTS
ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY TO APPLY
FOR THOSE- THOSE DOLLARS ON
BEHALF OF THEIR LANDLORDS- IN
ADDITION ALSO TO- MY
COLLEAGUES- A REFERENCE TO THE
NOW. MORE SETTLEMENT. DOLLARS
DIDN'T WAS PROVIDE A NICE
YEAR'S BUDGET- WOULD A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL ON THAT
OBVIOUSLY THERE WAS THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION IN-
SETTLEMENT FUNDS THAT WAS ADDED
AND- THERE WAS- APPROPRIATED IN
THE BUDGET- MANY MUCH OF THAT
IS GOING TO BE GOING. TOWARDS
THE BOAT WITH THREE HUNDRED
MILLION IS GOING TO BE GOING
TOWARDS- COUNSELING SERVICES SO
RENTERS. AND HOMEOWNERS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO RECALL I'M
THROUGH A LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO I
REQUEST COUNSELING SERVICES TO
HELP THEM FIGURE OUT HOW TO
NAVIGATE HOW TO REFI. AND HOW
TO ADDRESS- A RARE CHASE- IN
ADDITION THE OTHER THIRTY ONE
MILLION. IS GOING TO BE
PROVIDED FOR- LEGAL AID
SERVICES FOR RENTERS TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL- I'M- SO.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY MORE
QUESTIONS FEEL BETTER DRESSED-
THE BULK OF YOUR QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAD. THE TICKET ADDRESS A
LOT OF THEM THE WILL CONTINUE
TO ASK QUESTIONS- OFFLINE OF
COURSE. I STILL THINK THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION I WAS
ASKING ABOUT. WHETHER OR NOT-
THE STIMULUS DOLLARS PROSUMER
DOLLARS ARE FUNGIBLE ENOUGH TO
BE DEPLOYED- IN IN TERMS OF
SOME OF THE- MEDIATION TYPE
WORK THAT WE WERE BOTH JUST
TALKING ABOUT IS. IS JUST-
STILL UNRESOLVED IN MY MIND SO-
ITSELF DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
YOU'RE TOO WORRIED ABOUT WHERE
THE MONEY'S GONNA COME FROM SO-
MAYBE THAT'S A NON ISSUE BUT-
THANKS I'M STILL ON RESULT. ON
THAT I COULD I COULD TAKE- MORE
OF THE RISK. OF IS THERE A
GONNA PULL BACK. MAYBE TO
THIRTY THOUSAND FEET HERE- IN.
BERMAN **** BECAUSE SIMPLY WITH
REGARD TO TOO COLD A- NOT NOT
ANYTHING ELSE IN OTHER WORDS I
DON'T NEED A HI NEW HERE BUT I
DON'T THINK I NEED A CIVICS
LESSON ON- THAT'S
RESPONSIBILITY FOR
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
KOBE BECAUSE THE EMERGENCY
POWERS OF. OF THE STATE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH SIDE ON THE
EXECUTIVE SIDE THERE'S SOME
QUESTION IN MY MIND. AS TO. YOU
KNOW WHERE THE LINE IS DRAWN-
AS WE PROCEED ON THIS BUDGET
PATH. BETWEEN WHAT REMAINS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE. OF VERSES OF WHAT.
CLEARLY FALLS IN. THE CATEGORY
OF EMERGENCY EXECUTIVE POWERS
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH POWERS. OF
FOR EXAMPLE ISSUES AROUND
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES- OF A ROPE
AROUND- DEPLOYMENT FOR
COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN WOULD
WOULD SEEM TO ME TO BE
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES THE
POLICY QUESTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- YOUR RESPECTIVE OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL NEED TO. DEPLOY
THOSE DOLLARS FOR MERCY
PURPOSES- IN THE LARGER SCHEME
AND I'M JUST WONDERING MAYBE
FROM THE L. A. O. WITH I HAVE
TO BELIEVE AT SOME POINT
SOMEBODY IN THE ALEJO'S OFFICE
SAT DOWN AND STARTED TO. CHECK
THAT OUT OR FIGURE THAT OUT IS
THERE SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED TO ME OBVIOUSLY TO
OTHERS. OF WHICH- WOULD WOULD
WOULD AT LEAST IN A TOP LINE
SORT OF FASHION START TO
SEPARATE THAT OUT IT JUST SEEMS
TO ME THAT PROBABLY BECAUSE- OF
A WHOLE BUNCH OF REASONS-
EXPEDIENCY. COOLEY OF THE
MERCIES. UNKNOWNS ABOUT HOW
LONG THIS PANDEMIC WAS GONNA
LAST SAID. BUT THERE MAY HAVE
BEEN. A LOT OF DIFFERENCE IN
OPERATION HERE- IN AND
CERTAINLY HOPE WATER THAT
CONTINUES BUT I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW. WHERE THE LINE IS DRAWN
AT SOME POINT IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO. GET MORE
PRESCRIPTIVE ABOUT HOW THINGS
ARE DONE. YES SENATOR I THINK-
THIS IS A IS A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION AND WE HAVE- YES SOME
OF THE SEVENTEEN- IT NEEDS TO
BE DONE ON AT THE- IN CANNOT BE
ANTICIPATED IN ADVANCE BECAUSE
IT AS YOU NOTED IT'S IN
RESPONSE TO AN EMERGENCY AND
SO. PART OF WHAT THE GOVERNOR
IS PROPOSING HERE IS TO INCLUDE
SOME CONTROL SECTION LANGUAGE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW. THE
ADMINISTRATION ADMINISTRATIVE
FLEXIBILITY WITH SHIFTING SOME
OF THE FUNDS AROUND AFTER-
BUDGET ENACTMENT- WITH THAT
SAID I THINK I HAVE A COLLEAGUE
DREW SODERBERG WHO IS AVAILABLE
HERE AND CAN PROBABLY PROVIDE A
BIT MORE- AS A DETAILED
RESPONSE FOR YOU. YEAH AND IF
IT'S TOO DETAILED I CAN TAKE IT
OFFLINE I'M JUST ASSUMING THAT
ANYTHING LIKE THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED TO YOU KNOW THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE ANYWAY. THANK YOU.
SORT OF BORED LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- BASICALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION- HAS PROVIDED AN
OVERALL FRAMEWORK FOR HOW THEY
PLAN TO FIND A CODEX THE ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
CODE EXPENDITURES- IN THE
COMING BUDGET YEAR R. ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION OF THIS IS GOING
TO BE ALLOCATED TO SPECIFIC
DEPARTMENTAL BUDGETS HOWEVER-
AS MR PADDOCK MENTIONED THE-
THEY ARE PROPOSING CONTROL
SECTION LANGUAGE. THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO SHIFT FUNDS
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENTS
RECEIVED THOSE ALLOCATIONS IN
ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION- IS
RESERVING ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN- AN OFF
BUDGET BUDGET ITEM THAT THEY
COULD ACCESS TO FURTHER
SUPPLEMENT THEIR CODE RESPONSE
EFFORTS IN ADDITION IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
CURRENTLY THE EXPENDITURES MANY
MUCH OF THE- SITTING SENATORS
ON COVERED RESPONSE HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE- DISASTER RECOVERY
AND EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT THREE- OH- AND THE
AUTHORIZATION TO USE THE FUNDS
INJURY- OFFER CODE RESPONSE ARE
EXPIRING AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR. AND SO THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO CONTINUE TO USE TRIO- IN THE
FUTURE YEARS AND GIVEN THE
STRUCTURE OF THE EMERGENCY
SPENDING AUTHORITIES THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION TO
SEND- WELL BEYOND THE. ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION PROPOSED.
ARE IN THE IN THE- FISCALLY- IT
COMES TO DREAM OF THE- THE
CURRENT A STORE ALLOW IN OF
REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION TO.
THE MUCH ONE FINE ARE BEING.
TRANSFERRED INTO ALL OF THERE'S
NO REQUIRE FOR. ON HOW THOSE
FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY SPENT ON.
HOW WHERE THEIR THEIR%
ULTIMATELY ALLOCATED HOWEVER IT
IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
DESPITE THAT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION THEY HAVE
COMMITTED. TO PROVIDING THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THIS
INFORMATION ON A MONTHLY BASIS-
AND- HAD DONE SO FOR THE MOST
PART THE HAVE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE
WITH MONTHLY REPORTS ON ON HOW
IT'S SPENDING THE FUNDS. THAT
ARE BEING ALLOCATED FOR PUBLIC
RESPONSE. THURMOND WHAT AGAIN
WOULD YOU. SUGGEST THAT I CAN
TAKE THIS INTO- YOU KNOW LATER
ON AT SOME POINT IN TIME BUT- I
THINK FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT I'M
REALLY ASKING IS- IN TO LOOK AT
IN REVERSE IS ONCE. THE ABOVE
THE AMHERST NY MERCY DECORATION
IS- HAS RUN ITS COURSE. WHICH
POWERS OF APPROPRIATIONS. IT
CAN LEGISLATIVE POWERS RETURN
TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT
ESSENTIALLY BEEN. YOU KNOW
SEATED TO THOSE OVERSEE CARS AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THAT'S
ANOTHER WAY FOR ME TO FIND OUT.
WHAT WHAT LAUGHTER JURISDICTION
AND WHAT'S GOING TO COME BACK
AT SOME POINT SO I CAN. POP UP
LIKE THAT. A TO THIS ON THESE
ONGOING BUDGET DECISIONS OR
SUGGESTIONS OR RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE HAVE SO I JUST LIKE TO
GET THAT. FINISH UP CAR OR GET
THAT INFORMATION AT SOME POINT
AFTER TODAY I KNOW TODAY'S AN
OVERVIEW IT'S NOT INTENDED. FOR
A DEEP DIVE. THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSES THAT YOU PROVIDED SO
FOR- SIMILARLY FOR ME TO SELL
US FOR MAYBE SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE PROVIDED TO DOCUMENT A
LESSER SOME OBJECTION- IN IN
THE IN THE LARGER REVENUE
DISCUSSION- I APPRECIATED THAT
I. THINK WE WERE GIVEN SOME
HIGH POINTS AS TO WHY THINGS
ARE THE FEAR BY THE FISCAL
PROJECTIONS ARE BETTER NOW THAN
THEY WERE. I DIDN'T HEAR A LOT
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT PROPERTY
TAXES WHAT THE- PROJECTIONS
WERE- FIFTEEN PERSONS WHERE
THEY ARE NOW- IN FACT WHAT I'M
NOT CLEAR THAT I'VE SEEN
ANYTHING ON ON SALES TAXES AS
WELL IS IT POSSIBLE TO GET THIS
SOMETHING WHAT IS A BAR CHART
OR A PIE CHART OR SOMETHING ON
A ONE PAGER THAT SHOWS US-
THEN. VERSUS NOW IN TERMS OF.
LAST SUMMER LAST SUMMER'S
PROJECTIONS VERSUS VERSUS NOW
PARTICULARLY AND WHAT PROPERTY
TAX ACTUAL SERBIAN FOR EXAMPLE
VERSUS WHAT. CHANGES WERE
PROJECTED TO A PATH TO OCCUR
WHEN THIS- BUDGET WAS
ORIGINALLY ADOPTED THIS CURRENT
BUDGET. YEAH I'M JUST LOOKING
FOR YES OR NO ALL OF THAT AN
BE PROVIDED MORE FOR MYSELF AND
FOR. WE CAN PROVIDE THAT HERE
STAFF HUNTER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SIMILARLY I WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND. OVERALL OF HOW THE
HOMELESS FUNDING THAT'S
PROPOSED AT THIS POINT IN THE
BUDGET IS. IS BROKEN DOWN
BETWEEN PERMANENT HOUSING WHAT
WILL. LOCAL GOVERNMENT SUPPORT
HOUSING VERSUS SHORT TERM
SHELTER. NEEDS I'M JUST LOOKING
FOR TAKING THE NUMBERS THAT YOU
ALREADY HAVE BEEN SPLITTING
THEM INTO THOSE TWO CATEGORIES
IS THAT ALSO POSSIBLE TO GET.
AFTER TODAY. I'M SURE I WOULD
JUST POINT OUT THAT THE ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION WE
HAVE PROPOSED IN THE CURRENT BY
IN THE IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IS FOR ACQUISITION OF- OF UNITS
AND SO WE SEE THAT AS A MORE
PERMANENT BUT I THINK YOU'RE
ASKING FOR- OVERALL SPENDING
AND HOW MUCH OF IT IS GOING
TOWARDS- SUCH THINGS AS YOU
KNOW THE LONGER TERM
INVESTMENTS VERSUS- MAYBE
SHELTERS IS THAT RIGHT YES SOME
OF THE FOR EXAMPLE SURPRISE MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS- IT THAT. HAD EVEN
TAKE THAT HAVE BEEN- PUT
FORDERT. RANGE FROM A
PURCHASING. A SHORT TERM-
HOUSING- FACILITIES- BY WAY OF
TAKING OVER MOTELS. FOR EXAMPLE
OR EXISTING FACILITIES THAT CAN
BE USED TO GET PEOPLE. IN AND
OUT. OUT OF. OUT OF HARM'S WAY
INTO TEMPORARY SHELTER AND THEN
AT SOME POINT PRESUMABLY ON A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND THEN THERE'S PERMIT
SUPPORTED HOUSING FUNDING WHICH
IS ACTUALLY CAPITAL INVESTMENT
IN. NEW APARTMENTS TYPICALLY
FOR EXTREMELY LOW INCOME FOLKS
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S BOTH IN
THIS BUDGET FOR TO WHAT EXTENT.
THERE'S RESOURCES FOR THOSE
TWO. FOR THOSE TWO WORLDS GOOD
TO HAVE- TO BE FUNDED. AND
THEY'RE THERE YEAH WE CAN WE
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AND GET
YOU SOME MORE INFORMATION THERE
ARE THERE ARE ONGOING- PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE FOR SOME OF THIS
AND NOT NEW PROPOSALS AND SO WE
CAN- BREAK THAT DOWN FOR YOU.
SUPER THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
THEN LASTLY ON THE- THE HIT THE
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE. I
APPRECIATE THE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
PROPOSED IN. I MEAN JUST. I
DON'T HAVE GREAT CONCERNS THAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE INADEQUATE
ON A ON A ONE YEAR BASIS JUST
ON THE BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
TYPE OF CALCULATION MY OWN
PART- HOWEVER. THE PROGRAM THAT
WOULD BEST REPLICATE THIS IN
SENATE DISTRICT FIFTEEN IS A
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM IN JUST ONE COUNTY SO.
DEPENDING ON HI YOU EXTRAPOLATE
THESE PROGRAMS AND OBVIOUSLY
HOW MANY HOW MUCH NEED THERE
IS- I I'M NOT CLEAR AS TO
WHETHER THE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS ENOUGH THAT
SAID. HAZARD IT SEEMS TO BE
PRETTY WIDELY KNOWN THAT
THERE'S MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT MONEY THAT'S GONE UNUSED IN
THE STATE- FROM JURISDICTION TO
JURISDICTION HAVE. IN THIS IS
REALLY FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAVE HAVE WE LOOKED AT.
WHETHER OR NOT THE THAT SORT OF
DOLLARS RATHER THAN GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS- CAN CAN AUGMENT
THIS NEED. THE SAME NEED. ADD
THANK YOU FOR POINTING OUT THE
AVAILABILITY OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FINDS- I THINK
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT- DOLLARS THAT CAN BE USED
TOWARDS MENTAL HEALTH-
GENERALLY CAN BE BRAID BRAIDED
AND COMPLEMENTARY AND TO THE
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
ARE. OF THE FOUR HUNDRED TWO
HUNDRED WOULD BE GENERAL FUND
AND- BELIEVE THE REST WOULD BE-
THROUGH. THAT ACCOUNT- RECOUP
ITS BUT I WILL DEFER TO OF- MY
COLLEAGUE RYAN MILLER FOR MORE
DETAIL IN A MOMENT- YES THE-
THE DOLLARS- THERE IS ANOTHER
PROPOSAL ACTUALLY TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL- AND
THAT DOES. NOT PROVIDE
EMERGENCY DOLLARS FOR STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH- BUT GENERALLY
THERE'S ALSO- FLEXIBILITY THAT
REPORTING IN THE OR PROPOSING
IN THE BUDGET ACT- THE MAIL
OFFERS MAURICE'S OF THAT MUCH
IF THEY DOLLARS A SMILE BUT I
WILL TURN OVER FOR MORE DETAIL-
TO FINALLY. HEY THANK YOU RYAN
MILLER- I DON'T HAVE MUCH TO
ACTUAL I MEAN I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW IT'S KIND OF A- OF. FREE
AND RELATIVE. I WOULD SAY THAT
THE INVESTMENT DOES BUILD ON
RECENT- AUGMENTATIONS IN RECENT
YEARS FOR SIMILAR MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES- I THINK
NOTABLY. FIFTY MILLION I THINK
IN THE- TWENTY- NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT I WANT TO SAY- SO- YOU KNOW
I. I THINK THAT- WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER MORE YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
THE PROPOSED. I HAVE A
COLLEAGUE I REALLY I DON'T
RAMOS WHO COULD SPEAK MORE TO
THAT. YEAH I DON'T LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP LATER THAT'S ALL I
HAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANDSORRY FOR THE LINK THE NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS THAT WILL TAKE
FIVE SIMPLE QUESTIONS WHEN A
WHEN A ROOM DOWN BUT- LITTLER
THANK YOU. CENTER CORTESE AND
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
LOOK THIS IS OUR FIRST. BUDGET
HEARING AND WE HAVE ALL BEEN-
WERE ALSO JUST RETURNING BACK
AFTER A BREAK AND WE ARE AWARE.
OF THE DEMANDS THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE- THE NEEDS
THEY ARE FEELING DID MANAGE
THEY ARE. REQUESTING IN ITS- I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US
OBVIOUSLY TO GET OUR QUESTIONS
OUT THERE BECAUSE THEN. NOT
ONLY DO ALL OF US IS COLLEAGUES
KNOW WHAT'S ON EACH OF OUR
MINDS WE ALSO THAT- DICK THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES. AND SO I
DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE THAT YES THIS HEARING
ON MAY TAKE SOME TIME BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY MEMBERS HAVE GREAT
QUESTIONS. AND SO WHAT I WOULD
DO NOW IS JUST LIST TO YOU THE
ORDER THAT I HAVE AND I HOPE WE
HAVE CAUGHT EVERYONE. THAT WE
WILL NEXT GO TO SENATOR MCGUIRE
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR WHITE
CASKEY FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
STERN FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MEN.
THEN SENATOR EGGMAN THAN
SENATOR NEWMAN THEN SENATOR
CAFIERO AND THEN SENATOR PAM.
SO MISTER. MCGUIRE GO AHEAD.
THANK SO MUCH AND GET A MADAM
CHAIR A GOOD AFTERNOON
REPRESENT FROM BOTH THE A. O.
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE- WOULD
LIKE BE ABLE TO ADVANCE SYSTEM
COMMON SENSE OF QUESTIONS IN
REGARDS TO WILDFIRE PREVENTION
RESPONSE. FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS. CANDIDLY WE'VE BEEN
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AS WELL
AS CALFIRE. RELATED TO FIRE
RESPONSE AND WHAT HER RESPONSE
A PREVENTION. IT IS BEING
CRYSTAL CLEAR EVEN THOUGH THAT
CALIFORNIA IS THE GOLD STANDARD
OF A FIRE FIGHTING FORCE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. THAT THEY'RE SHORT
STAFFED- AND THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO COMBAT. THIS ERA OF MEGA
FIRES THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
LIVING IN. YEAR AFTER YEAR.
WE'VE ADVANCE REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL ENGINES BECAUSE AND
RETAIN PERSONNEL. NOT AS WELL
AS DOLLARS WHEN IT COMES TO
FIRE PREVENTION FOR EXAMPLE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WHAT WE
KNOW IS CAO FIRES. STAFFING CAL
FIGHTERS STAFFING. ACTUALLY HIT
RECORD NUMBERS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IN IT HAS YET TO
RECOVER FROM OVER FORTY YEARS
AGO. IN THIS IS DESPITE THE
FACT THAT TWENTY TWENTY. WAS A
RECORD BREAKING FIRE SEASON
THAT FOR THE STATE FIFTEEN OF
OUR LARGEST FIRES OF ALL
CURTAIN THE LAST DECADE IN
PHARMACYNEED SEASON IS NOW
NEARLY EIGHTY DAYS LONGER THAN
IT WAS BACK IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE SUBMITTED ALONG
WITH OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE SUBMITTED A REQUEST
ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTY
FOUR MILLION TO HIRE ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL BOTH FULL TIME AND
SEASONAL FOR CALIFORNIA. ALONG
WITH THE NECESSARY EQUIPMENT
AND IT WAS GOING TO BE THAT WAS
GOING TO BE NEEDED. TO HELP
STAFF AND EQUIP A MODERN DAY
FIRE FIGHTING FORCE. NOW BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BACK
IN TWENTY TWENTY WE WERE TOLD
WE WERE TOLD BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THAT IT WASN'T
POSSIBLE TO EXPAND TO THE LEVEL
THAT WE WERE SUGGESTING. THERE
ARE SOME REASONS FOR NOT
ENOUGH- NOT ENOUGH OF ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO GET FIRE ENGINES
IN A RAPID MANNER. BY NOT
ENOUGH CREW QUARTERS A TAKES
TIME TO BETTER TRAIN UP FULL
TIME FIREFIGHTERS. AND IT TAKES
TIME TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
NECESSARY EQUIPMENT IN. NOW
THIS YEAR. D. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS PROPOSING MOSTLY
SEASONAL I MIGHT ADD SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN POSITIONS.
IN THE MEANTIME THE COMMUNITIES
OF THE NORTH COAST HAS
CONTINUED TO BURN. THE LARGEST
WILDLAND FIRE IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX
FIRE SCORCHED MILLION ACRES
THIS YEAR. THE GLASS FIRE THE
WALBRIDGE FIRE RAGED THROUGH
SONOMA AND NAPA COUNTIES. WE
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH STAFFING.
HERE'S MY BOTTOM LINE HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE. NOW. TO BRING ON THIS
ADDITIONAL STAFFING THE WE'VE
BEEN REQUESTING QUITE CANDIDLY
AND YOU CAN HEAR MY INCREDIBLE
FRUSTRATION AND YES ANGER.
THANK YOU ALL SAID WE COULDN'T
DO BACK IN. TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. IS READY WE CAN DO IT
IN TWENTY TWENTY. BECAUSE OF
CONSTRAINTS AND AGAIN IN THE
MEANTIME. COMMUNITIES HAVE
CONTINUED TO BURN. SO THERE'S A
FEW QUESTIONS ONE WHY THIS YEAR.
WHY NOT PREVIOUS YEARS TO HAS
THE MONEY THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ALLOCATED BEING SPENT I IN
REGARDS TO THE STAFFING
INCREASES THAT THAT WAS SETTLED
ON LAST YEAR THREE FOR THE
EARLY ACTION PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR ON
THE FIRE PREVENTION SIDE. HOW
MANY ADDITIONAL ACRES DO YOU
ANTICIPATE IS GOING TO BE DEALT
WITH BEFORE THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR MY UNDERSTANDING
FROM READING THE BUDGET IT'S
ABOUT FORTY FIVE TO SIXTY-
EXPEDITED ENVIRONMENT EXPEDITED
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT- PROJECT
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE WHAT
THAT MEANS IN ACRES. AND IT
DOES CAL FIRE CURRENTLY HAVE
THE SUFFICIENT STAFFING TO DO
THIS EARLY ACTION WORK OR Y'ALL
NEED ADDITIONAL BANDWIDTH TO BE
ABLE TO GET THESE ADDITIONAL
MOSTLY MOSTLY SEASONED
FIREFIGHTERS ON THANK YOU SO
MUCH VENTURE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THESE.
FOUR OR FIVE QUESTIONS PLEASE.
IF. ONE HUNDRED SENATOR MCGUIRE-
HERE I HEAR YOU'RE SAYING AND
I'M IN JUST ONCE- RELAY TO THE
THAT WE DO HAVE A FORTY THREE
MILLION GENERAL IS THE THIRTY
NEW SAFETY SETS OF THEM ARE CAL
FIRE OTHERS OF ARE CONSERVATION
CORPS- WE ALSO INCLUDE FORTY
EIGHT MILLION TWO. BLACKROCK
HELICOPTERS IN OUR TANK. AND
THROUGH OUR ONE BILLION I'M A
FIRE FORTUNATELY AND SEE-
PACKAGE REALLY WANT TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE NEEDS- BASED ON.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN ON THIS RECORD-
FIRE SEASON IN REGARDS TO YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I WILL HAND
IT OVER TO ALISON HEWITT. I
SENATOR MCGUIRE ALISON TO IT
HERE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST WANT TO ANSWER
AND- SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU POSED. AND IT'S TO THE
ANSWER OF WHY THIS YEAR AND NOT
LAST YEAR I DO WANT TO JUST
RECALL IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND SPECIFIC WE BELIEVE
STAFFING PROPOSAL THAT CAME
FORWARD FOR CALIFORNIA. ADDED
EIGHTY FIVE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET IN PART
OF THAT IS TO FIND PERMANENT
POSITIONS BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE- LEGACY STAFFING FOR
HEALTHCARE. AND HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE. WITH ALL THE RESPECT
WITH YOU IT ON THAT ISSUE FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR THIS. AND SO WHAT
THAT ENHANCES ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED AND APPROXIMATELY
HUNDRED FIFTY FULL TIME
STAFFERS A LITTLE OVER THREE
HUNDRED SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS
BUT WE NEEDED THIS MONEY BACK
WE KNEW THAT WE NEEDED THIS
SPENDING MONEY BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. IT DID NOT
HIT THE MARK FOR WHAT WAS BEING
REQUESTED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN EVEN LAST YEAR AND
AGAIN I'M NOT TRYING TO.
INTERRUPT TO BE DISRESPECTFUL
BUT WHERE MY FRUSTRATION IS ON
THE GROUND IS THAT THE FIRE
SEASONS CONTINUE TO GET WORSE
AND WORSE WE KNOW IT'S GONNA
GET WORSE HERE IN THE YEARS TO
COME IN YOUR HEARING MY
FRUSTRATION IN YES AT TIMES
ANGER BECAUSE- WE KNOW WHERE WE
NEED TO GO. BUT FOR SOME REASON
AGAIN I WILL TELL YOU WHAT I'VE
BEEN TOLD NOT ENOUGH CREW
QUARTERS. NOT IN A FIRE ENGINE
TO TAKES TWO YEARS TO BE A TO
GET A FIRE ENGINE. IT TAKES
TIME TO BETTER TRAIN UP FULL
TIME FIREFIGHTERS. IT TAKES
TIME TO BE ABLE TO PROCESS THE
TRAINING- APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
NEEDED ALL THE APPLICATIONS IN
BAND WITH. THE WHEN I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT IF YOU CAN JUST
ANSWER DIRECTLY WHY THIS. YEAR
NOT OVER THE LAST TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS. ALL TRAINS. ALSO HELP
TO FOLLOW WITH YOUR OFFICE IN
THE TO FOCUS. THE THERE'S BEEN
A- IN A FOCUS- WITHIN THE IN.
FOR BOOTS ON THE GROUND THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING. AS WELL AS
NEW AIRCRAFT NEW TECHNOLOGY.
AND SUFFERING TO THAT NEW
LARGER TANKERS. SO IT'S REALLY
ABOUT TRYING TO FIND THE RIGHT
BALANCE BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
WE'RE TRYING TO INTEGRATE AS
MUCH. TECHNOLOGY AS MANY
RESOURCES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WITHIN OTHER BUDGETARY
CONSTRAINTS I THINK IS THE BEST
WAY THAT. I CAN RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION HAPPY TO IT TO WORK
WITH YOUR OFFICE AND OTHERWISE.
AND WE HAVE ADDED SOME
PERMANENT STAFF BEING WE'VE
ADDED ADDITIONAL FIRE ENGINES.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REALLY COMMITTED TO ENHANCING
THE STATE'S WILDFIRE RESPONSE
AND HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON NOT.
AND BUT JUST WHEN IT'S LIKE
THAT WE HAVE ADDED. AND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN RECENT
RECENT BUDGET CYCLES. AND GET
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE
I DON'T THINK ANYONE'S ARGUING
IN IN AGAIN. I AM VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THIS DIALOGUE AND I WILL
NOT BELABOR THE POINT IN YES
I'M HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO GO
OFFLINE. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS. IS FAR AS THE BLACKHAWKS
IN THE C. ONE THIRTIES THIS HAS
BEEN TALKED ABOUT OVER THE LAST
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS AND BUDGET
COMMITTEE. WE KNOW THAT IT
TAKES TIME TO BUILD A RAMP UP
TO BE A TO GET THE BLACKHAWKS
IN FROM POLAND TO BE ABLE TO
GET IN IN- ON SHORE
DOMESTICALLY TO GET THEM INTO-
WORKING HERE IN THE STATES. AND
ON THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE. IN
REGARD TO THE CRUISE FROM CAL
FIRE RESPECTFULLY. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
ASKING. EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
FOR THE CRUISE IN THIRTY ONE
CAL FIRE ENGINES- TO BE TO GET
THOSE FOLKS SKILLED AND TRAINED
AND I. AM BEEN CANDID THE
ANSWERS THAT I WAS GIVEN. NOW
DON'T SEEM TO BE THAT BIG OF AN
ISSUE NOW THAT WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD THIS YEAR POSTING ON
SEASONAL. BUT WE'RE STILL YET
TO HIT OUR NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE PEAK IN IT'S JUST
INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATING. WHEN
YEAR AFTER YEAR. FORESEEN.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BURKE. SO
I'M HAPPY TO OFFER. ON THAT- IS
WELL EFFECT JUST TRANSITION. TO
JUST TWO OTHER. SO DO CAL FIRE
HAS JUST. TO DO THE EARLY
ACTION WORK. UNDERSTANDING IS
YES AND THERE'S ALSO SOME OTHER
EFFICIENCY IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING AT
INCLUDING CONTRACT EXEMPTIONS
BECAUSE THE GOAL PARTICULARLY
WITH A THREE HUNDRED AND- THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S PROPOSED
FOR EARLY ACTION IS TO GET
THOSE PROJECTS ON THE GROUNDS
AND STARTED BEFORE THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FIRE SEASON. AND
BECAUSE OF THE KIND OF
LIFESAVING APPLICATIONS AND THE
ABILITY TO HARDEN COMMUNITIES
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF OPTIONS ARE
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
HEALTHCARE IS PREPARED TO AND
WILL IMPLEMENT THESE PROJECTS-
IN IN- COLLABORATION WITH A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITY PARTNERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS. AND ZACKS ARE
ARE UNDERSTANDING AND ADD THAT
INSPIRATION IN PUTTING THIS
FORWARD HAS THE FULL CONFIDENCE
IN UNDERSTANDING THESE PROJECTS
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE DISCO FIRE HAVE THE
BEING WITH AS FAR AS STAFFING
TO BE TO GET THESE INDIVIDUALS
HIRED AND- EQUIPMENT. PURCHASED
ARE YOU SEEN AS THAT A LOT OF
THIS WORK WILL BE DONE WITHIN
HEALTH FAIRS THE- STOP RESOURCE.
AND I'M AGAIN SOMETHING WE- GET
BACK TO YOU ON OUR
UNDERSTANDING AS THE SOUTH
STOPPING NOT BE IN ISSUE FOR
THE PURPOSES. GETTING THESE
PRESS ON THE GROUND. BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE- PERSONALITY BE HIRED
IN ADDITION EQUIPMENT IT'S
GOING TO NEED TO BE PURCHASED.
THIS SO EVERY. THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE IS VERY
TARGETED ZERO WHAT IS THAT
INDUSTRY'S ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES.
THERE IS ALSO A PORTION OF
THEIR SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN MILLION THAT'S TARGETED
FOR BUDGET YEAR. SOME OF THAT
GROUP WILL AND- REQUIRE SOME
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THAT
HEALTHCARE IS GONNA START.
ADVERTISING AND HIRING FOR AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SUBJECT TO
BE EIGHT. THE- BUDGET ACT
ITSELF. SO SOME OF THAT
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY IT WILL BE
ADDED IN BUDGET YEAR BUT FOR
WHAT WE NEED TO GET ON THE
GROUND AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE. FOR
RATE IS WHAT TRUMPCARE IS ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH AND THAT WE THINK
IS GOING TO MAKE A SCALABLE
DIFFERENCE BEFORE THE FIRE
SINGH FOR THE- BUDGET CHANGE
INVOLVES OF CALLING FOR SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN POSITIONS AS
WELL AS- THAT WILL ADD THOSE
ADDITIONAL HAND CREWS- THE GOAL
IS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THEM ON
BY MARCH FIFTEENTH OR WINS THE
GOAL TO BE A TO GET TO MINE
SINCE THE SEASONAL CONTRACT.
CONTRACT. IS MARCH FIFTEENTH TO
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH. THE SO I'LL
HAVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
SENATOR MY- HAD TO DO SO. AND
SO UP WITH CAL FIRE JUST MAKE A
QUICK TO SEE. THAT THE FIRE.
THAT WERE PROPOSING FOR BUDGET
YOU'RE REALLY ABOUT OF FIRE
PROTECTION AND- PREVENT TO PASS.
SO LITTLE. **** FROM THE THREE
HUNDRED ANDTWENTY TWO MILLION.
BUDGET BUT WILL ABOUT PART OF
THAT. YEAR AFTER IN MOVING
FORWARD BUT LET ME FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU TERMS OF WHEN CAL FIRE
FROM. AND BE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
STUFF ON. AND TO START
SUPPORTING THE SOUTH. THEY'LL
BE GREATLY APPRECIATED THANK
YOU- MAY CHAIR IN WILL BE
FOLLOWED OVER THE PART FINANCE.
YOU'RE WELCOME SENATOR MCGUIRE
SO WE'LL GO TO CENTER WHITE
HOUSE. AND WE WILL BE FOLLOWING
TO SET TWO ON THE- FIRE LOOK
FOR TO TALK WITH. A CHIEF. I'M
GOING TO SPEAK. THE PESTICIDE
CHANGES IN THE BUDGET WE'LL
TALK ABOUT THE MIDDLE FEE AN
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT.
WHICH STAFF THE SAME WITH THE
REFORMS AND DTIC THE NEW- FEES
AND OTHERS ARE EMBRACED AND SB
FORTY TWO. AS WELL AS- CALCIUM
FORMALLY DOCKER THE CHANGES
THAT WE HAVE THERE THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FOUR- ALL-
PRIORITY HAZARDOUS WASTE SPOTS
WILL BE WORKING WITH THAT. I'M
WORKING WITH MY SENATE
COLLEAGUES ON A SUPER
ENVIRONMENTALLY AND THAT MAY BE
OF ASSISTANCE FOR SOME OF THE
WORK THAT'S DONE ON- NOT ORPHAN
SITES FOR PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A HOMEOWNER BUT- I AM A
PULSE SO OF CAN. ABOUT THE
PRIORITIES BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT
THE BUDGET SAY IN ITS
SERIOUSNESS OF COMING OUT OF
FINANCE YOU KNOW. THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED- AND CLIMATE CHANGES IS
HERE AND SERIOUS AND WHILE
WE'RE ALL KEEN FOR FUNDING-
THAT ADDRESSES CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS SIXTY C. LEVEL RISE OR
THE- FORCE MANAGEMENT OF MY-
COLLEAGUE FROM THE- PACIFICA
NORTHWEST WAS TALKING ABOUT.
THESE ONE TIME GENERAL FUND-
ANSWERS IS SIMPLY JUST NOT
ENOUGH. WHAT WE NEED IS A
STABLE ONGOING A FUNDING SOURCE
AND CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE TUNING
UP ITS CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
AND MAKING. IT MAKING IT BETTER
THE LAST SUMMER THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE TO REPORTED OUT
AND SUBSEQUENTLY TO THE SENATE
APPROVED ADOPTING A DIRECTIVE
TO A CAL EPA TO CONSIDER
CHANGES IN THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. NOW SECRETARY OF
BLUMENFELD RESPOND WITH THE
PROPOSES TO FALLS WITH A LETTER
COMMITTING CAL EPA TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE US. IN CARB. TO
EXAMINE THE PROGRAM'S ROLE IN
IT CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY THIRTY
CLIMATE STRATEGY IN ENSURING A
COMPREHENSION HAVE.
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW. BELL I
SEE IN THE PROPOSED CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM YOU HAVE. THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
DOLLARS FOR- EQUITIES. BUT
THAT'S FINE AND DANDY BUT AB
SIX ONE SEVEN IS A POLLUTION
PROGRAM IT DOESN'T REDUCE
CARBON YOU KNOW YOU GET
EXPENSIVE MONITORING EQUIPMENT
THAT'S PUT ON PRIVATE PROPERTY
AND WE EDUCATE PEOPLE WE GIVE
PEOPLE INFORMATION TO
UNDERSTAND IT BUT THIS REDUCE
CARBON SAFE DRINKING WATER.
DOESN'T REDUCE CARBON IMPRINT
YOUR PREDECESSOR MISLITOLD US
THAT THE CULLIGAN MAN SOCCER TO
MAKE THE TRIPS THIS VENTURE YOU
SEE THAT THERE'S A REASON WHY
WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT SO MY
QUESTION IS THE MINISTRATION
SERIOUS. ABOUT WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND WORKING WITH
THE AIRPORT AND IDENTIFYING NEW
LEGISLATION. REGULATION CHANGES
AND- REVISIONS OF THE SCOPING
PLAN TO SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE STRATEGY.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR AND OF
COURSE THE MINISTRATION WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON ALL OF THOSE
GOALS- I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE TO UPDATE YOU AND
ANY PARTICULAR- EVENTS THAT
HAPPENED ON TO THAT AFFECTS BUT
YES THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU TOWARDS
COMMON GOALS FOR CAP AND TRADE
AND FOR CLIMATE- ACTION. I
THINK THIS IS TO RESET COLOR
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS YES
WE EXPECT- IN DISCUSSIONS TO
CONTINUE AS THEY HAVE BEEN WITH
THEIR BOARDS REGULAR UPDATES
ON. THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
AND CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS IN
THIS MATTER AND WHAT. ON THE
LEGISLATURE LOOKING FOR AS FAR
AS CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE
PLAN BUT AS YOU NOTED OUR
EXPENDITURE PLAN REALLY DOES
FOCUS. ON THE PRIORITIES OF OUR
MODEL JUSTICE AND PUBLIC. AS
YOU WANTED. I WOULD I WOULD
HOPE THAT ANY CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM FOCUSES ON REDUCING
CARBON WHAT IS THE BIGGEST BANG
FOR THE BUCK. YOU KNOW WHAT
I'VE SAID HERE'S CHEERS UP TO
FOR FOUR YEARS I GOT MY
COLLEAGUES TALKING ABOUT FORCE
OTHER COLLEAGUE UP FROM LASSEN
COUNTY. CENTER STERN COULD BE
ON HERE SO WE REALLY THE
PROGRAM IS NOT DESIGNED FOR. A
DO GOOD BY A SOLVE ALL THE
PROBLEMS OF ALL THE ILLS OF
CALIFORNIA WE COULD WE COULD
I'M SURE PEOPLE THAT NEED
DENTAL HEALTH NEED- AN
INJECTION OF FREE DENTAL HEALTH
BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA DO WITH THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM I MEAN.
I'M SURE MY FRIEND FROM
SACRAMENTO WOULD LOVE TO SEE
MONEY COMING OUT TO GIVE TO THE
KIDS BUT I'LL MOVE ON I LOOK
FORWARD TO SOME SERIOUS
DISCUSSION SINCE UP TO. NOW THE
YOU HAVE A CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS. FROM YOU KNOW SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS ARE BRAND NEW I
NEVER EVEN HEARD OF THEM- AND-
YOU KNOW THE IDEA IS THAT. THE
L. A. L. HAS TOLD ME ANYTHING
FINANCIALLY SAID THAT THESE
PROJECTS ARE EXPECTED TO BE
COMPLETED. OVER MULTIPLE YEARS.
AND SOME OF THE PROJECT SECTOR
HOLLISTER- THE HELICOPTER PAD
THAT WAS PROPOSED IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. I THINK IT WAS
APPROPRIATE DIDN'T GET BILLED.
TWO THOUSAND SIX APPROPRIATE
DIDN'T GET BILL NOW YOU GOT
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF THIS FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT. SO IF
THE FORECAST IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE HAVE AN OPERATING
DEFICIT IN THE FUTURE HOW ARE
THESE PROJECTS EVER GOING TO
GET FINISHED NO WE START THEM
BUT HOW WITH THE- OTHERS. HOW
DO YOU HOW DO YOU COMPLETE THEM.
HI AND I CANNOT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE CABIN- SORRY
IN OUR CAPITAL PROGRAM- LET ME
DO THIS INNER. FOR THAT CENTER
Y. CASKEY THAT MORE RETOOL
POINT OR YOU'RE WANT THEM TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THAT. SILICON
MEANING YOUR LAST POINT ABOUT
HOW TO HOW WE DO WE COMPLETE
THEM. WHAT'S THAT MORE AP.
ILLUSTRATIVE A RHETORICAL POINT
OR WOULD YOU LIKE THEM TO
ANSWER THAT NO I MEAN LET'S
JUST PICK THE HOLLISTER.
HELICOPTER BY KATE AND HOW THIS
SAID HOW DOES THAT PROJECT IS.
COMPLETE WHERE DOES THE OTHER
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS COME FROM
IF WE GOT A DEFICIT IN THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. OKAY GO AHEAD. M.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. HOW YOU TO
FUNDED. AFTERNOON MY BIGGEST
APARTMENT FINANCED- WE'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION AND GET
BACK TO YOU. W. GREAT- ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE- BILLION DOLLARS
SECURITIZED OUR AB EIGHT
REGISTRATION FEE- WHAT ARE THE
MERITS OF SUPPORTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CHARGING A FUEL
STATIONS OKAY YOU WANT TO BUILD
FUEL STATIONS VERSUS JUST
PURCHASING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES- I NOTICED AT THE C.
B. R. P. PROGRAM IS NOT FUNDED
IN OR AT LEAST THE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS BEEN ARE SORT OF GO TO
PRIVATE PROJECT TO GET PEOPLE-
TO PURCHASE THIS IN WHY WOULD
WE GET A BIGGER BANG FOR THE
BOX IF WE JUST BOUGHT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. RATHER THAN A BILLION
DOLLARS ON THE PROGRAMS AND
AGAIN SOME OF THE PROGRAMS ON
THE EVE YOU CHARGING STATIONS
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION MISLI YOU
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW THAT I
SPENT MANY YEARS PRACTICING IN
BANKRUPTCY COURT I KNOW THAT WE
THE BUDGET INCLUDES A MORE
TOWARD EXTENDING THE MORATORIUM
ON EVICTIONS SO THE PEOPLE IN
OUR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY WHY
I'M LOOKING TO HELP THEM OUT IF
THEY IF THEY'RE GOING TO GET
AFFECTED AND THEY'RE GOING TO
CAN'T PAY THEIR ELECTRIC BILL
THEY'RE GETTING FOOD ASSISTANCE
THAT WE HEAR ABOUT. HE CAN'T
PAY THE THEIR WATER BILL AND
THEY DON'T HAVE A JOB THERE ARE
A PART OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT HOW
WOULD THEY GO TO BUY A BRAND
NEW CAR BUT- YOU KNOW ELECTION
VIA. ON TOP THAT BUT WHY. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE VERSUS- REBATES
OR INCENTIVES TO BUY MORE. I
EVN HYDROGEN CARS ARE ALL
RESPONDED AT A HIGH LEVEL AND
THEN HANDED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES RESET GALLAGHER- I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
UNDER MY NAME OR THE TEAMS
AGAIN OF THIS BUDGET IS REALLY
JOB CREATION AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE- ONE BILLION AND
SECURITIZATION OF FUTURE FEES
AS A MEANS OF JOB CREATION AND
ALSO- PROVIDING. CHARGING
STATIONS THAT WILL BE NECESSARY
TO- AROUND THE STATE TO HAVE-
PEOPLE WHO DO HAVE- THIS OUT
ABLE TO USE THEM AND SO THERE'S
A NEED THAT I THINK ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE WERE
ATTEMPTING TO- MEETS AND IN
REGARDS TO THAT THE SECOND PART
THAT'S THERE'S FOUR HUNDRED SIX
SIXTY FIVE MILLION- TWO PLUS
THE PROGRAM THAT YOU PROVIDE
SUBSIDIES SO THAT WE CAN GET
MORE PEOPLE INTO MORE
EXPENSIVE- THAT. DOES YOUR
MISSION- BUT YES I WILL HAVE IT
OVER MORTGAGE. TO TREAT THE
CALVERT. THANK YOU. I TREES
ACCOUNTING AND ON YOUR CREDIT
THERE IS A NO I. FUNDING
PROVIDED FIRST YEAR P. AND THAT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN WOULD
NOT THERE ARE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT DO PROVIDE REBATES FOR
PRISM SO- THERE'S ALSO THE
CLEAN FUEL REWARDS FOR A
PROGRAM AND THERE ARE SOME
EXISTING. THE R. P. PROGRAM BUT
WANTING TO KNOW THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- IS REALLY THERE
TO. FOCUS ON REDUCING EMISSIONS
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
AS ADAM. ON SUCH A BIG SOURCE
FOR EMISSIONS AND ALSO I'M
GOING TO HAND IN HAND WITH
THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS AND I
NOTED THAT YOU PROVIDE REBATES
FOR SENSE THAT DO EXIST. FOR
FOLLOW UP HOUSE HELP WHAT'S THE
PLAN FOR PRIORITIZING
DEPLOYMENT YOU KNOW HOW IS THE
PROGRAM GOING TO BALANCE THE
INVESTMENTS THAT VOLKSWAGEN AND
THE I. O. U.'S ARE DOING RIGHT
NOW WE DO HAVE. A
INFRASTRUCTUREBEING BUILT HOW.
HOW DOES FINANCE PROPOSED IN
THE BUDGET TO DO THAT. I'M
LEVEL AB- PROGRAM BECOME A ON
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY AND WE MAY
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU I DO
HAVE- COLLEAGUES FROM THAT
TRANSIT ARE FROM THE ENERGY
AREA HERE I'M NOT SURE IF
THEY'RE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT
NOW IF THAT'S GOING TO BE
ANOTHER. OKAY MANAGER I HAVE
FIVE I'M WITH THE FOR US MOTHER
QUESTIONS AT OF BASICALLY IN
SEPT TWO ONE. DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TO MY COLLEAGUE-
FROM THOUSAND OAKS SENATORS
STERN SO. WITH THAT I'M DONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR REID KALECKI
SENATOR STERN YOU ARE UP IN THE
SENATOR MEN FOLLOWS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MY COMING THROUGH
OKAY. YES OKAY- SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AS
FAR AND ESPECIALLY THE-
COMMENTS FROM ALL MY
COLLEAGUES- OPENING LEVEL- JUST
WANTED NOTE OUTSIDE OF THE
BUDGET SEVEN TWO ARENA WERE
OMITTED. HAVE A COUPLE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS- APPRECIATE THE
INTENTION MY COLLEAGUES IN WHAT
ON SCHOOL RE OPENING SOME OF
THE CONCERNS FROM LOS ANGELES
ESPECIALLY I THINK SHOULD BE
NOTED. COURAGE STUDIES SEE SOME
MOVEMENT ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESSNESS I'M ESPECIALLY IN
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES AND
SOME OF THE CAL AIM INNOVATIONS
THAT ARE BEING LOOKED AT SO-
SEVENTY TO DO MORE WORK THERE
AS WELL AS IN DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- IN RESTORING
SEVENTY AYE YES S. FUNDING-
THAT IS SO SORELY NEEDED FOR.
THOSE WHO ARE ALL ALONE GOING
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND
HEALTH- WITHIN THE BUDGET SENT
TO ARENA THOUGH I WANT TO DRILL
DOWN ON WILDFIRE- AS WELL AS
THIS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
QUESTION SO MY FIRST QUESTION
IS ABOUT. ON THE WILD FIRE
FRONT- I WAS GOING THROUGH THE
DC PD HERE AND TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF. EXACTLY WHERE-
BILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED FOR
THE WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE STRATEGY IS HEADED.
AND YOU KNOW MY CONCERN HERE IS
THAT WHEN I LOOK AT THE FUNDING.
I KNOW FIRE SAFE COUNCILS HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT UP BY A DIVERSE
RANGE MEMBERS HERE BUT ACTUALLY
JOHNSON YOURS FOR JUST ONE
ELEMENT THAT IS. IMMUNITY ARMY
A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO SAY
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND SIMPLY-
LARGE SCALE FORESTRY MANAGEMENT
IN 10% THE KIND OF WORK THAT
HAPPENS AROUND COMMUNITIES LIKE
JUST EXPERIENCE THE ELDORADO
FIRE OR BLUE RIDGE- OR THE
VALLEY FIRE IN SAN DIEGO- WITH
BOBCAT FIRED L. A. COUNTY
HISTORICALLY. THESE COUNTIES
AND THESE PROJECTS HAVE
RECEIVED IT- SHORT SHRIFT. AND
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE ANY DIFFERENT. 4% I
THINK OF THE TOTAL BILLION IS.
WHEN YOU TOWARDS COMMUNITY
HARDENING LOOKS LIKE ABOUT 96%
TOWARDS A BROADER RANGE OF
FORCE. AND FORESTRY HEALTH
PROJECTS AND WHILE I EAT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ARE. SUPPORT
SOME OF THESE XCELERATED
FORESTRY HEALTH PROJECTS. YOU
TALKING ABOUT. CAPITA BASIS NOT
ON A PER ACRE BASIS BUT ON A
PER CAPITA BASIS WILDFIRE
FUNDING IS NOT BEING GOING TO
LARGE POPULATIONS THAT. AND SO
I WANTED TO GET A LITTLE SENSE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION OR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHAT.
WHAT THE STRATEGY IS HERE WHY
SUCH A SMALL AMOUNT FOR
COMMUNITY HARDENING AND WHY.
WHY NOT TRY TO RESTORE SOME OF
THE HISTORIC IMBALANCE THAT WE
SEEN 93% OF ALL FUNDS IN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION OVER THE
LAST FIVE OR FOUR YEARS SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. NINETY THREE
PERCENT- I'M GOING TO BE SORT
OF CHAMBER ORIENTED LARGER-
NORTHERN PROJECTS FOR LACK OF A
BETTER PROXY NOT JUST NORTHWEST
TENDS TO BE. AND WHEN YOU
COMBINE THE L. A. COUNTY ORANGE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO COUNTY SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IMPERIAL
COUNTY VENTURA COUNTY.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY- YOU'VE
RECEIVED ABOUT 3% OF THAT FUND.
SO THERE'S A MISMATCH HERE WANT
TO RAISE IT YOU'RE A QUICK
REACTION I KNOW IT IS GOING TO
TAKE A LOT MORE WORK. SO IS
YOUR IS YOUR BOX. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN- CAN I TURN THAT
QUESTION OVER TO ALLISON- OR
SOME A COLLEAGUE. A BI METALLIC
THANK YOU. I SENATOR STERN THIS
IS THE ALISON YOU IT DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I'M JUST BE QUESTION SO
COUPLE OF THE FIRST IS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT COMMUNITY HARDENING
WE THINK ABOUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS AND SUGGESTED SO THERE'S
A TWENTY FIVE MILLION THAT
SPECIFICALLY FOR KIND OF A HOME
IN TIP AND UNITY CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING
PROGRAM AND THAT'S WHRE YOU
FUNDS WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
GOLD TWO STRUCTURES IN AND
HURTING THEM AGAINST WILDFIRES.
BUT WE ALSO THINK ABOUT OUR-FIRED THAT DAY FUNDS THAT ARE
IN THE BUDGET OF WHICH THERE'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION SEE AN
EARLY ACTION AFTER THE FIRE
PREVENTION PROJECTS IS ALSO A
PART OF THAT COMMUNITY
HARDENING BUCKET BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY IF YOU BUILD A
STRATEGIC FUEL BREAK WHICH IS
WHAT WE'VE TURNED THE BUCKET
YOU'RE ALSO HURTING THE
COMMUNITY AGAINST WILDFIRE AND
PREVENTING INCURSIONS ARE JUST
TO SEE THAT WITHIN THE PACKAGE
AS A WHOLE. I THINK WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT COMMUNITY HARD
ENOUGH IT MORE BROADLY THAN
JUST THE ONE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUCKET THE OTHER
THING I WOULD I WOULD FLAG IS
THAT THERE IS SOME THINKING
HERE ABOUT TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT FUNDING IS APPLIED
STATEWIDE- SO THAT WE ARE
HITTING AREAS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE ALSO PRONE
TO FIRE RISK AND IN ONE
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE I WOULD SAY
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
HAS THE REGIONAL FIRE AND FORCE
CAPACITY PROGRAM. AND
SPECIFICALLY WITHIN SOME OF THE
TARGET A SPECIFIC FOCUS ON
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
BUILDING REGIONAL. CAPACITY IN
THOSE AREAS. RESTAURANT I KNOW
THAT THE- THAT REGIONAL. ITSELF.
SOME OF THE NEW IDEA ONCE YOU
READY TO ALL THE COUNTY I NAY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- ABOUT TWO
TWO MILLION. WHO HAVE GOT ABOUT
4% OF THE FUNDING OVER THE
YEARS THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME
RECTIFICATIONS HERE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL
ON THAT- I THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE. LASTLY I KNOW WE- HAD
A LONG HEARING HERE BUT ONLY
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- PROPOSAL-
D. W. R. CAL FIRE PARKS ARE
TRYING TO CHIP AWAY AT THEIR- I
THINK WHAT BILLION DOLLAR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BUDGET-
JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF-
WHAT WHY THIS AMOUNT IN THE ONE
TIME FUNDING PROPOSAL- AND-
WHAT. IS BEST IN LIGHT OF THE
INDUSTRY OPERATING DEFICITS
GOING FORWARD IN THE COMING
YEARS ISN'T IS A GOOD YEAR TO.
BE TAKEN CARE OF. MORE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. YES THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION AND I THINK- AND
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BALK
AT AS IT WERE- IS ATTEMPTING
TO- DEAL WITH SOME OF THAT. THE
MAINTENANCE OF OUR- OUR STATE-
PROPERTIES AND IN REGARDS TO
THE AMOUNT- I THINK THAT WE
DIDN'T WANT TO SPEND DOLLARS-
I'M I'M HIGHER DAYS INCLUDING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND THAT
THAT'S SORT OF WHERE IT ENDED
UP BUT- I WILL I WILL I HANDED
OVER TO. MY COLLEAGUE FOR MORE
SPECIFIC- THE HEALTH. HI TERRY
SAID HOWARD WITH FINANCE AGAIN.
DETAIL OTHER THAN TO NOTE THAT
IT IS A BALANCE OF- FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR THESE PURPOSES
AND ALSO BALANCING WITH THE
PRIORITIES OF THOSE THOSE
ENTITIES YOU MENTIONED- FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WHICH ALSO
HAS ENTITIES OUTSIDE OF THAT
THE RESOURCES. AREA AS WELL.
YOU GUYS ARE THERE ANY PLANNED
THOUGH FOR THE- I GUESS SEVERAL
BILLION DOLLARS OF. I'M
STANDING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
EVEN IF WE SIGN THIS FOR THE
OUT YEARS IS THEIR LONG TERM
THINKING ON THIS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FEES. THE PROPOSAL
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT I MEAN WE
CONTINUE TO REVIEW THAT AND AS
YOU NOTED THERE ARE A LOT OF
DEFERRED. MAINTENANCE NEEDS FOR
STATE PROPERTIES. OKAY THANKS
FOR FOLLOWING UP WITH YOU THERE
AND DINNER DEEPER AND ALL THIS.
MANAGER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN NOW SENATOR MEN.
I COME IN CLEAR. YES YOU ARE A
FANTASTIC FIRST I JUST WANTED
TO SAY- I APPRECIATE THE
BRIEFING AND- THIS IS MY FIRST
BUT IT HEARING- THERE'S A
SAYING FROM THE GREEKS THAT
REALLY SPEAKS TO ME A
CIVILIZATION'S GREAT WHEN ITS
ELDERS PLANT TREES WHOSE SHADE
THEY KNOW THE NUMBER SAID IN AN
I AIN'T LOOKING CLOSELY THIS
BUDGET IT SEEMS TO REFLECT THAT
GENERAL LONG TERM IS TO
APPROACH- THAT THAT I THINK IS
SO IMPORTANT- WHILE ALSO
CONVEYING A STRONG EMPATHY IS
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
NOTED- I WANTED TO TURN BACK
TO. THE TOPIC OF EDUCATION AND
SCHOOLS- NINETY TWO QUESTIONS
ONE RELATED TO THE K. TO TWELVE
PIECE AND ANOTHER RELATED TO
HIRE ADD ON THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE SIDE. FOR UP ON- MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR LAYERS
COMMENTS- I'M A DAD TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL KIDS I'VE GOT A THIRD
ONE THAT'LL DURING KINDERGARTEN
NEXT FALL. HI THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
PERSONAL TO ME. BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT MAYBE THE
INFLEXIBILITY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH AND I JUST WANTED TO
DIG IN A LITTLE BIT. THERE I'VE
GOT SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT THAT
TELL ME THEY'RE READY TO GO
RIGHT NOW TO RE OPEN AND DO IN
PERSON LEARNING THEY DON'T NEED
MUCH AND AS WELL AS FAR AS
RESOURCES. I'VE GOT SCHOOLS
THAT TELL ME THAT THAT FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLAR AMOUNT I
NOT GONNA BE NEARLY ENOUGH FOR
THEM. I EASIEST TOO MUCH OF A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH IN I
GUESS I'D BE INTEREST IN
PRACTICE IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
CAN BE COMMUNICATED TO US.
THROUGH THE BUDGET SUB ONE CAN
MEET SUBCOMMITTEE- BUT- YOU
KNOW WHAT WAS THE BASIS FOR
THAT FIGURE IN THAT PARTICULAR
AMOUNT OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER
RELATED QUESTION IS DOES THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM. MAYBE
PROVIDE THE WRONG INCENTIVES TO
TRY TO RE OPENED EARLY RATHER
THAN SAFELY- YOU KNOW YOU GET
THIS POT OF MONEY FOR OPENING
ON ON DEMAND AND- YES I THINK
CENTER LAYERED COMMENTED QUITE
ELOQUENTLY ON. SO THE PROBLEM
WITH THE DEADLINES BUT BUT DOES
THIS KIND OF THING I THINK AS
FAR AS- INCENTIVES AND WE'RE-
CREATING AN- INCENTIVE HERE FOR
SCHOOLS TO OPEN. QUICKLY BUT
MAYBE NOT NECESSARILY SAFELY
AND IS THERE SOME FLEXIBILITY
OUR WAY TO. TAILOR THIS A
LITTLE BIT MORE BASED ON- THE
DISTRICTS AND SO- I GUESS
THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION AND
THEN- PERHAPS ALL. ALL AS MY
SECOND QUESTION A MOMENT. THANK
YOU THAT QUESTION AND I THINK
THAT I WOULD UNDERSCORE THAT ON
THE GOVERNOR MENTIONED AND IT
IS FRESH HOW COMPANIES LAST
WEEK AND- IF WE CAN'T BRING
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS BACK.
SAFELY TO SCHOOL THEN WE
SHOULDN'T BRING THEM BACK
SAFELY WE CAN BRING THEM BACK
TO SCHOOL AND SO THAT THE
DOLLARS THAT ARE PROVIDED A
REALLY TO- GIVE IT. TO SUPPORT
THE SCHOOLS IN WHATEVER IT IS
THAT THEY THINK THEY NEED TO DO
SO WHETHER IT'S P. P. AGAINST.
BUT OTHER RESOURCES- IT'S
TESTING OR CONTACT TRACING- WE
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT TO THE SCHOOL SO
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS. AND OTHER
VIOLATIONS NOT BE GOING INTO AN
UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT AND SO I
JUST WANT TO. MAKE SURE THAT
THAT. THAT UNDERSCORED- AND I
THINK THAT THE PLANT WAS-
INFORMED BY COMMUNICATION BACK
AND FORTH AND CONTINUES TO BE
INFORMED WITH THAT
COMMUNICATION. WITH THE HOPE
AND UNDERSTANDING THAT- LOCAL-
LIAISE WILL DISTRICTS WILL DO
WHAT THEY NEED FOR THEIR
STUDENTS- AND THAT THAT THAT
FLEXIBILITY REALLY DOES NEED TO
BE THERE IT ISN'T A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL. AND IT SHOULDN'T BE
BECAUSE WE HAVE MILLIONS OF.
KIDS ACROSS THOUSANDS- SCHOOLS-
THAT NEED TO BE. THERE NEEDS
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED SO JUST
WANT TO. SAY THAT- YOU KNOW THE
PLAN WAS NOT CREATED IN A
VACUUM AND HAS BEEN INFORMED
AND CONTINUES TO BE INFORMED.
THROUGH ENGAGEMENT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. I GUESS IS AVAILABLE ARE
ARE THERE GONNA BE KIND OF
MEASURE BURKE SAVED BY ARE CAN.
DOES YOUR THAT. ARE EACH OF THE
ELEAZAR AIDS ACTUALLY BY
DOCKING BEST PRACTICES. YES
I'LL HAVE TO GET TO A HIGH
LEVEL ON THAT AND THEN- MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA HOLMES MAY
HAVE THE DETAILS BUT ABSOLUTELY
THAT THE IDEAS TO REALLY
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY AND IN
WHAT. SCHOOLS ARE DOING SO THAT
PARENTS AND OTHERS CAN FEEL
THAT THEY CAN TRUST WHAT'S
HAPPENING- IN IN REGARDS TO
METRICS I'M GONNA TURN THAT
OVER TO- MY COLLEAGUE JESSICA
HOME. YES THANK YOU AND JUST GO
HOME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
AND THE GOVERNOR ACTUALLY HERE
IN AND- AT PRESS OFFICE JUST
RELEASED- THE NEW SCHOOL AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
UNDERCOVER NINETEEN TO THAT BUT
NEAR THE GET THE GUIDANCE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY GUIDANCE THAT
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING AND HAS
JUST BEEN RELEASED ANTI
ENCOURAGE FOLKS TAKE A LOOK
THERE BECAUSE I THINK. THAT
REALLY IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECES OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS- BE A BUILDING OFF
OF THAT HEALTH AND SAFETY
GUIDANCE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
USING THE MOST RECENT SCIENCE
AVAILABLE- TO SET. AT TO PUT
AND SOME GUIDELINES TO HELP
SCHOOLS REOPEN SAFELY THEY JUST
WANTED TO FLAG THAT- IN
ADDITION. IN ADDITION TO THE
NEW GUIDANCE- WE ARE.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
WORKING WITH LOCAL HEALTH
AGENCIES. TO SET UP A- AT
BASICALLY FOR LACK OF A BETTER
TERM HOTLINE NUMBER. AND UP
PROCESS AN ONLINE PROCESS FOR
PARENTS. STAFF TO MAKE. IT TO
FLAG ISSUES THAT THEY THINK AND
COLDER HAVING WITH HEALTH AND
SAFETY- BETTER HAPPENING IN
REAL TIME SO THAT THEY CAN
APPLY THOSE FOR THEIR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS IN THIS
ISSUE CAN BE INVESTIGATED THAT
THE REALLY ANOTHER REALLY. AND
THAT THE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO. THANK YOU IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I'M SURE WE CAN FOLLOW
UP LATER- BUT I JUST WANT TO
ONE OF MY SECOND QUESTION- SO
AS I'M LIKE. A MONTH AND A HALF%
AGO I WAS FACULTY AT UC IRVINE
I NOW HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING AT UNIVERSITY IN
MY DISTRICT. I AND SO I WANTED
TO TALK ABOUT HIGHER ED- YEAH I
KNOW YOU KNOW THAT THEY HAVE A
3% INCREASE BUT THAT I BELIEVE
WAS ON TOP OF A TEN PERCENT.
CUT FROM THE PREVIOUS BUDGET
CYCLE- INSTILLING BACK I THINK
THE BIG HAVE EIGHT SIGNIFICANT.
CUT FROM. THE PRE COALBED
BUDGET. I AND I KNOW FROM
PERSONAL OBSERVATION THAT THAT
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS ARE PUBLIC AND
UNIVERSITIES ARE FACING
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES. HI
THERE LOSING SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE STREAMS- THEY'RE HAVING
TO ADAPT TO NEW CHALLENGES- AND
SO WHILE I'M PLEASED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT PLAN
ANY TUITION INCREASES. I GUESS
I'M CONCERNED THAT WE MAY NOT
BE DOING ENOUGH OR OUR OUR
FINAL AGAINST HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS HERE. I IS THE
PLAN TO DO SOMETHING GOING
FORWARD ARE SORTED IS THIS JUST
KIND OF. WILL WE RESTORE THOSE
10% AT SOME POINT AND SO WHAT'S
THE. LONG TERM A PLAN HERE. OUR
YEAH WE HAVE THAT BEEN- GETTING
BACK. AS AS I WOULD JUST THAT-
THE PLAN WAS NOT NECESSARILY
TO- RESTORE CUTS BUT TO REALLY
HELP OR WE COULD AN OBVIOUSLY
THREE PERCENT- BASED INCREASE.
ALONG WITH- SEVERAL MORE I'M
GOING AND ONE TIME COSTS WILL
HELP SUPPORT THE MISSION OF ALL
THE SYSTEMS. THAT ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THERE IS.
ADDITIONAL GENERAL- ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S COMING
IN- WE'RE LOOKING AT ABOUT TWO
POINT NINE BILLION FOR THE UC
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COMING INTO THIS MOST RECENT
STIMULUS. PACKAGE AND THERE IS
ALSO BILLIONS IN PRIOR PACKAGES
AS WELL AND SO I THINK IN IN IN.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT
AGAIN THROUGH THIS BREEDING OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF FUNDING
SOURCES TO PROVIDE THE SPORTS
OR WE CAN TO OUR HIGHER.
EDUCATION SYSTEMS AND KNOWLEDGE
AND THAT THEY HAVE BEEN-
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
PARTICULARLY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND- THE STUDENTS.
THERE AND SO- THE FEDERAL FINES
I THINK WE'LL DO- A LOT TO HELP
AND THEY HAVE AS WELL IN THE
PAST PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES
TO EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID-
WHICH ARE BUDGET ADDRESSES AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MANAGER. I GUESS JUST TO BE
CLEAR I'M DONE MANAGER.
THE
ACTING CHAIR WILL RECOGNIZE
MISS EGGMAN PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER ACTING CHAIR- ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE ISSUES OF- OF NOT
KNOWING HOW TO. RAISE YOUR HAND
ON THE OF THE S. COMPUTER IS
THAT YOU GO TOWARDS THE END AND
EVERYTHING'S BEEN ASKED SO. OF
COURSE WOULD LIKE TO LINE SO MY
COMMENTS WITH THE- CENTER
LAYERED AROUND EDUCATION I HAVE
CERTAINLY HEARD FROM MY
DISTRICT SAID. IT'S
UNREASONABLE TIME LINE THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO MEET AND
THEY'D LIKE MORE JUST TO PAY
DOWN DEFERRALS- ILAM SOME MY
COMMENTS WITH ISSUES AROUND
EDT. AND THE FRUSTRATION FROM
CALIFORNIANS- AND THEN IT TOO
MIGHT. YOU KNOW WE STRUGGLE
BETWEEN DOING THINGS TO THE
BUDGET THAT ARE POLICY OR THAN
TRYING TO DO POLICY THAT
REQUIRES FUNDING- SO I
APPRECIATE HOW MUCH YOU PUT IN
FOR MENTAL HEALTH BUT I THINK
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER ISSUE
THAT- IS ON THE FOREFRONT OF
CALIFORNIA'S MIND BESIDES EDM
AND THE ECONOMY CO IT IS THAT
THE ISSUES AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
AND HOMELESSNESS AND HOW THOSE.
HOW THOSE INTERSECT SO- I KNOW
MYSELF AND A LOT OF MY PEERS
REALLY WANNA WORK ON THAT THIS
YEAR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SO. IF YOU NEED
IDEAS PLEASE DON'T HESITATE TO
REACH OUT- AND I THINK WE SEE
IT WITH THE CHRONIC AND
PERSISTENT POPULATION BUT THEN
I WOULD OFFER THERE IS NOT ONE
OF US. ATTENDING THIS. BUDGET
HEARING RIGHT NOW WHO HAS NOT
FELT AN INCREASE IN ANXIETY AND
I'M EASE- UNKNOWN. AND SO YOU
KNOW YOU PUT THAT ON TOP OF
THAT BEING HOMELESS OR- LIVING
IN AN ABUSIVE SITUATION AND WE
JUST KNOW THAT JUST FOR THE
GENERAL POPULATION. ISSUES
AROUND MENTAL HEALTH WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW SO AS MUCH AS
WE CAN DO INTO THE SCHOOLS-
IT'S GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT-
AND THEN I GUESS JUST. JUST TO
BE ABLE TO ASK THE KIND OF THE
MIRACLE QUESTION IF WE DEAL.
WITH STARKEY- SO. SOME OF THE
EARLIER PREDICTIONS WERE I
THINK TWENTY SIX BILLION FOR-
THE WINDFALL AND NOW IT'S
STANDARD FIFTEEN. HOW CONFIDENT
ARE WE THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
GET EVEN FURTHER BY THE TIME
THE MAY REVISE COMES AND THEN
HOW WE MAKE THAT ADJUSTMENT.
BUT I GUESS MY ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT QUESTION IS THE
IDEA OF- IF WE GET A HUGE
INFUSION OF FEDERAL FUNDS-
WHERE THEN WOULD WE TAKE THE
GENERAL FUND MONEY AND INFUSE
IT BACK IN TO THE BUDGET WRITES
A LETTER THAT SAYS KIND
AMERICAN QUESTION MY IF YOU
pMIGHT BE GETTING SOME MORE.
WHERE MOST FOCUSED DO YOU THINK
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD INVEST. I
WOULD LIE IF I WON THE LOTTERY
KIND OF QUESTION- IT WAS
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS WERE NOT
COUNTING ON RIGHT NOW WHAT WILL
WE DO WITH OUR MONEY- I LOVE
THE QUESTION I WOULD SAY THAT
GENERALLY IF. WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES GIVE US MONEY
WE DO LOOK FOR PLACES IF IT'S
IF IT'S- POSSIBLE. TO BACK FILL
FOR THE GENERAL FUND SO THAT WE
CAN USE THOSE PRECIOUS DOLLARS
ON ANOTHER- STATE PRIORITIES.
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE
ALL THE FEDERAL FUNDING GET
WHENEVER. THE BILL AND THAT
INCLUDES FOR THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND- OUR ARTICLE IN
RESPONSE AND TRYING TO. GET
BACK FEMA REIMBURSEMENTS FOR A
LOT OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
SPENDING- STATE MONEY FOR UP
FRONT- AND I GUESS YOUR
QUESTION REALLY IS- IS YOU KNOW
WHERE WHERE DO ALL OF OUR
PRIORITIES LIE AND I WOULD SAY
AGAIN THIS IS- A GIVE AND TAKE.
AND DEFINITELY MUCH MORE
CONVERSATION WILL OCCUR IN THE
SPRING- BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE A
POINT THAT- OUR OUR ECONOMICS-
UNIT- HAS COME OUT WITH-
ADDITIONAL REVENUES AND FROM
DECEMBER ABOVE THE FORECASTED
IN OUR CURRENT- THE- GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION. IN REVENUES FROM
DECEMBER AGAIN ABOUT WHAT WE
HAVE FORECASTED BUT I WOULD
ALSO SAY IT'S VERY TENUOUS TO
EXPECT THAT THAT WILL HAPPEN
FOR EVERY MONTH UNTIL FOR THIS
CURRENT YEAR AND SO WE WILL WE
WILL. BE BACK AGAIN AND THE
REVISION WITH FINAL REVENUES
AND- EXPENDITURES AND HAVE A
MUCH BETTER SENSE- OF WHERE WE
ARE AND WHAT WE CAN DO IF WE DO
HAVE THAT- YOU KNOW IT
ADDITIONAL WINDFALL ABOUT THE-
THE FIFTEEN HOUR OR WHEN FALL
SURPLUS EXTRA MONEY WHATEVER
YOU WANNA CALL IT ABOVE. WHAT
WE CURRENTLY. HAVE IN THE
BUDGET AT FIFTEEN BILLION. AND
THEN JUST A ONE FINAL. AND YOU
ALL FOR ALL YOU WERE IN. THIS
OVER SO AND A LOOK FORWARD TO.
SPEAKING IN THE- SO HEARINGS
BUT I WAS VERY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S ALL THE SIXTY FIVE
YEAR COULD HAVE A VACCINE NOW
BUT- THAT YOU KNOW IT'S CREATED
A BUNCH OF LOGISTICAL ISSUES I
THINK. A LOT OF OUR- COUNTY
LEVEL PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTORS
WHO ARE ALREADY. OVERWHELMED
WITH THE PANDEMIC AND DEALING
WITH. NOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
FOLKS EXPECTING OUT- THE
VACCINE SO I CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT WE'RE GONNA. REALLY PUSH
THOSE VACCINES OUT. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GOT WHAT WE
KEEPING OUR WORD AND NOT. A
FURTHER DISAPPOINTING THE
PUBLIC THANK. SURE AND I WOULD
JUST HIGHLIGHT IS WITH THIS IS
NOT DONE BEFORE AND THAT THAT
IS MY MISTAKE IS THAT WE DO
HAVE DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET THAT
WE HAVE- BASICALLY ESTIMATED
TOWARDS VACCINE DISTRIBUTION.
AND OBVIOUSLY THERE NEEDS TO BE
A LOT OF COORDINATION AND
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN. THE
STATE AND LOCALS AND IN REGARDS
TO JUST THAT PROCESS YOU
MENTIONED- ABOUT- PART OF IT IS
COMMUNICATION AND PART OF IT IS
IT JUST TAKES A PART OF IT IS.
JUST ABOUT THE PROCESS OF-
WORKING DID HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM- AND WITH COUNTIES AND
SO- THE MONEY IS THERE FOR- A
SUCCESSFUL DISTRIBUTION OF
VACCINE SO THAT WE CAN GET. AS
MANY PEOPLE VACCINATED AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR EGGMAN WORDS THAT
YOU'RE DID YOU HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION OR WAS IT THANK YOU
OKAY GREAT NKS
WILL NOW GO TO SENATOR NEWMAN.
PATIENT SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO- TO THE FINANCIAL SIDE
MEYER YOUR STAMINA AND YOUR
GOOD NATURE TODAY. REAL QUICK
QUESTION AND IF I MISS IT I
APOLOGIZE IN THE- BUDGET
OVERVIEW WHICH SEEMS LIKE DAYS
AGO. THERE WASN'T MUCH AS I
RECALL REGARDING CHILD CARE AND
CHILD CARE FUNDING AND PLANNING
FOR. A CHILD CARE FUNDING AS
YOU KNOW- CHILD CARE FACILITIES
ACROSS THE STATE BOTH PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZING PRIVATE HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY THE RECESSION- IF
YOU COULD JUST GIVE US A QUICK
OVERVIEW ON PLANS AND THINKING.
AS IT RELATES TO FUNDING FOR
CHILD CARE AND CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS- I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT WE ARE EXPECTING A BILLION
DOLLARS TO COME FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THIS LAST
STIMULUS PACKAGE SPECIFICALLY
FOR CHILD CARE- AND OBVIOUSLY-
PLANS AND DISCUSSIONS. FOR THE
DISCUSSIONS MAJOR KERR IN
REGARDS TO DON AND- POTENTIALLY
MORE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING- BUT
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO JESSICA
HOMES TO GIVE YOU. A SENSE OF
MORE THE DETAIL AND WHAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN FOR CHILD CARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST GO
HOME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
THE BUDGET INCLUDES- AN ONGOING
ALLOCATION OF FORTY FOUR
MILLION CANNABIS AND TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CHILD CARE.
AS WELL AS FIFTY FIVE MILLION A
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- FOR
COULD RESPOND- FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
MISLEAD AT MICHELINE MENTIONED-
WE ARE ANTICIPATING AN
ADDITIONAL BILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO- INCORPORATE
INTO THE BUDGET HOWEVER I WOULD
NOTE THAT. SB EIGHT TWENTY FROM
LAST SESSION AND IT'S NOT A
POSITIVE TRIGGER FOR CHILD CARE
FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY WERE. PROVIDED AND-
THAT PROVIDE US WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO ALLOCATE IT TO
THREE HUNDRED MILLION OF THOSE
FUNDS FOR THINGS LIKE-
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS FOR
PROVIDERS WHO WERE FORCED TO
CLOSE BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC-
EXTENDING CARE FOR SPECIAL
WORKERS- AND THAT AS WELL AS RE
OPENING COST YOUR PROVIDERS AND
SOME OTHER THINGS AS WELL SO.
AMBER CERTAINLY AWAITING TO BE
AWARDED BEST PLAN. THAT WE CAN
GET THEM OUT VERY QUICKLY
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS AT
THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION IN
ORDER TO GET THOSE OUT QUICKLY-
BUT THERE WILL BE SOME
ADDITIONAL- SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO.
APPROXIMATELY TO LOOK AT IN
TERMS OF- FURTHER INVESTMENTS
IN THIS SPACE AND SO WE- HAVE
STARTED TO REACH OUT TO AND
YOUR STAFF AND STAFF INTO THE
COMMITTEES THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- ON WHAT. WE NEED TO
DO IN ORDER TO GET BEACH THESE
FUNDS ALLOCATED AND. WHAT THE
PRIORITIES TO BE FOR THEM. SO I
DO APPRECIATE THAT A LOT FOR
CONTINUE KIND OF. THANK SENATOR
NEWMAN THANK YOU FOR ASKING THE
COURT. I HAVEN'T- ADDING IN TO
WHAT ELSE QUESTION BUT IT DID
OCCUR TO ME THAT. CLEARLY WHEN
I REFERENCED IN THE OPENING OF
THE HEARING THAT THE LATEST
DATA IN DECEMBER FROM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT. THE JOB LOSS
THE MOST RECENT JOB LOSS WAS
ALMOST A HUNDRED PERCENT. OF
FELT AMONG WOMEN THAT A GOOD
DEAL OF THAT WAS CHILD CARE
WORKERS NOT ALL OBVIOUSLY AND
THAT IN GENERAL ARE CHILD CARE
WORKERS ARE PRETTY LOW WAGE
WORKERS SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE IMPACT HOW WE KNOW THAT
THIS PANDEMIC HAS. INCREASED
THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES IN
POVERTY THAT CERTAINLY AN
ASPECT BUT IT DIRECTIONALLY WE
WILL- WE ARE I THINK ALL OF US
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OBVIOUSLY ALSO- WE ARE. TRYING
TO- NOT TRYING WE ARE ORIENTING
A BUDGET TOWARDS- A CALIFORNIA
THAT IS BACK TO FUNCTIONING AND
ECONOMICALLY ROBUST. AND OF
COURSE WE KNOW THAT ONCE. DID
VIRUSES UNDER CONTROL AND
PEOPLE ARE BACK AT WORK CHILD
CARE WILL BE ESSENTIAL SO
OBVIOUSLY WE DO NOT WANT TO
LOSE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR ASKING THAT
QUESTION. AND NOW WE WILL GO
TO. SENATOR CAFIERO AND THEN
FOLLOWED THAT DOCTOR PAN
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE RURAL CALIFORNIA SHUT
DOWN MIKE FOR SENATOR CAFIERO.
SALAS HAPPENS TO RURAL ROUTE
RULE RESIDENCIA SHUT OFF THE
MIKE HOPE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- YOU KNOW THAT
THIS- CORONA VIRUSES REALLY-
IT. PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON THE
ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
FAIL TO ADDRESS- WHETHER IT'S
BROADBAND OVER HOW TO CURB OVER
CROWDED HOUSING. OR THE LACK OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR OUR
POOREST RESIDENTS- DOES.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY EVENT
DETRIMENTALLY AFFECTED AND- YOU
KNOW ON THE BROADBAND ISSUE THE
TWO LITTLE GIRLS SITTING IN
FRONT TO TALK ABOUT. BECAUSE
THERE WAS INTERNET ACCESS THERE
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THEIR SCHOOL- EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM THAT WAS IN MY
COMMUNITY IN MY DISTRICT- AND
THAT'S NOT UNUSUAL- SO I WANT
TO SAY THAT BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
BE VERY. DELIBERATE ABOUT HOW
WE TAKE IT THE REVENUE THAT WE
HAVE NOW AND HOW WE INVESTED
IN- IN OUR RESIDENTS SO THAT WE
CAN GET THE BEST OUTCOME
POSSIBLE. WE NEED TO WORK AS
DILIGENTLY AS POSSIBLE TO PULL
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WE CAN
AND THEN COME UP. TO GET
TOGETHER- AND TO HELP TO
STARTED DRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AND WE NEED TO- ENGAGE
THE LEGISLATURE I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT BECAUSE ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS ARE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY AND WE'RE FACING
THIS PANDEMIC A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY AS WELL- N. AS A AS
A FOOTNOTE- THIS IS REALLY BEEN
A- A TOUGH YEAR. AND THE TOUGH
YEAR HAS FALLING
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON THE
POOREST MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE ONE SHINING
LIGHT IS THE VACCINE. AND SO- I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB BECAUSE AS I
HAVE CALLED AROUND TO FIND OUT
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF THE
VACCINE- THERE IS CONFUSION.
AND THERE'S DISAGREEMENT OVER
HOW THE TIERED SYSTEM WORKS AND
WOOD AND THAT IS THE ONE
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO SHOW
THAT GOVERNMENT CAN FUNCTION
WELL IN THAT WERE WORKING
TOGETHER AND THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GET THIS ONE RIGHT SO I WANT
TO JUST SAY THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE. BUT WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT. WHO SHOULD BE
RECEIVING THE VACCINE RIGHT NOW
WE NEED TO MOVE WITH ALL DUE
DELIBERATE SPEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY GET INTO PEOPLE'S
ARMS SO I JUST SAY I'VE GOT I
SOME QUESTION ABOUT. BUT BUDGET
SUB FOR I WON'T. BELABOR A LOT
OF IT BUT IF YOU COULD TELL US-
THAT THAT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE- SMALL BIT
BUSINESS GRANT. A PROPOSAL THAT
THE GOVERNOR. ROLLED OUT. USING
THIS YEAR'S- I'M RESOURCES AND
THEN HE'S HE ADDS FIVE HUNDRED
AND 500-005-0065 THOUSAND.
MILLION I'M SORRY DOLLARS
EXTRA- THE APPLICATION. EACH
CLOSE EITHER YESTERDAY OR TODAY
AND I WONDER IF YOU COULD TELL
US HOW MANY. OF THIS THESE ARE
THE SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS HOW
MANY APPLICATIONS GO BIZ HAS
RECEIVED SO FAR BOTH IN TERMS
OF NUMBERS OF APPLICATIONS AND-
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY REQUESTED
AND- IF YOU COULD ALSO
ELABORATE ON HOW GRANT GRANTEES
WILL BE SELECTED. YES I'M GOING
TO ASK MY COLLEAGUE WENT HOME
TO ANSWER SOME OF THE DETAILS
OF THAT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON- SO THE GRANT PROGRAM
DID CLOSE LAST NIGHT- IT BUT AT
THIS POINT WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC FIGURES TO PROVIDE YOU
ON THE PRECISE NUMBER OF
ALLOCATIONS. AS OF YESTERDAY IT
WAS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS-
THERE COULD BE SOME DUPLICATION
IN THERE BUT I DON'T EXPECT
THAT IT EXPECTED TO BE
SOMEWHERE IN THAT ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE- WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIFICS ON THE AMOUNTS
REQUEST AT THIS POINT SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET THAT TO
YOU- THIS SOON AS IT'S
AVAILABLE THE NEXT. DAY OR TWO-
AS IT RELATES TO THE SCORING
CRITERIA. IT'S GOING TO BE ON
THREE PRINCIPAL AREAS-
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION BASED
ON THE CODE NINETEEN HEALTH AND
SAFETY RESTRICTIONS- ACROSS THE
STATE. THAT BENEFITS THE
INDUSTRIES MOST IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. AND THEN IT'S LOOKING
OUT UNDER CENTER SEARCH SMALL
BUSINESS GROUPS- ACROSS THE
STATE SO THAT MIGHT BE.
MAJORITY OWNED OR AROUND THE
DAILY BASIS BY WOMEN MINORITIES
PEOPLE OF COLOR VETERANS
BUSINESSES LOCATED IN THE LOW.
TO MODERATE INCOME IN RURAL
AREAS. VERY GOOD THANK YOU I
EXPECT TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE DATA IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBERS AYE AYE. THE PURPOSE OF
THAT OBVIOUSLY IS TO FIX IT IS
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE RIGHT
SIZE- WHETHER WE NEED TO ADD
MORE MONEY TO PRODUCE. TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM OR NOT.
MOVING ON TO THE CAPTAIN PIZZA
GRANT PROGRAM THIS THIS IS-
ANTICIPATED BE A PROGRAM THAT
WOULD HELP BUSINESSES THAT WANT
TO EXPAND. AND CAN YOU DEFINE
OR ELABORATE WHAT QUALIFIES AS
A HIGH NEED HIGH OPPORTUNITY
AREA- AND THEN MY SECOND
CONCERN IS- IF IN FACT.
COMPANIES COULD. OBTAIN A
GRANT. AND HOW THAT HAVE NO OR
LITTLE TAX LIABILITY IN THE
STATE WHAT WOULD PREVENT THEM
FROM. RECEIVING A GRANT AND
THEN TURNING AROUND AND LEAVING
THE STATE IN THE YEAR TWO. HI
THIS IS GOING TO COME AGAIN- AS
IT RELATES TO THE DEFINITION
AND WE'RE STILL SORT OF WORKING
THROUGH HOW I'M HOW PRECISELY
DEFINED THAT WERE ACTUALLY SORT
OF HOPING TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
FOR YOU- THE GUIDELINE PROCESS
IN KALKAJI. THE IDEA HERE IS
THAT- LOOKING AT REGIONS OF THE
STATE THAT- YOU COULD USE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND SORT OF EVEN PRIOR
TO COVER NINETEEN AND- RECOVERY
FROM THE- GREAT RECESSION AND
THOSE AREAS WHERE WHERE WHERE
THE- RECOVERY DIDN'T YOU KNOW
MEET OUR ORDER WAS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH THE REST OF THE
STATE SO AND THEN THERE'S
NUANCE AND THEIR ANSWER SO
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THIS IS AS
FLEXIBLE AS POSSIBLE THAT. YOU
KNOW THAT EVEN IF IT'S IN AN
INDUSTRIAL AREA NEAR LOW INCOME
AREA THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY PUT
SOMETHING IN BECAUSE FOLKS IN
THOSE AREAS CAN'T GO TO WORK-
JUST ACROSS THE STREET SO
THERE'S CHALLENGES WITH GETTING
TO SPUR SCRIPTED AMMAN SO WE'RE
TRYING TO PUT OUT A DEFINITION
TO SERVE THE INTENDED PURPOSE
WITHOUT BEING OVERLY LIMITED-
BY A STATUTE IN THE FUTURE- AND
THEN- AB. FORGETTING YOUR OTHER
QUESTION- I'M SORRY IT WAS THAT
HAD TO DO WITH- THE FACT. THAT
IF WE IN FACT. GRANT
ACCOMPANIED DOESN'T PAY. IN THE
STATE OF A GRAY TO COME THAT
DOESN'T PAY TAXES IN THE STATE-
WHAT WOULD KEEP THEM FROM
LEAVING THE STATE NEAR TO ONCE
THEY TAKE THE GRANT. USE IT AND
THEN LEAVE. YEAH SO WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT- RECAPTURE OR
COLLECTION OPTIONS THAT CURRENT
CAL COMPETES PROGRAM. DOES HAVE
A RECAPTURE IF THEY DON'T NEED
THAT- CRITERIA AS LAID OUT IN
THE AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE STATE
MORE BUSINESS. SO WHERE-
LOOKING AT IT YOU KNOW. THE
BEST WAYS TO GO ABOUT DOING
THAT WHEN THE WHEN THE MET-
THAT BUSINESS DOESN'T NEED-
AGREED UPON- PLAN. VERY GOOD SO
THAT THE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
HIGH NEED IN HIGH OPPORTUNITY
AREAS I WOULD I WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT WE WORK DILIGENTLY
TOGETHER I BELIEVE THAT'S ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WAS RAISED
BY MY COLLEAGUE. THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT. ABOUT
EXACTLY HOW THAT WOULD ROLL OUT
AND WHAT KIND OF BUSINESSES
COULD BENEFIT AND WHAT KIND OF
JOBS ARE BEING CREATED IN IN IN
THOSE BUSINESSES SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR ANSWER. AND
THEN IN REGARDS TO THE- KELLY
ITC. THIS PROGRAM HAS RECEIVED
A LOT OF SUPPORT IN THE
LEGISLATURE. BECAUSE IT HAS A
PROVEN RECORD OF FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGING THE LIVES OF FOUR
PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING AND SO-
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE.
RETURNING TO CALLIE ITC IS ONE
OF THE WAYS TO GET CHECKS OUT
TO THE MOST. THE PEOPLE THAT
OUR NEEDIEST IN OUR COMMUNITY.
ARE THERE ANY- ANY RESTRICTIONS
ON KALECKI ITC ELIGIBILITY OR
TRENDS IN CLAIMING CAL EITC LET
ME TELL YOU THE REASON FOR THIS
IS THAT. ON THE PART OF THE
CHALLENGE WITH WITH THE EITC
PROGRAM IS THE UPTAKE. D.
INFORMATION OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
PEOPLE ARE ELIGIBLE AND BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO FILE A TAX RETURN
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO GET A
CHECK- LAST YEAR- A BILL WAS
PASSED THAT ASKED EVERY FIFTEEN
BE TO WORK WITH THAT- AND
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS THAT
COLLECT INFORMATION ABOUT FIVE
CALIFORNIANS. INCOME TO FIGURE
OUT IF THERE IS A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEM A CHECK
AUTOMATICALLY SO I GUESS I'M
I'M ASKING IN THIS QUESTION
WHETHER ONLY THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE FILED UP TO THIS
POINT- THEIR THEIR TAXES WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM
AND IS THERE ANY POSSIBILITY
THAT WE CAN GO BEYOND THAT
BECAUSE THE MOST. THE MOST
NEEDY MAY BE THE ONES THAT
DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR IT. YES I LET ME
ANSWER THAT QUESTION IN A
COUPLE WAYS ONE IS THAT YOU'RE
RIGHT WE HAVE HAD- FUNDING IN
THE LAST FEW BUDGETS FOR EITC
OUR REACH- BROUGH AT TV AND SO
THERE'S BEEN WAYS. THERE BEEN
THERE'S BEEN FUNDING TO ATTEMPT
TO GET THE WORD OUT THERE AND
YOU SAY- AND THEN SECONDLY. BE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS WAS
PROPOSED- AGAIN PRIOR TO
KNOWING WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
NOT KNOWING IF ANYTHING WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN SAID THE GOAL
AND THE TARGET AUDIENCE. WITH
TOO THAT THE GOAL IS TO GET THE
MONEY OUT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
KNOWING THAT A LOT OF-
DEADLINES- A LOT OF PROGRAM
BENEFITS WERE ENDING AT THE END
OF. THE LAST CALENDAR YEAR AND
SO- THE A. T. THE PROPOSAL IS
TO- PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED ONE
TIME TO TWENTY NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA E. I. T. C. PILOT-
RECIPIENTS AS WELL AS- TWENTY
TWENTY YEAH T. C. I. TEN FIVE
HOURS- THE FIRST WAS. IS THE
LARGER GROUP THERE'S PROBABLY
CLOSE TO. I WANT TO SAY- THREE
POINT. EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE IN
THAT GROUP AND- THE IDEA IS
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE THOSE
FOLKS ON FILE WE CAN GET THE
MONEY OUT TO THEM QUICKLY- I
THOUGHT THAT WAS. THAT WAS THE
PURPOSE AGAIN- THIS IS- THIS IS
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AT THE
START OF CONVERSATIONS AND WE
HAVE HEARD MANY OTHERS ASK
WHETHER OR NOT THAT. THAT
POPULATION. CAN BE MODIFIED
SOMEWHAT SOMEWHAT. THANKS FOR
THAT I. THAT WE'RE TURN TO DO
THE IS COOK AS- AND ARE
HAPPENING IN REAL TIME VERY
VERY QUICKLY. AND THEN IN REACH
IN REGARDS TO THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM- I
JUST. I WANT TO PUT A POINT IN
THIS AND THEN ALSO ABOUT THE
HOMELESS FUNDS- THIS IS A
PROPOSAL. THAT THAT WOULD
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND OUR OUR
HOUSING NEEDS AND THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTE PRIORITY AND THIS.
INTERFERE THE INFIELD MONEY
TENDS TO BE OVERSUBSCRIBED
USUALLY- BY. MULTIPLE MEMBERS
SO- THE QUESTION I HAVE IN
REGARDS TO THIS IS WHAT ARE THE
OUTCOMES IT'D MINISTRATION
HOPES TO ACCOMPLISH BY THIS
PARTICULAR- GRANT PROGRAM SO
THAT WE CAN REALLY FOCUS ON
TRYING TO SEE IF WE CAN MOVE
SOMETHING QUICKLY I BELIEVE
THIS IS A REAL ON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. STRATEGY BUT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT RURAL
CALIFORNIA I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF MY SMALL COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE INCREDIBLE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT- THAT
OUR- PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
NEEDS- SEWERS AND WATER SYSTEMS
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS I'M
WONDERING WHAT YOU HAD IN MIND
AND WHAT THE OUTCOMES YOU'RE-
YOU'RE SEEKING TO LOOK AT. SURE
A COUPLE YEARS AGO WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED PUTTING
ADDITIONAL MONIES IN. THE IN
INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM-
GRANT PROGRAM OR ID. IT WAS
REALLY IN RESPONSE TO LOCALS
THAT WERE SHARING THEIR NEEDS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
BASICALLY SAYING YES WE WOULD
LIKE TO BUILD MORE HOUSING BUT
WE NEED. TO SET WE NEED TO
BUILD A SEWER LINES WE NEED TO
BUILD- WATER AND LIGHTING AND
BASICALLY WE NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED HELP
PAYING FOR THAT INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND HENCE- THE FIRST FIVE
HUNDRED. MILLION I THINK IT WAS
THE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET FOR IJJI
AND- WORKING FROM THAT AND
UNDERSTANDING TO TWO THINGS
AGAIN DON'T CREATION. AND
GETTING. PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
ARAMBULA ONE OF THE GOAL OF.
THIS PROPOSAL AND ANOTHER ONE
IS OBVIOUSLY- ANOTHER PRIORITY
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION AND- A
PARTY FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND BUILDING
MORE OF IT SO. I'M TRYING TO
HIT SOME LOCALS THERE- IN
REGARDS TO- THE FINAL OUTCOME I
THINK IT REALLY IS JUST AYE
GETTING MORE UNITS UP- MORE OF.
DEMAND CAN BE MET AND WE CAN
START DRIVING DOWN THE PRICES
OF HOUSING. THANK YOU AND THEN
FINALLY I THIS IS NOT IN THE
FORM OF A QUESTION JUST TO BE
ABLE TO ASK FOR INFORMATION
LATER IS THAT THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED. AND
MANY IT FOR MANY YEARS HAS
PUSHED UP MONEY FOR HOMELESS
SERVICES INC AT HUPP MONEY FOR
HOMELESS SERVICES IN A VERY
FLEXIBLE M<c.cyan> CAN BE USED FOR.</c>
A VARIETY OF THINGS. BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME DATA ON.
BEST PRACTICES HOW MANY
HOMELESS HAD ACTUALLY BEEN
TAKEN OFF THE STREETS AND WHERE.
THAT HAS HAPPENED IS IT THE BIG
CITIES IS IT RURAL COMMUNITIES
IS IT ONE PARTICULAR AREA. WHAT
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND THEN-
HOWEVER THIS YEAR SHE'S DOING
BECAUSE I. I ASK LOCALLY FOR
INFORMATION AND I HAVE A REALLY
HARD TIME GETTING DATA FROM
THEM AND- IT IT IT BECOMES
DIFFICULT TO JUST KEEP- EVERY
YEAR. ADDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND NOT SEEING THE
RESULTS ON THE STREETS AND I
KNOW WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO
MAKE EVALUATIONS BASED ON. THE
SITUATION AS IT IS RIGHT NOW
BUT I JUST I WANNA BE BELIEVE
THAT THE MONEY WE'RE PUTTING
OUT THERE IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
I I'M VIGNETTES DON'T DON'T
SELL IT WE NEED TO KNOW. IF WE
HAD TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE STREETS AND TWO
YEARS AGO AND WE HAVE A
THOUSAND LAST THAT TELLS ME
THAT WE'RE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- AND THAT IT YEAH AND
I'D LIKE TO KNOW IF THERE'S
SOME BEST PRACTICES AS WELL
THAT THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE
USING AND WE SHOULD INCLUDED IN
OUR LEGISLATION SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- YOUR- YOUR-
YOUR- EXPLANATIONS TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THIS IS- PRETTY
UNUSUAL TO BE DOING THIS THE
FIRST WEEK THAT WE COME BACK IN
INTO SESSION AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE URGENCY THAT ON
IN MOST OF THESE ISSUES THAT WE
GET THEM DONE. AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AS SENATOR PER EURO AND DAD.
SENATOR PAN RIGHT BEFORE WE GO
DO YOU ARE JUST SOME GOING TO
ALERT FOLKS THAT- UNLESS AND
ANY OTHER SENATOR HAS THE DAY
OF NECESSITY TO ASK ANOTHER
QUESTION THAT WE WOULD BE
QUEUING UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
FOLLOWING. DR PANTS QUESTIONS
SO IN MY- AM I OKAY TO QUEUE UP
THAT PUBLIC COMMENT SENATORS.
OKAY SO- THE MIDDLE OUT DR PAN
AND THEN- THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
BY PHONE YOU'LL SEE THE PHONE
NUMBER ON THE- ON THE SCREEN.
OKAY GO AHEAD DOCTOR PAN THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- YOU KNOW I
THINK- BOTH DEPARTMENTS FINANCE
AND- DELEO- FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS TODAY- I WOULD
MAKE A NOTE THAT- MY GOOD
FRIEND- FROM FREMONT- THAT- I'M
NOT LOOKING TO CAP AND TRADE
MONEY FOR DENTAL SERVICES BUT I
DO HOPE THAT- WE CONTINUE TO
PROTECT UP PROP FIFTY SIX. THIS
FUNDING- AS VOTERS INTENDED TO
IMPROVE ACCESS A MEDIC CAL AND
I DO APPRECIATE- THE STEPS IN
THAT DIRECTION AND- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- A FEW
COMMENTS AND THEN A AND THEN
IDEA SOME QUESTIONS- SO FIRST
OF ALL- YOU KNOW. AND MAINLY
FOCUS ON HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
AND CERTAINLY SHARED MAIN
CONCERNS OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE OTHER AREAS AND- AND EAGER
TO HEAR DAY AND GET. THE
ANSWERS THAT THEY RECEIVE- TO
THEIR QUESTIONS- SO ON THE ONE
TWENTY I JUST MAKE A NOTE IN
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
BUDGET ESPECIALLY WE LOOK AT
THE OUT YEAR PROJECTIONS- WHAT
WE'VE DONE FOR MANY YEARS AS
WE'VE BUILT IN. AUTOMATIC CUTS
TO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES I
HSS TO DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
AND SO FORTH AND THEN WHAT WE
DO IS WE SUSPEND THOSE CUTS.
RIGHT BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
YOU KNOW WE BUILD WE BUILD IN
AND OUT YEARS SEVEN PERCENT.
ETCETERA CUTS TO A WIDE VARIETY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND I
GUESS MY CONCERN AND I KNOW
THAT YOU SUSPENDED IT FOR THIS
COMING YEAR SO RELEVANT TO THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET BUT AS WE'RE
LOOKING OUT YOUR PROJECTIONS.
I'M NOT SURE IT'S NECESSARILY
APPROPRIATE OR FAIR TO SAY THAT
WELL ACTUALLY WHAT WE CAN DO IS
NOT BUDGET ON THE IDEA THAT-
YOU KNOW NEXT YEAR THE YEAR
AFTER WE'RE GONNA DO A 7% CUT
AUTOMATICALLY ACROSS THE YOU
KNOW ON ALL THESE PROGRAMS ARE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND-
AS THOSE PROGRAMS ARE.
DESPERATELY NEEDED AND- SO WE
SUSPEND THESE CUTS YEAR AFTER
YEAR THAT'S APPROPRIATE THING
TO DO BUT I JUST I. JUST
CAREFUL THE NOMENCLATURE THAT
WE'RE SUSPENDING. THE CUTS
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE REALLY DOING
IS ONE WE DOES HAPPEN THOSE ARE
TO BE CUT IN AND THEN SOMEONE'S
GOT SAY WELL WE'LL NEED TO.
SOME MORE. AND SO- AND AGAIN
THIS IS PARTICULAR TO HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES I JUST WANNA
MENTION THAT THE OTHER THING I
ALSO DO WANT TO QUICKLY MENTION
AS WELL IS- ON THE MEDICAL
FRONT I REALLY DO APPRECIATE-
THE- WHAT WE'RE TRYING O DO
WITH CAL AIM. WHICH IS WHICH
FUNDAMENTALLY IS TRYING TO
IMPROVE OUR MEDICARE PROGRAM
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THEIR
SPECIFICS THAT- LOOK FOR TO
DIGGING INTO ONE EARNED AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND- PERHAPS SOME
CHANGES OR TWEAKS THAT WE
MIGHT. HEAR FROM DIFFERENT
PEOPLE ABOUT IT. BUT I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT PART OF THE
ISSUE IN TERMS OF TIMING IS
THAT NEAR THE WAIVERS FOR
EXAMPLE WE GOT A WAIVER THAT WE
GOT EXTENSION OR ELEVEN FIFTEEN
WAIVER BUT THAT WILL. END THIS
YEARS AGO WHEN YEAR EXTENSION.
SO WE DO HAVE TO REPOSITION OUR
MEDICAL PROGRAM ANYWAY BECAUSE
OF THE NATURE OF THE WAIVERS
THAT WERE. LOOKING FOR AND
GETTING AND SO I CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT SOME PEOPLE MA
RAISE THE QUESTION OF WHY WE
SPENDING MORE MONEY ON ON GOING
ON MEDIC CAL BUT- I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THESE STEPS ARE
REPOSITION MEDICAL PROGRAM TO
HOPEFULLY ACTUALLY BE MORE
EFFECTIVE AND MORE COST
EFFICIENT GOING FORWARD. AND WE
KNOW THAT AFTER CODE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE MORE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND OTHER TYPES
OF THINGS AS WELL. AND THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO A BETTER
JOB OF. DOING THAT SO I DO JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DIGGING INTO. THAT
MORE IN DEPTH AND THE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
DEALING A PANDEMIC. AND
CERTAINLY I THINK ONE OF OUR
TOP PRIORITIES IS FIGURE OUT
HOW DO WE CONTAIN THIS- THIS.
COVERED VIRUS WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATELY. TAKEN TO
MOBILIZE A TO MAKE CALIFORNIANS
IS DEVASTATED. FAMILIES OUR
ECONOMY. HIS ABILITY GO TO
SCHOOL PEOPLE GAME BE ABLE TO
GO TO WORK BUSINESSES BEING
OPEN- AND I'VE I RECOGNIZE
THAT- YOU KNOW WE'VE GOTTEN
MONEY FROM THE FED ZIDAN YEAH
THE FIRST TEARS ACT AND OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS WE'RE GONNA GET
MORE MONEY. BUT AS WE ARE DOING
OUR HEARINGS ALL RIGHT NOW HERE
FINANCE SAID YOU KNOW WE'RE
PLANNING THIS BUDGET WE DIDN'T.
KNOW WHAT WAS GONNA HAPPEN THE
SECOND STIMULUS WHICH BY THE
WAY IS PASSED BY ABOUT LESS
THAN TWO WEEKS AGO- WE- I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE IMPORTANT THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE. ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT EXACTLY HOW
MUCH MONEY ACTUALLY WE AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO WORK WITH
BETWEEN BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
AND CERTAINLY HELP HIM SERVE AS
WE ALLOW FEDERAL MATCHING MONEY
AND STUFF BUT TAX. THINGS SO WE
KNOW WHETHER WE'RE DOING THE
RIGHT AMOUNT AND- TEN AND SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO FINANCE-
AND I APPRECIATE AND ALSO L. A.
L. SAID WELL. YOU KNOW WE
DEVELOP THIS BUDGET AND YES
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
IN MAY REVISED BUT WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME THINGS YOU
WANNA MOVE OUT NOW. ARE CODED
RESPONSE NEEDS TO HAPPEN NOW.
WHAT KIND OF INFORMATION YOU'LL
BE SHARING WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND OUR SUBCOMMITTEES. ON THE
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL MONEY THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED BOTH TO DATE AND
WE ANTICIPATE. PARTICULARLY TO.
IN MY MIND PUBLIC HEALTH
BECAUSE THAT'S THE TIP OF THE
SPEAR BUT ALSO THE OTHER THINGS
AS WELL SO. YOU KNOW I GET IT
YOU'RE SAYING NOW OKAY WE
DEVELOP THIS BUDGET THAT'S
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I THINK OUR
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE BUDGET
CAN'T JUST BE CONSTRAINED ONLY
TO WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND WHAT WE ARE SPEND
STATE MONEY ON. WE HAVE TO
KNOW. THE COLLECTIVE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT'S AVAILABLE SOME OF
IT OF COURSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNATED FOR CERTAIN THINGS
SO WE CAN'T REALLY CONTROL THAT
BUT WE AT LEAST NEED TO KNOW
WHAT. TOKEN CAN BOTH- FINANCE
IN ELLO. SPEAK TO ARE YOU GOING
TO BE WHEN YOU'RE AT A SUB
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND ALSO WE
HAVE A BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. THEN WE'LL HAVE A
MORE DETAILED CONVERSATION AND
ACTUALLY GIVE US THAT
INFORMATION WE HAVE THOSE
HEARING SO WE CAN MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISIONS. ON RESOURCES.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND AND AGREE
THAT WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT A
FULL. A FULL PAGE HERE NOT JUST
THE GENERAL FUND OR STATE FUNDS
BUT ALSO FEDERAL FUNDS- AND NOT
AND IN TERMS OF TIMING NOT
USING ANYTHING AS AN EXCUSE-
JUST WANTING TO SERVE. PUT OUT
THERE THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE
HAD IN OUR BUDGET- BUT
DEFINITELY NEED TO UNDERSTAND
BETTER WHAT'S COMING DOWN FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND I
WOULD SAY GENERALLY SPEAKING
THAT WE- IT'S COMING MORE AS A
TRICKLE THAN ANYTHING ELSE AND-
AND- BY. SORT OF PROGRAMMING
PROGRAM IN REGARDS TO RAGS AND-
STIPULATIONS AROUND HOW THESE
DOLLARS SHOULD GO OUT- I DID
PROVIDE FOR THE COMMITTEE- THE
POTENTIAL ESTIMATES FOR
CALIFORNIA WE- I'M NOT SURE IF.
YOU'LL HAVE THAT THERE IS AN
UPDATE TO THE TABLE THAT WE
HAD- IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND OF COURSE EVERYBODY JUST
CAME OUT TWO WEEKS AGO WE
ALREADY HAVE UPDATED CHANGES IN
PROBABLY THE TABLE THAT
PROVIDED WILL CHANGE AGAIN-
DEPENDING AND WHEN WE GETMORE.
INFORMATION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT ABSOLUTELY AND-
THE GOAL IS TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION TO
YOU AS WEAK AS AS IT'S RELEASED
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO
INFORM- HOW WE CAN AUGMENT OR
USE THOSE DOLLARS- TO
COMPLEMENT THE THINGS THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY DOING ON THE
GROUND AND IN REGARDS TO COOK
NINETEEN RESPONSE BUT ALSO
WHAT'S INCLUDED AND- THE
BUDGET. FOR EITHER- EARLY
ACTION OR AS PART OF THE NORMAL
BUDGET PROCESS OKAY SO YOU'VE
BECAUSE WE MAKE OUR DECISIONS
WE GOT PUT ALL THAT TOGETHER SO
WE CANCER LIKE THIS IS THE
STATE PARK IN THE NURSES AND
THAT WE'RE GONNA YELL AUGMENT
WHERE SO WE NEED TO KNOW
STRATEGICALLY WHAT WE ACTUALLY
ARE. AND ACTUALLY ELIA ON IF
YOU HAD ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD TO
THAT IN TERMS OF YOUR ANALYSIS
AS WE GET. THIS INFORMATION OUT
HOW MUCH FEDERAL MONEY LIKE. IN
TERMS OF OKAY THE TOTAL OF
MONEY WE REALLY GOING TO
COMMITTING THIS WOULD BE ACCESS.
YES DOCTOR CAN'T IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION- AND- CERTAINLY OUR
STAFF WILL BE CONTINUING TO
WORK THROUGH THAT. THE FEDERAL
PACKAGING B. YOU KNOW BE ABLE
TO DISCUSS THAT IN MORE DETAIL
WITH YOU IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS. BUT WE ALSO DID WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- INCLUDES A PROVISION
THAT WOULD. ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO.
ALLOCATE FEDERAL FUNDS AT THEIR
DISCRETION AND SO I MEAN I
THINK THIS IS ALL JUST TO SAY I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. AND- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE I. I WOULD EXPECT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
WEIGH IN ON THOSE CHOICES SO-
AND I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FROM THE L. A.
WOULD WANT. TO SUPPLEMENT
ANYTHING AT SAID ON THAT. OKAY
SO- AND I APPRECIATE THAT
RESPONSE I THINK TO SAY NOW
APROPOS TO WHAT- I THINK CENTER
CRAZY ASKED A LITTLE EARLIER-
IT IS THE- THIS BRANCHES JOB TO
APPROPRIATE- AND WILD WE DON'T
TECHNICALLY APPROPRIATE. THE
FEDERAL MONEY DIRECTLY- I WOULD
SAY THAT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
ADMINISTRATION VIEW US AS
PARTNERS AND DEBT ALLOCATION
THAT IT'S NOT LIKE- IT'S
FEDERAL MONEY AND THEREFORE WE
CAN ALLOCATE THAT WE WANT TO
WITHOUT TALKING TO YOU KNOW AT.
YOU'LL YOU'LL LET US KNOW I'M
SURE WE'RE GOOD PARTNERS IN
THAT SENSE BUT- I THINK YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO BE ENGAGED IN
THOSE DECISIONS. RIGHT SO WE
KNOW WE HAVE CERTAIN FEDERAL
MONEY'S GOING AND WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE DECISIONS ON HOW
ALLOCATE. DEL APPROPRIATE STATE
MONEY WE DIDN'T NEED TO KNOW
WHAT KIND OF DECISIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO MAKE
ON THE FEDERAL MONEY SO WE DO
SO WE DON'T FIND OUT THAT- WE
APPROPRIATE THE STATE MONEY AND
NOW WE HAVE THIS MUCH GOING ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE AND THEN
THERE'S A HOLE SOMEWHERE ELSE.
SO I THINK THAT. WE NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT LANGUAGE REGARDING
THAT AS WELL- I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT I KNOW EARLIER WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT IS THAT
TRAILER LYFT I DON'T I THINK
THAT'S- RIGHT I THINK LAST YEAR
WE SORT OF ACCEPTED IT BUT I
HOPE THAT THIS YEAR WE REVISIT
THAT AS WELL I THINK WE DO NEED
MORE CONTROLS ON THE- ON THE-
LEGISLATIVE SIDE. I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT YES THIS IS AN
EMERGENCY BUT THIS IS. AN
ONGOING EMERGENCY YOU KNOW WE
THIS IS THE NEXT BUDGET CYCLE
AND WE'RE STILL HAVING THIS
EMERGENCY AND- FRANKLY THE
LEGISLATURE NEED TO HAVE MORE
OF A SAY IN AN EMERGENCY
THAT'S- ONGOING THIS LONG IN
TERMS OF APPROPRIATIONS. LET ME
JUST MENTION MAYBE TO USE MORE
SPECIFIC THINGS I MAY DELVE
INTO IT- SO FIRST OF ALL DID
NOT PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
VACCINATION I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR COMMITTING. THREE
I THINK IT'S THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SOME MILLION FOR
VACCINATION. AND IN ADDITION- I
UNDERSTAND WE'RE GOING TO GET
MORE FUNDING FOR VACCINATION
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BY
JUST Y. CLARIFIED THAT THE
AMOUNT THE GOVERNOR IS
ANNOUNCED THAT FROM THE STATE.
IS THAT SEPARATE FROM FROM. AN
THEREFORE THE ADDITION. MONEY
FROM THIS. CARE IS ACTIVE A D.
TO AN TERM OF FOR. OR IS THAT
THE SAME MONEY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. AND THEN ALSO
WE'RE IS THAT THREE HUNDRED AND
SOME. SEVENTY MONEY MILLION
DOLLARS COMING FROM XANDER
STAND THAT'S NOT NECESSARY FROM
THE GENERAL FUND SO CAN-
FINANCE PLEASE KILL IT
CLARIFIED. THE COMMITMENT TO
GETTING OUR VACCINES OUT- TO
ME. IN TERMS OF YES- WE ARE.
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING- THE EFFORTS AND
GETTING THE VACCINE OUT YES TO
AS MANY PEOPLE AS- POSSIBLE AND
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO. THAT
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
MILLION FIGURE THAT WAS QUOTED
BY THE GOVERNOR- IS. IT AN
ESTIMATE WITH AN ESTIMATE MADE
AT THE TIME- THAT WE DEVELOP
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF WHAT
WE ANTICIPATED HAVING TO SPEND
OR NEEDING TO SPEND. IN REGARDS
AFFECTING IT IS NOT- A
PROPOSAL- AND THERE ISN'T. IF
IT TAKES ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
THAT WOULD BE PART OF THE- THAT
THE COST ESTIMATE- AGAIN THE
DEALERS RECALLED SYSTEM
INTERROGATE FORTY SIX OF THE
SUMMARY PAGES. THAT'S WHERE
YOU'LL FIND- THE THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLAR
FIGURE. LOOKS FROM SORRY
WHERE'S. THAT MONEY COMING FROM
THE THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
MILLION. SOURCE OF THE FUNDS
YOU'RE NOT AGAIN THESE ARE NOT.
THAT BASED ON A FUNDING THE ARE
TO OKAY. PETER COSTS AT. AND SO-
INTO MANY CASES MAY END UP
HAVING TO PAY STATE MONEY UP
FRONT BUT GET REIMBURSED
THROUGH OTHER FUNDS LATER SO
THAT'S JUST. JUST WHAT WE
ANTICIPATED AGAIN NOT KNOWING
WHAT WE WERE GOING TO GET FROM
THE FEDS. THE FEDERAL DOLLARS-
THE FAT I BELIEVE THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS COMING DOWN- FOR
VACCINATION. IS ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND- THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY ACCORDING TO L. A. L.
UNDER REPORT. WHILE WORKING ON-
THAT WOULD BE ON TOP OF
ANYTHING THAT THE STATE WOULD
SPEND. AGAIN IT'S A BIT OF A
COINCIDENCE THE NUMBERS ARE
SIMILAR- BUT THAT IS ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS SO THAT'S ADDITIONAL ON
TOP OF THE THREE OKAY SO
LOOKING FORWARD TO DELVING MORE
SPECIFICALLY INTO THAT- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT EXPLANATION.
AND THEN I GUESS ON THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SIDE YOU KNOW OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS- DAY ARE
YEAH WE'VE BEEN UNDERFUNDING
THEM FOR A LONG TIME I
APPRECIATE THAT IT WAS WITH US
LAST YEAR. A YEAR TWO YEARS
AGO- THAT ACTUALLY DO IT WE
ACTUALLY. EVEN ALLOCATED I
THINK THOSE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- TO TRY TO HELP
BOLSTER THEM UP BEFORE EVEN YOU
CODE WAS COMING. I KNOW IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL AT LEAST-
YOU CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
I DON'T SEE ANY ADDITIONAL-
STATE MONEY FOR. COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS I KNOW OUR CDPH IS-
IS. YEAH THEY'RE STRETCHED TO-
SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT
KIND OF SUPPORT WE'RE GIVING TO
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
WHO ARE BOTH DOING ALL OUR
CONTACT TRACING TRAINS YOUR
VACCINATIONS I MEAN I'M-
USUALLY TALKING TO THEM WILL.
MAKE IT TEN OR ELEVEN AT NIGHT
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST SO BUSY-
AND- SO. IS IT BECAUSE
EXPECTING THE FEDS TO PAY FOR
ALL OF THAT OKAY SO CAN WE CAN
WE TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. A
WIDER HASN'T BEEN- AN
ALLOCATION FOR. OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. ARE AND
OBVIOUSLY. TOTALLY AGREED THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT ARE
DOING A LOT MORE COORDINATING
WITH THEM ON. ON ALL ASPECTS OF
THE RESPONSE INCLUDING
VACINES- BUT TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC- BUDGET-
KIND. OF DEPARTMENT. OF HEALTH
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO SOMEBODY
IN OUR EIGHTY JUSTINA. OKAY
EIGHTY NINE. HI DOCTOR PAN RYAN
MILLER FROM FINANCE. EXCUSE ME
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR QUESTION-
SO I IDEA I THINK THE FIRST
THING I THAT I WOULD HIGHLIGHT.
IS THAT IN JULY OF LAST YEAR-
WE HAD ALLOCATED- SORRY I'M
TRYING TO FIND THE EXACT NUMBER
CORIO- TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SIX. MILLION DOLLARS- TO LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS FROM
FEDERAL ET DOT EPIDEMIOLOGY AND
LABORATORY CAPACITY GRANDSON
THAT WAS IN ADDITION TO SOME OF
THE OTHER- FUNDING THAT YOU HAD
REFERENCED EARLIER AND THAT
FUNDING WAS FOR TESTING IN
CONTACT TRACING SO I THINK
FIRST I NEED YOU KNOW START
HIGHLIGHTING THAT- IN ADDITION
TO THAT IN THE STATE CLEARLY
HAS BEEN- YOU KNOW UNDERTAKING.
BIG EFFORTS WITH THE VALENCIA
BRANCH LAB- AND OTHER TESTING-
IN CONTACT RECENT ACTIVITIES
THE STATE HAS- I THINK- ABOUT
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED STATE
EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED TO
ASSIST LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS WITH THEIR
CONTACT TRACING EFFORTS I THINK
THAT'S BROUGHT THE TOTAL
CONTACT TRACERS WITH- WITH
LOCAL EMPLOYEES UP TO I THINK
NEARLY TEN THOUSAND. CONTACT
TRACERS- SO THAT I THINK THERE
HAVE BEEN VARIOUS EFFORTS I
THINK TO YOUR QUESTION YOU KNOW
YOU I THINK YOU'RE ASKING MORE
ABOUT- YOU KNOW WHAT IS
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- AND I THINK THAT. YOU
KNOW WE'RE REALLY MOSTLY
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC OF COURSE- IN
ADDITION TO THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
ERICA I JUST MENTIONED- WE ALSO
EXPECT ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR TESTING
ACTIVITIES BUT IT APPEARS BASED
ON GUIDANCE THAT THAT WE
RECEIVED YESTERDAY THAT THE
FUNDING ACTUALLY COULD ALSO BE
USED FOR OTHER ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING CONTACT TRACING AND
IN SOME VACCINATION ACTIVITIES
AND SO I THINK WE'RE PLEASED
THAT. THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
FLEXIBILITY THERE- YOU KNOW AND
WE'RE WE'VE BEEN MEETING
RECENTLY WITH A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ABOUT THEIR NEEDS
ABOUT- YOU KNOW THE OTHER YOU.
KNOW SIERRA FEDERAL FUNDED
CORONAVIRUS POLICE FUNDS AND
THAT WAS THAT WERE. PROVIDED TO
CARRY CARRIES. YOU KNOW
STARTING RUN OUT AND HOW DO WE-
YOU KNOW CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THEM- AND SO YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT WE WILL BE. ENGAGING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON. YOU KNOW A
PRO A PROPOSED ALLOCATION OF
THESE- YOU KNOW ROUGHLY TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF
NEW FEDERAL FUNDING- BUT
CONCERNING THE BUDGET. I THINK
I WOULD HIGHLIGHT- A PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE IN THE IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY- WHERE WE WOULD LIKE TO
I REQUEST SOME FUNDING TO DO-
SORT OF AFTER. AN AFTER
COLLUDED YOU KNOW RETROSPECTIVE
STUDY TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU KNOW PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES CERTAINLY AND ALSO.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
HEALTHEQUITY- YOU KNOW-
CHALLENGES THEY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED EVEN MORE BYE BYE
COATED AND- AND- SO I THINK
THAT. IN THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT WE ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING THE CURRENT A
PANDEMIC BEFORE WE KIND OF GET
INTO SOME OF THOSE OTHER
CONVERSATIONS. I APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT PRIORITY I
THINK IT THEN SPEAKS TO WHAT I
STARTED WITH THIS IS THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE ALLOCATIONS SO I'M
SITTING HERE GOING WE NEED TO
EXPAND SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND YOU'RE TELLING WE
HAVE FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S GOING
TO DO THAT. THAT'S ALL WE NEED
TO SEE THE WHOLE PICTURE
TONIGHT AND THAT WAY WE CAN
EVALUATE IS THAT ENOUGH DO WE
NEED TO DO MORE ODD MENTAL
STATE MONEY IS IT GOOD ENOUGH
IT CETERA. SO AGAIN BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE WHOLE PICTURE IS GONNA
BE REALLY IMPORTANT. AND BE
ABLE TO KNOW THAT- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ADMINISTRATION
THAT EXACTLY HOW MUCH OF THE
FEDERAL MONIES CAN BE ALLOCATED
WHERE SO THAT WERE MAKING THE
RIGHT DECISIONS ON THE STATE
MONEY IS GONNA BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. AND THAT'S ALSO WHY
SO I THINK WE'RE COMING FULL
CIRCLE HERE. YOUR ANSWER WILL
BUILD IT MORE DEEPLY AND
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT THAT IS WHY WE
NEED TO KNOW. HOW THE SEASON'S
GONNA BE MADE ON THE FEDERAL
MONEY SO WE CAN MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS ON THE STATE MONEY.
SO PROCEED THAT. I GUESS FINAL
POINT APPRECIATE THE BUILDINGS
OF THE CHAIR- THIS IS ACTUALLY
NOT HELPING HUMAN SERVICES
THING- IN MY REGION YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN WORKING HARD- AND-
I'D- TRY DEVELOP INFRASTRUCTURE
TO TRY TO USE THE GOVERNOR'S. A
GOALS OF- OF BEING ABLE TO
IMPROVE INCREASE HOUSING HAVING
THE TRANSPORTATION GOES WITH IT
AND DOING IN A GREEN WAY- SO.
EVEN AS WE ARE TRYING TO
TACKLE. THE BOTH THE PANDEMIC.
WILDFIRES OTHER CRISES AND I
YOU KNOW I HAVE TO SAY THAT-
THIS GOVERNOR AND UNFORTUNATELY
SAID THE DEALS MORE CRISES-
THAN I THINK MANY GOVERNORS HAS
SO I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR.
THAT I KNOW THAT SIR THAT MAKES
IT REALLY HARD. AND I THINK WE
SHOULD EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
FOR. HIS THE CHALLENGES HE HAS
TO FACE TO DO THAT AND ALL OF
YOU WORK FOR HIM. I HOPE THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN SOME OF THESE OTHER
THINGS MOVING FORWARD
ESPECIALLY THEY DON'T REQUIRE
MORE DOLLARS BUT ACTUALLY JUST
ASK FOR SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
EXISTINGDOLLARS SO. I'M JUST%
GONNA PUT THAT OUT THERE SO. WE
COULD Y. STILL ACHIEVE SOME OF
THE AIMS THAT HE TALKED ABOUT
PRE CODED. THAT WE CAN DO IT.
BY GIVING SOME MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO EXISTING DOLLARS. I HOPE
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
ADMINISTRATION BE FAVORABLE TO
THAT US THINGS LIKE GREEN MEANS
GO HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM CHAIR
APPRECIATES TIME. THANK YOU DR.
SIR WE WERE GO FOR. Q. ON
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL GO FIRST
TO THE FOLKS IN THE- KORAN SITE
IN THE- GALLERY AND I AM GOING
TO BE LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT
TO ONE MINUTE- AND THEN WE WILL
HAVE. THE OF A- PHONE LINES
WILL OPEN AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE MODERATOR HAS- THE R. I. T.
MODERATOR HAS INFORMED TO THOSE
WHO ARE IN THE QUEUE. SO WHAT-
CAN WE HAVE THE PHONE LINE
NUMBER PUT BACK UP ON THE
SCREEN JUST IN CASE FOR THOSE.
PEOPLE WHO MAY WANT TO CALL IN
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. ALL RIGHT
SO WE'LL START WITH THE GALLERY
AND IT'S- WE HAVE A ONE MINUTE
LET ME GO AHEAD. I'M I'M SORRY
I DIDN'T CATCH THAT HOW LONG DO
I HAVE ONE MINUTE. ONE MINUTE-
HE RUNS. YOU HEAR WHAT I HAD TO
SAY BUT DID YOU NEED TO CATCH A
BUS WE'RE GOING TO START YOU AT
THE ONE MINUTE NOW SO IF YOU
COULD INDICATE YOUR NAME BUT I
WANTED TO EXPAND THE VACCINE
EXPERT TO HEAR ME BUT HE'S GONE.
WELL. THERE WAS CERTAINLY A
GOLDEN TIDBIT IN THE US HEARING
WASN'T THERE TO QUOTE SENATOR
DORADO THE ONE SHINING LIGHT IS
THE VACCINE. WHICH I WILL
RESPOND A QUOTE FROM DEL BIG
TREAT MEDICAL INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALIST WE HAVE NOW REACHED
HEARD STUPIDITY. MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SPEAKING AT THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
VACCINE SAFETY SUMMIT IN
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
ADMITTED THAT SCIENTISTS DO NOT
TRULY UNDERSTAND HOW VACCINE
ADJUVANTS WORK AND THAT THERE
IS NO SAFETY STUDIES ON
INJECTING MULTIPLE VACCINES
WITH THE MULTIPLE ADJUVANTS
INTO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
MANDATED MEDICINE IS A DISGRACE
NOW AND FOREVER WE KNOW THIS
FROM HISTORY AND THIS IS WHY WE
HAVE SIGNED A TREATY AFTER
TREATY EDIFYING THE IMPORTANCE
OF INFORMED CONSENT THERE IS NO
MORE BASIC LIBERTY AND THE
FREEDOM TO DECIDE WHAT GETS
INJECTED INTO OUR BODIES. AND I
WILL CONCLUDE WITH A QUOTE BY
MARK TWAIN WHEN THE MOB AND THE
PRESS AND THE WHOLE WORLD TELL
YOU TO MOVE YOUR JOB IS TO
PLANT YOURSELF LIKE A TREE NEXT
TO THE RIVER OF TRUTH AND SAY
NO. YOU DON'T MOVE SO DID. MOVE
OVER BECAUSE AS SOON AS WE THE
PEOPLE ARE. THANK YOU WE WILL
HAVE OUR NEXT SPEAKER AND THAT
WAS OVER ONE MINUTE CLOSE
PLEASE ABIDE THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANOTHER SPEAKER IN THE
GALLERY. CAN I WAKE YOU GUYS UP
FROM THAT NAP. HELLO IF YOU ARE.
ALL OF POLITICAL POWER IS
INHERENT IN THE PEOPLE.
GOVERNMENT IS INSTITUTED FOR
THEIR PROTECTION YOU TO MADAM
CHAIR CAN YOU PLEASE LISTEN.
SECURITY AND BENEFITS. AND THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ALTER OR
REFORM. WHEN THE PUBLIC COULD
MAY REQUIRE. IN CASE IF YOU
GUYS ARE. NOT KNOWING THIS IS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. RECALL IS THE
POWER OF THE ELECTORS TO REMOVE
AN ELECTED OFFICER. NEWSOME'S
FIRST. AND ONCE HE'S GONE. PENN
IS THE NEXT IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO LINE UP WITH HIM I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND TO USE YOUR BRAINS.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW- THAT IS JUST
LOST YOU GUYS ARE NOT THINKING
THERE'S NO CRITICAL THINKING IF
YOU'LL WANT TO VACCINATE
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA YOU
GUYS ARE NOT THINKING. THANK
YOU AND THERE'S ONE MORE NO.
SEVENTEEN A MILLION GUNS WERE
PURCHASED IN THE UNITED STATES.
FIRST TIME GONE OVERS PLUS
SEVENTEEN MILLION WHAT DO YOU
THINK. I THINK THEY'RE GONNA DO
AND I WILL HAVE OUR NEXT
SPEAKER IS THERE ANOTHER
SPEAKER IN THE GALLERY. ALL
RIGHT THEN WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ALWAYS SORRY THERE
IS ANOTHER SPEAKER. OKAY YOU
MAY BEGIN HI YOU GUYS A
PROPHETIC. THAT BELIEVE THE
MONOPOLY MONEY YOU PLAY WITH
TODAY IT'S GOING TO SAVE YOU
WHEN IT'S DESTROYED IN EXCHANGE
FOR DIGITAL CURRENCY DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT BROKE YOU TOOK AWAY YOUR
FREEDOMS AND THEN REWARDED YOU
WITH THE GOVERNMENT POSITION IS
GOING TO GIVE YOU A DIFFERENT
SEAT AT THE TABLE WHEN THE
WORLD COLLAPSES BECAUSE LET ME
TELL YOU YOU'RE GOING TO BE THE
FIRST TO GO YOU GUYS ARE THE
DISPOSABLE BAGS OF DOG ****
THAT WERE THE PERFECT PONDS TO
PUSH THE WAGON DOWN THE HILL.
TO HELP THEM BRING IN THE NEW
WORLD ORDER NEW WORLD ORDER YOU
KNOW THE LOVELY. WORLD ORDER
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT ON BUT
TOGETHER THE SAME ZERO SO WE
HAVE TODAY WE DON'T. TO DANCE.
SIT HERE AND WAIT TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE DIDN'T BUY GUNS FOR
NOTHING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE CAN NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- WATER READER. AND WE
WILL HAVE THE SAME- OF A TIME
LIMIT FOR THOSE WHO ARE CALLING
IN. SIR GO AHEAD PHONE
MODERATOR. PLEASE IN GERMAN IF
YOU WISH TO OFFER COMMENTS YEAH
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THE FIRST COMMENT BECAUSE
LINE TWENTY SO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS GIVE IN
THE COUNTY THAT IF THE PATIENT.
AND I'LL BE OF THE STATED THAT
OF. IRVING COUNTY THE COUNTY
WILL COUNTY THE CAL AND THE
HELP OF THE PATIENT CALIFORNIA
ONE HIGHLIGHT THE URGENT NEEDS-
ARE LOCAL HELP HAVE I
THROUGHOUT THE- PANDEMIC LOCAL
DEPARTMENT DON'T LOOK LIKE
PASSED HI MOST OF THE CALL
TRACERS ANDY VIDAK GATORS AND-
SUPPORT VULNERABLE INTO. FOR
LIKE VERY. I'M CURRENTLY
LOOKING. I WITHOUT IT WILL LET
RECRUITING ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THREE
ATHLETICALLY TO PLEASE TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET YEAR TO PROVIDE THE
FOLLOWING FUNDING AT A LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS OVER THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS. UNDER MILLION.
HARD COVER ACTING DISTRIBUTION
AND ADMINISTRATION. TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION FOR COVERT
NINETEEN TESTING. FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILLION FOR CONTACT
TREATING DISEASE INVESTIGATION
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS. AN
ADDITION TO OUR IMMEDIATE NEEDS
WE ALSO ASK THAT CALIFORNIA
REGION IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE BEYOND THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC. ASSEMBLY
AFTER THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDY. AN
ONGOING FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND CAN'T REBUILD OUR
PUBLIC. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY NICE TO GO TO LINE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THE
NAME COLBERN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
BUDGET IN THAT IT DOES NOT
REFLECT THE CRISIS WORKING MOMS
AND FAMILIES ARE EXPERIENCING
NOW. WITH MY FACT THAT THE
CHILD CARE THISBUDGET ACTUALLY
HAS A LOT OF CHILD CARE WHAT
ABOUT YOUR PROGRAM FOR MONTHLY.
750-006-6000 AND IT'S NOT
ADDRESS. WILL RESULT IN
DIFFERENT MOMENTS OF THE
POTENTIAL WORKERS ALL THIS
WHILE CREE PANDEMIC THERE WERE
OVER TWO MILLION FOR THE
THIRTEEN CHILDREN WITHOUT ANY
ACCESS TO CHILDCARE. THE BUDGET
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
CHILDCARE WORKERS I READ FIRST
BETWEEN THREE TO SEVEN DOLLARS
PER HOUR ALL THE WHILE THE
MINIMUM WAGE IS JUST INCREASE.
THEIR COMMITMENT TO THE FACT
THAT NOT TO CHANGE FINALLY
ROUGHLY A THIRD OF FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS OFFENDERS HAVE
CLOSED THEIR DOORS DURING THE
PANDEMIC WITH MORE COME UP.
WITH MANY MORE ON THE BIRDS SO
WHERE HAVE THEY BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS IT OPENS. THAT
ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WERE
SUPPORTED AND OUR SCHOOL COULD
MOVE TO DISTANCE LEARNING IF WE
DO NOT ADDRESS THE CHILD CARE
CRISIS NOW IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY SIMPLY
WILL NOT HELP THE CHILD CARE
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT WORKERS
GOING BACK TO WORK. THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND PERHAPS BEFORE WE KEEP
GOING- WE WELCOME I'M NOT
APOLOGIES FOR LIMITING THE TIME
BECAUSE WE DO WELCOME THE INPUT
THAT WE'RE HEARING. AND WE
DEFINITELY WELCOME YOU TO
COMMUNICATE TO US IN WRITING SO
WITH THOSE SAME REQUEST SO THAT
WE CAN TRACK THEM- NOW-
MODERATOR. COULD YOU GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE THIRTY THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON NOT CHAIR
AND TYLER IN THE ON BEHALF OF
THE TOWN TO HECKLE HEALTH CARE
ARE. AS WE LIKE YOUR GRATITUDE
AT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET WHICH DEDICATES ACCENT
FOR THE BILLION DOLLARS A
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SAFETY NET
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS. THIS
FUNDING WILL HELP BUILD COUNTY
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT NEEDED
SYSTEM TRANSFORMATIONS WHAT
PAYMENT REQUIREMENT MEDICAMENTS
AT ANY CHANGE A THIRD. IN
EXTENDED MUCH NEEDED MHSAA
REGULATORY RELIEF DURING THE
PANDEMIC INVESTMENT IN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AS A MATTER
OF LIFE AND DEATH THAT'S MORE
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN. PSYCHIATRIC
CRISIS BEING HOSPITALIZED DINO
THE RESULT OF AN OVERDOSE ON
WHICH IN SUMMARY THAT REGIONS
OF THE STATE ARE OUTPACING
COBIT RELATED FATALITIES.
RESOURCES FOR THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SAFETY NET ARE CRITICAL
AS WE FACE INCREASED SERVICE
NEED ASSOCIATED WITH A PANDEMIC
WHICH WILL CONTINUE TO GROW
AFTER THE PANDEMIC IS OVER WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO BUILD UPON
THE PROPOSAL OUTLINING. THE
JANUARY BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THE NEXT A
MODERATE NEXT SPEAKER. MEXICO
TO LINE UP FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MEANWHILE FOR ONE WITH A R.
P. CALIFORNIA YOU'RE
REPRESENTING A THREE POINT
THREE MILLION MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA ONE ENGINE A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS FIRST OF ALL WE DI
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE ELEMENTS
IN THE BUDGET. ARE IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH ALSO
WHICH INCLUDED AMONG OTHER
THINGS INVESTING FOURTEEN
BILLION TO BEGIN THE QUOTE
UNQUOTE EQUITABLE AND GARBAGE
RECOVERY. THREE BILLION IN A
CANONICALLY INDIVIDUALS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE CODED NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
WILL BE COMMENTING MORE ON THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
ISSUES AS A COMMITTEE MEETING I
ALSO WANT. TO DATE ON OCT AND
CALL ON IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION PLEASE TO EXTEND THE
MARGIN THREE PAID. SICK LEAVE.
THANK YOU. NEED PROTECTION FOR
OUR- ESSENTIAL TO STOP THE
SPREAD OF CODED. THANK YOU VERY
FOR YOUR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING TO MORE. THANK YOU.
THANKS TO LINE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO AARON APTI WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES COMMENTING ON
THE EDUCATION PROPOSALS WE
APPRECIATE THE TWO BILLION FOR
SCHOOL RE OPENING AND SUBPAR
OFFERING IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AND THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
SAFELY STUDENTS ARE LOW INCOME
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT
HAVE BEEN HARDEST HIT BY
COPING. AND WHO ARE STRUGGLING
MOST WITH DISTANCE LEARNING BUT
ESPECIALLY BENEFIT FROM IN
PERSON EDUCATION HOWEVER
DISTRICTS MUST CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY DISTANCE
LEARNING FOR STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT WISH TO OR WHO ARE UNABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN PERSON DURING
THE PANDEMIC. IF OVER THE NET
SEVERAL WEEKS DISTRICTS AND
LOCAL UNIONS CANNOT REACH
AGREEMENT ON RE OPENING AND IS
THE STATE'S CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY
TO ISSUE CLEAR HEALTH AND
SAFETY PREEMPTING SANDERS FOR
ALL DISTRICTS. PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
INCREASED VACCINES AND TESTING
THE MOST IMPACT THE COMMUNITY
TO HELP TEACHERS STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES FELT CONFIDENT
RETURNING A PERSON THIS YEAR WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION FOR EXTENDED LEARNING
DESIGN SHOULD BE ALLOCATED BY
CONCENTRATION OF HIGH NEED
STUDENTS AND INSURANCE REALLY
RESTORATIVE RETURNED TO SCHOOL
YOU KNOW JUGGLING COUNTER
MEDIATION BUT INSTEAD
INNOVATIVE. AND ENGAGING
LEARNING THIS YEAR. EXTENDED
LEARNING. BUT ALSO PROVIDE
KILLERS ANIMAL. THE TO ADDRESS
STUDENT TRAUMA. FOR DONG TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IN
HEADLINE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SURE MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS- PASSING THROUGH
ONE POINT SIX BILLION IN
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR RENT RELIEF-
FOR OUR RENTERS AND LANDLORDS
WHO ARE BURDENED Y THE
ACCUMULATION OF DEBT. ON THAT
HAS OCCURRED THAT HAS BUILT
OVER THE LAST FIVE MONTHS. WE
CAUTION THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S THOUGH THAT THAT IS
GOING TO BE AN INSUFFICIENT
AMOUNT OF- OF RELIEF- GIVEN THE
FACT THAT MOST ESTIMATES ARE
PUTTING IS THAT CLOSE TO FIVE
BILLION ALREADY. IF THE
MORATORIUM IS EXTENDED AS WE
HOPE IT WILL BE THAT'S GOING TO
ADD TWO ADDITIONAL DEBT BEING
ACCUMULATED. SO WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED TO STEP UP FULLY AND
MAKE RENTERS AND- AND LANDLORDS
HOLE. BY THE TIME TE PANDEMIC
IS OVER. I'M ON BEHALF OF
ARYANA HEALTH CARE WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S ARM.
THE PROPOSAL RELATIVE TO PROP
FIFTY SIX- FUNDING AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ASSURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON ANDREA SAN MIGUEL ON
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING ON TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE SEVEN ACTUALLY AT THE
START COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE GREW OVER HUNDRED
HEALTH CENTERS HUNDRED TWO
QUICK POINTS. FIRST WERE
RELIEVED TO SEE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET NINETEEN THE
INVESTMENT IN SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS THEY WERE PUT IN
PLACE BY THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
FORM OF PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
HUNDRED PAYMENTS- AND JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT WERE
ENCOURAGED- BUT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET ALSO NOTED THE NEED FOR
ONGOING TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITY
IS WITHIN THAT HEALTHEQUITY
SECTION- YOU KNOW AS SOME OF
YOU KNOW THE PLAN PARENTS SEVEN
AFFILIATES HAVE BEEN. WORKING
ON IMPLEMENTING TELEHEALTH
ANOTHER INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER CARE I'M
HERE BECAUSE THEY WILL CONTAIN
OTHER NEEDS TO MEET PATIENTS
WHERE THEY ARE I WISH
OFTENTIMES IT'S NOT JUST ONLINE
OR IN PERSON BUT BY PHONE SO
WE'RE REALLY EAGER TO SEE WHICH
FLEXIBILITIES ARE INCLUDED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN-
SPECIFICALLY INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO
HEALTH CARE SUCH AS THE
TELEPHONIC VISITS I'M REMOTE
ENROLLMENT FOR SOME OF THE
LIMITED SCOPE PROGRAMS AND
PAYMENT PARITY WITH A MEDIC CAL
SO I WILL BE WATCHING FOR THOSE
AND- APPRECIATE THAT THE FUTURE
DISCUSSION THAT. WILL BE IN
EFFECT COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI IT'S NANCY
GOLDBERG- FROM JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE FROM LOS ANGELES I
FIRST WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR THIS EXTENDED AND
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION AROUND
THE- STATE BUDGET PROPOSAL WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND ITS PROTECTION AT
THE MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM. FUNDING FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS IN
THE INVESTMENT INTO YOUR MEALS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO AS NINA
SAID TALKING IN MORE DETAIL
AROUND HHS AND THE APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEES BUT WHEN I DID WANT
TO RAISE HERE TODAY IS THE-
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PROGRAM
AND THAT WE HOPE THAT IT CAN BE
MODIFIED FROM THE ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL. TO ENSURE THAT SSI
RECIPIENTS ARE ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM THE- DEARLY NEEDED FUNDING
THEY HAVE BEEN FORCED TO TAKE
ON SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER COSTS
TO MEET MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS
GET TO DELIVERY OBTAIN PP AND
YET THEIR ABILITY TO OBTAIN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS EXTREMELY
LIMITED. SO WE HOPE THAT YOU
LOOK AT HOW GOLDEN STATE MILLIS
IS DESIGNED AND IMPLEMENTED WE
FIND A WAY TO INCLUDE THIS-
POPULATION OF HIGH NEED IN THAT
AS WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND LOOKS. I'M SORRY
ALEX TO WORK WITH THE LEAD. IN
THE YOU'REAHEAD. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS INTERCHANGE ARE
COMMON AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS- ALL ECHO THE THANKS-
FERMENTABLE PART AND ALSO ALIGN
MYSELF WITH HER COMMENTS ON-
INCLUDING PARITY FOR SSI
RECIPIENTS IN GOLDEN STATE
SERIAL IS JUST UNDER SCORE-
THAT OLDER ADULTS ARE- BY FAR I
BELIEVE 80% OF THE MORE
CALORIES WHO CALLED IT.
ANALYSTS INCOME OVER ADULT
ANALYSIS I HAVE EXTRAORDINARY
COSTS IN TERMS OF FOOD MEDICINE
DELIVERY PP JUST TO STAY SAFE
AND SHELTERED HOME- SO THANKS
FOR LEGISLATURE TO
MINISTRATIONS CONSIDERATION OF
THAT- OF THE REST OF MY TIME I
WANT TO FOCUS ON HUNGER WHICH
IS AT AN ALL TIME HIGH THE MOST
RECENT DATA SHOW THAT IN FACT
ONE FOR CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS.
JUST A STUNNING TEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE HUNGRY ENOUGH
WORK THAT MUCH HIGHER FOR BLACK
AND NOT NEXT HOUSEHOLDS
ACTUALLY DOES THE KIDS SO WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT THERE ARE SOME
PROPOSALS INCLUDING CORPORATE
BANKS THEIR THE MILLION DOLLARS
AS EVERYONE KNOWS THE MIND YOU
MEAN EXTREMELY LONG WE'RE
ASKING FOR EARLY ACTION ON THAT
TO AVOID GAP IN THE SPRING- BUT
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE GOVERNORS
CONTINUED SUPPORT AS WELL AS
THE LEGISLATURE- AS WE CONTINUE
TO KEEP CALIFORNIANS HELPING
MARK THAT. TIME WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR- AND
THE MINISTRATION WORKING TO
TRUE UP THE S. AND P. AND G.
AND B. HOLD HARMLESS PROPOSALS-
OF COURSE APPRECIATE DR PAN
PERSONAL WORK ON THE FULL TIME
WITH BENEFITS- IN ADDITION TO
WRITING THEM WE NEED TO DO TO
CLEAN UP FROM THE ORIGINAL-
PASSAGE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN REPLACE THOSE
BENEFITS DURING THE FASTER
PEOPLE NEED THE MOST. OTHERWISE
THEY'RE NOT HOLDING PEOPLE
HARMLESS AS WELL AS- STOPPED
CHURNING IN WHICH PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO HOW WE PROVIDED
FLEXIBILITY CALCRAFT. ANIMAL
BROADLY I WOULD JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT WE NEED TO INVEST
IN SCHOOLS EDUCATION SERVICE
DEPARTMENTS NOT JUST IN RE
OPENING WE KNOW HOW BADLY
EITHER- BY NOT BEING ABLE TO
HAVE AS MANY REIMBURSABLE MEALS
I MEAN ARE CALPERS PROGRAM-
BECAUSE THESE NOT ONLY HELP
KEEP CALIFORNIANS HEALTHY AND
WELL FED THERE. PROVEN TO DRIVE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WHO ARE
CRITICAL TO ECONOMY SUPPORT BY
JUST. KIND OF UNFAIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. X. GO TO LINE FIFTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NEW ME
PLEASE. YES HELLO AND WE CAN
HEAR GO AHEAD. CITING WAS JUST
RETURN HERE AND IT JUST FEELS
LIKE IN THE LINE OF. DREW DOING
THE COLD FOR SSR SO I WILL ECHO
THOSE STATEMENTS I WILL ALSO
LET GO MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP I HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN YOUR INTERNET
BROADBAND I PARTICIPATED IN
YOUR MASTER PLAN I PARTICIPATED
IN YOUR HEALTH CARE HALL WHO'S
A. CRITICAL NEEDS THAT YOU NEED
TO LOOK AT. I WILL OFFER TO THE
STATE IN TWO YEARS. THANK FIVE
YEARS A AND FOR WHAT YOU MADE
AND WHAT BEST RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
YOU TO BE THINKING IN THOSE
TERMS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF WHAT YOU DO RIGHT
NOW WILL HAVE THE IMPACT AND
WITH THE FACT THAT DECREASING
BUDGETS COMING UP YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE CAR IN THE
EFFORT BUT MONEY. TO ADDRESS
THE THINGS NEED SO MAKE THE
BEST INVESTMENTS PEOPLE IF YOU
CAN'T. RIGHT NOW IT ALSO ONE
MINUTE ISN'T BECAUSE NOT DO
JUSTICE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IF
YOU'RE REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT
LISTENING TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
I WILL PUT IT IN WRITING
FURTHER. YOU KNOW PUBLIC
COMMENT IS HERE FOR YOU TO HEAR
BACK NOT IN YOUR TWO HOURS WHAT
IS OUT THERE FOR THE REAL
PEOPLE THAT ARE EXISTING I NEED
AN EIGHTY PLUS COMPLEX. AT
LEAST FORTY OF THEM PROBABLY
HAVE NOT BEEN OUT SINCE THE
DATA DO MAKE BUT ONCE OR TWICE.
YOU HAVE A HOME BOUND IF YOU
HAVE NOT YET SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AS MARTIN MANY OTHER COUNTIES
FIGURED OUT HOW DO YOU ADDRESS
THE WHOLE BARREL. PEOPLE
RESIDING IN THE APARTMENT
POLICE. WAS IN ALMOST EVERY. HE
NEED TO BUDGET THEIR YOU NEED
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE NEED TO
BE MAY TO ENSURE THAT BUT LONG
GOVERNOR'S EXPECT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK TO LIE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. K. WATER WHAT
HELP WORK AND FAMILY. WOULD
MEAN LIKE TO ON THE CALL LIKE A
TO TAKE IMMEDIATE TO EXPAND
AMERICAN PAID DAYS ISSUE AN
EXTRA- CALL THE NINETEEN ARE.
IN CALIFORNIA AND HOT ACROSS
THE STATE- AND 0% I THINK
CAPACITY WHEN WORKERS LAST A
DECADE THEY'RE ASKING WORKERS
TO RISK THEIR JOBS IN ORDER TO
FOLLOW PUBLIC HEALTH AND FIND.
A HOME TO RECOVER COMPOSED OF
NINETEEN TO GET ACCESS TO
FOLLOW THEIR PHYSICIANS ADVICE
I TWITTER PORN OR EVEN TO GET
VACCINATED IT IS INDEFENSIBLE
WORK TO MAKE CHOICE AND PUT OUR
ENTIRE HELP ADDRESS WE NEED TO
EXPAND PAID SICK DAYS NOW IN
ORDER TO STOP THE SPREAD OF THE.
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTER STAYING ABROAD ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WERE INSTRUCTED PORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S THERE I
MENTIONED TRANSPORTATION BUDGET.
THE CALIFORNIA NEVER GOING TO
HAVE A BALL AIRPORT CLINICAL
THE MEDIA GET INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE DOCTOR OUT. I
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE MACHINE
TRANSPORTATION FUND BUDGET. ARE
NOT DIVERTED FROM OTHER
PROGRAMS BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL SHORT YOUR MISSION
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
EXTENT AND LEVERAGES. HE
GRABBED THAT ALREADY. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADVANCING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. IT SON WILL GO
A LONG WAY AND ALLOWING
CONSUMERS AROUND ELECTRIC BE
ARRANGING SOCIETY WHICH WILL BE
CRITICAL TO THE WIDESPREAD
ADOPTION OF BEER- CARS. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE NINETY TWO
G. DOLLARS FOR THAT WHICH BE
APPROPRIATELY SPENT ON
GUARANTEED ADMISSION REDUCTIONS.
THE MAJORITY OF THE FUNDS WILL
HELP REPLACE HEAVY DUTY DIESEL
ENGINES THAT MAKE CALIFORNIANS
SICK WITH HEART AND LUNG
DISEASE EVERY DAY. FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO ADVANCE
THESE IMPORTANT BUDGET ITEMS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA MARKETS REPRESENTING
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST AND THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK WE
APPRECIATE THE EARLY SUPPORT
FOR REINSTATING FUNDING TO
CRITICAL CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS LIKE FOR
TO WORKING TOGETHER TO CROSS
FINDING SOLUTIONS THAT WORK TO
ADVANCE SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
AND FARMLAND PROTECTION ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY TWO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS REGINA BRINK BUT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND
AND THE SSI COALITION I WANT TO
ECHO MY COMMENT THE COMMENTS-
NANCY AND ANDREW AND JEFF ABOUT
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS BEING
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE BEEN
HARDEST HIT BUT DO NOT FILE
TAXES. THEY ARE THE CONCERN
PARTICULAR TO THAT GROUP WHO DO
ABSORB THOSE 7% I THINK HANGING
OVER OUR HEADS AND KEEPING-
DIFFERENT. I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT IT SHOULD CONSIDER BUDGET
PLANS WHAT IS BEEN MISSING FROM
THE GOVERNOR- LANDSCAPE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING AND- THE BROAD
BAND- DISCUSSIONS AND THE COBIT
NINETEEN RESPOND IS A
CONSIDERATION OF DISABILITIES
AND SPECIFICALLY THOSE WITH
VISUAL. AND HEARING
DISABILITIES THERE- SMALLER
POPULATIONS AND WE ARE BEING
OVERLOOKED BUT BEING THAT WE
CAN'T ACCESS PRINT AND WE CAN'T
DRIVE IT WILL BE CHILLY
IMPAIRED. OR THERE ARE
PARTICULAR COMMUNICATION
CONCERNS IF YOU'RE HEARING
IMPAIRED WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
WE'RE BEING LEFT OUT OF THE
RECOVERY PLANS AND THE
EMERGENCY PLANS INCLUDING THE
PLAN TO ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
AND HEALTHCARE AND GETTING
CASTING IN VACCINATING WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH SUPPORT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND YOU GOT THIS I
IT'S A SMALL POPULATION BUT AN
IMPORTANT POPULATION AND IT'S
GROWING. OVERREPRESENTED AMONG
THE SENIOR POPULATION FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND HARDEST HIT
SO. I HOPE I. DIDN'T. MIND ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
TERRY BRENNAN WITH AT TI YOU
CALIFORNIA LET ME START WITH
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS GOOD IN THE
BUDGET THAT 7% I HSS
RESTORATION. RECORDS FUNDING
FOR SCHOOLS CALLS TO EXTEND
THE- EVICTION PRETTY
PROTECTIONS IN THE US STIMULATE
CHECKS FOR OUR LOWEST WAGE
WORKERS- I WITH A BIT DISTURBED
OFFENDED BY THE L. A. O. T.
JACKSON THAT WE TARGET.
POPULATIONS OTHER THAN THOSE
THAT MIGHT BE GETTING THE
FEDERAL MONEY AND IF SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS WERE ENOUGH
MONEY WHILE WE'RE FIGHTING FOR
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AT THE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL- WHAT'S
MISSING FROM THIS BUDGET IS THE
RESTORATION OF ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS A CUT. THAT ALREADY
TOOK PLACE IN OCTOBER NO ONE'S
TALKING ABOUT- THE CUTS THE
STATE EMPLOYEE CSU COURTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN TRIGERED AND
ALL THE OTHER TRIGGERS ARE
MERELY PUSHED OFF INTO THE
FUTURE FOR MORE FACING. BAPTIST
SCHOOL CLASS. BOB NOT AN TO A
THE STRUCK DE. THAT WERE FACING
THE ROAD AND- THERE'S NO RELIEF
FOR THESE- EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
TO TAKE SICK LEAVE- THAT
EXPIRED IN DECEMBER SUSPENSION
OR BY EARLIER. SOCKS THERE'S A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT EQUITABLE
RECOVERY. BUT THE ONLY THING
FROM THE AUTOMATIC CHOPPING
BLOCK ARE PROGRAMS THAT DOES
THAT HELP THOSE WHO WERE HURT
MOST IN THE PANDEMIC A
RECESSION. THERE'S NO TRIGGER
OR TAX BREAKS OR SNOW TERRIER
PATAKI SPEND THE JURORS THERE'S
NO TRIGGER. FOR INCREASES IN
REVENUE- THAT SEEMS TO BE
PATENTLY UNFAIR I AGREE WITH
THE SENATE PANEL THAT ONE-
LET'S NOT REPEAT THE MISTAKES
OF THE PAST BY SETTING
OURSELVES UP. TO CUT OUR WAY
OUT OF THE RECESSION. AND STALL
THE RECOVERY. FOR YEARS IF NOT
DECADES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LIKE TO GO TO LINE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS AMBER BAUER AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE U. F.
C. W. WESTERN STATE COUNCIL AND
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
FRONTLINE UFCW MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA. ON JANUARY FIRST
DURING THE HIGHEST SURGE OF
KOBE NINETEEN CASES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE DISCOVERY
OF A NEW MORE CONTAGIOUS STRAIN
OF THE VIRUS WORKERS LOST THEIR
ABILITY TO ACCESS EMERGENCY
PAID SICK LEAVE A CRITICAL
SAFETY NET THAT ALLOWS WORKERS
PARTICULARLY THOSE LOW WAGE
MINORITY WORKERS. STAY HOME IF
THEY ARE EXPOSED OUR CONTRACT
CODE NINETEEN. WE'RE NEED
EMERGENCY SICK LEAVE MORE EVER
AND WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET
THAT PROVIDES ALL WORKERS
ADDITIONAL PAID SICK LEAVE.
WORKERS ARE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK AND ARE ONE PAYCHECK
AWAY FROM LOSING THEIR HOMES
THEIR CARS THEIR ABILITY TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE. EVERYTHING
EMERGENCY PAID SICK LEAVE IF
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A WORKER
BEING ABLE TO STAY HOME TO
PROTECT THEIR CO WORKERS FROM
EXPOSURE. ARE HAVING TO GO TO
WORK BECAUSE THEY NEED INCOME
AN IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION WE PUT
THEM. IN CONCLUSION WE STRONGLY
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT
EMERGENCY PAID SICK LEAVE
PROVISIONS THAN ANY IMMEDIATE
BUDGET THAT MOVE. FORWARD
WITHOUT THESE WORKERS ARE LEFT
WITH NO PROTECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TO DEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THANK ALL THE SENATORS ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE DIFFICULT
WORK YOU UNDERTAKE ON BEHALF OF
ALL THE PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
WELL THERE ARE SEVERAL
SIGNIFICANT ITEMS CAN BE LIKE
IN THE BUDGET LIKE YEAH THE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AND FORCED RESILIENCE CALAIS
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING THERE TO
SIGNIFICANT ITEMS THAT WE FEEL
WERE LEFT OUT OF ONE OF THEM I
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN THE CALL FOR
IMMEDIATE STATE FUNDING TO FILL
THE GAPS LEFT BY FEDERAL AND
OTHER FUNDING STREAMS. FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
MANY OF THOSE FUNDING STREAMS
ARE ON THE WAY BUT HAVE NOT YET
BEEN ALLOCATED UM C. DIGO ALSO
URGES THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING AND REFORMS
NEEDEDTO IMMEDIATELY EXPAND
ACCESS TO AN ADOPTION OF
BROADBAND AND REDUCE THE
INEQUITIES CAUSED BY THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. AND TO REALIZE
THE MULTIPLIER EFFECT THAT
COMES WHEN EVERYONE CONNECTED
MANY OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROPOSALS ARE OUTLINED IN THE
BROADBAND FOR ALL ACTION PLAN
RECENTLY ADOPTED A CALIFORNIA
BROADBAND COUNCIL AND SOME OF
THEM ARE ALREADY IN BILLS
INCLUDING SB FOUR EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIFTY FOUR WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER THESE MEASURES ARE
NOT XCELERATED. TIMELINE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JORDAN LINDSEY WITH THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
LETTERMAN COALITION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA GOOD
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THEIR FAMILIES
WORK FORCE. LIMON COLLISION IN
YOUR CALIFORNIANS RELIEVED THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
AT LEAST PRESERVES FUNDING TO
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THAT KNOWLEDGE IS INCREASING
NEED DUE TO THE PANDEMIC. WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP IN CHAMPIONS FOR
PRIORITIZING PEOPLE WITH IBD
DURING THIS PANDEMIC IN THEIR
BUDGET WORK. AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET HAVE A LOT OF INTEREST
IN ADDRESSING SYSTEMIC INEQUITY
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR DECADES THE
SYSTEM SERVING PEOPLE WORK IDEA
INCLUDING REGIONAL CENTERS AND
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS HAVE
BEEN CRITICALLY UNDERFUNDED
WHICH IS EXACERBATED
DRAMATICALLY DUE TO THE CALL
THE NINETEEN CRISIS. RESULTING
IN BARRIERS TO QUALITY SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS FOR POPULATION AND
THE CRITICALLY UNDERPAID
WORKFORCE SERVING THEM. WELL
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
THE DELAY IS THE SUSPENSION OF
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASES BY
ONE YEAR IT DOES NOT REPRESENT
A LONG TERM SOLUTION TO SYSTEM
WIDE PROBLEMS THAT EXIST TODAY.
AND THE REMAINING ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR UNDER
FINING THAT WAS IDENTIFIED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
ERVICES RIGHT STUDY. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THE
INEQUITY AND VULNERABILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR WHOLE
ROIC SUPPORT WORK FORCE. THAT
WAS CREATED BY THE CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING WILL BE. ADDRESSED
IN THE STATE BUDGET. I WE ALL
STRONG URGE THE AT THE TIME.
ALSO BEING IN THE GOAL STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ARE LIKE TO GO TO LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NINETEEN
STILL COMPLEMENT DIRECTED AND
TURNING IT PUBLIC COUNCIL IN
MCCANDLESS AND THE FACT THAT
THE WOMEN AND GIRLS RIGHT
PROJECT. I'M CALLING-
CRITICALLY TO ASK THE
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO EXPAND
EMERGENCY PAID SIXTY EIGHT- FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA WORKERS WITH
CASES SURGING IN CALIFORNIA AND
BIRTHWEIGHT DEFENSE WORKERS THE
BUT THOSE WERE THE HARDEST HIT
AND BROKE IT WITH. THE BALL AT
TIME TO LET THESE A PAYCHECK
DAY PROVISION WAX AND WE CANNOT
WAIT FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE ACTION. I'M CALLING ON
YOU TO TAKE URGENT STEPS TO
MAKE SURE THAT EMERGENCY PAID
SICK LEAVE CONTINUES FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKERS BUT I ALSO
WANT TO CHECK. I'LL BE RIGHT
HERE THE W. THE COALITION FOR
WORKING. FAMILIES OBSTINATELY
WHAT THE **** OUT OF THE PIRATE
I- ALSO APPRECIATE ALL
GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET A LONG. ON
THE FOR CHILDCARE DIRECTLY. ALL
WHO- ONLY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THANK YOU LEARN FOR YOUR TIME.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE FIFTY THREE.
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. BUT AT-
CIRCLED THE DS REPRESENTING THE
CAL SO FOR BY THE IT'S AND CAL
TOGETHER MY COMMENTS ARE
SPECIFIC TO THE TO BILL. IN
SEVEN FUNDING TO SCHOOL TO A
AND BURKE INSTRUCTION. FORTY
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS WITH
NEEDS. OUR STUDENTS SHOULD BE
AND COULD IN THE COAL OF
IDENTIFY FOR THE FUNDING WITH
THOSE GREAT SEVEN THROUGH
TWELVE ENGLISH LEARNERS LIKE
SPECIAL ED HOMELESS AND FOSTER
YOU HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS THAT ARE
NOT BEING WELL SERVED BY
DISTANCE LEARNING. SAYS
BRADDOCK OR INCONSISTENT
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
AND MINIMAL IF ANY IN PERSON
INTERACTION WITH WITH PAIRED
FOR FURTHER INCLUDES LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT PLEASE EXPLICITLY
INCLUDE ENGLISH LEARNERS A T.
K. THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE IN
THIS PROPOSAL WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU YOUR STAFF
AND THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
AND. OTHER BUDGET ISSUES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'D BEEN NATIONALLY HOW THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN YOUTH
AND THE CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE CALLING
REGARDING THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS FOR EXPANDED
LEARNING WHICH FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND FUNDING AND RECOGNIZING THE
ESSENTIAL EXPENDITURE IN
PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY FOR
STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND FOSTER CARE.
AND ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS I
TO ENSURE THAT SUPPORT EACH OF
THE STUDENTS WHO NEED IT MOST
OF QUICKLY EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE WE URGE YOU TO LINE UP
WHICH CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
SYSTEM A PUBLIC PUBLICLY FUNDED
AFTERSCHOOL AND SUMMER LEARNING
PROGRAMS. WITH MORE THAN FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED PROGRAMS COMMITTEE
PARTNERSHIPS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NORMALLY SERVING NEARLY
HALF MILLION STUDENTS EACH DAY
I HAVE THE EXPERIENCE THAT THE
STRUCTURE TO COMBAT PANDEMIC
FUNDING LOSS INSPIRED THE OF
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF
OUR MOST STUDENTS. WE ALSO ASK
YOU TO PRIORITIZE THE EXTENT OF
LEARNING WORKFORCE AND CHILD
CARE WORKERS AND TEACHERS IN
PHASE ONE B. VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION AS MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN PROVIDING IN
PERSON SUPERVISION AND SUPPORT
YOU CANNOT SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
CLOSED. AND FINALLY WE ASK THAT
YOU DEVELOP A PLAN TO INCLUDE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS FOR
STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES COLAS FOR
OTHER EDUCATION CATEGORICAL BUT
AMIDST THE AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION AND SAFETY. PROGRAM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK THANKS FOR
THE LINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIA
HERNANDEZ AND I'M AN ATTORNEY
AT LEGAL AID AT WORK A
NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES. FREE
LEGAL EDUCATION ADVICE AND
ADVOCACY FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS
ACROSSTHE STATE. SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC WE'VE
HEARD FROM HUNDREDS OF WORKERS
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN.
WHEN THEY'VE HAD ACCESS TO PAID
SICK DAYS THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
STAY HOME AND STOP THE SPREAD
BUT WHEN THEY HAVEN'T THEY'VE
BEEN FORCED INTO AN IMPOSSIBLE
CHOICE. EITHER GO TO WORK AND
RICK FRANCONA NINETEEN OR STAY
HOME WITH INCOMES AND THEIR JOB
FACED WITH THIS IMPOSSIBLE
CHOICE. THEY ARE LEFT WITH NO
OPTION BUT TO RETURN TO WORK
RISKING THEIR AND THE PUBLIC'S
HELP IN CONTINUING THE CRITICAL
THAT NINETEEN. I'M SURE YOU
WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TO HEAR
THAT THANK YOU MY CHOICE. SOME
WORKERS HAVE CHOSEN TO KEEP
WORKING. ON JANUARY FIRST
FEDERAL PAID SICK DAYS AND BY
EXTENSION THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OKAY DAYS AND THAT DURING
MILLIONS OF WORKERS INTO THIS
PREDICAMENT AT THE SAME MOMENT
THAT. SECTION RESTORED AND THE
IDEAS ACROSS THE STATE REACH
THEIR CAPACITY THIS IS A
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
STUDIES SHOW THAT IT COULD HAVE
SAVED LIVES DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE NEED TO TAKE THE ACT. ENSURE
THAT WORKERS CAN COMPLY WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTIVE STOP
THE PARTICLE THE NINETEEN AND
STILL KEEP THEIR INCOME AND
JOBS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
THE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO
YES LINES OPEN WE CAN HEAR YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT I THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY HI MY NAME'S
STEPHEN THE MANAGER THE MANAGER
AFTER SPEAKING WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION LONG
ASSOCIATION WITH THE BUDGET
PROCESS A CRITICAL OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS MANY LONG HEALTH
ISSUES AFFECTING CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHICH ONLY
SUPPORT THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
EXPAND FOR THE NINETEENTH AT
THE IMPACT HE DISTRIBUTION
BECAUSE OF THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS TO EXPAND TESTING
UNDESERVEDLY NINETEEN PER
CONTRACT TRACY. AND
CONSECUTIVELY PRODUCTION
DISTRIBUTION SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF A NEW OFFICE OF
PROFITABILITY TO INCREASE
HEALTHCARE QUALITY AND
CONTRAVENTION RENDITION YARD TO
KEEP FOCUSED ON YOUR MISSION
TRANSPORTATION AVENUE TEMPERATE
COMMITTEE HOW STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GLOBAL TO ADEQUATELY
DOLLARS FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
TO THE AUTHORIZATION BECAUSE
THE FRONT ENTRANCE OF THE
PRECIPITATE EUROPE
TRANSPORTATION BUCKLED OKAY
BECAUSE FOR ALL PROGRAMS AND
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
GOING TO BE ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
JUSTIFICATORY TO THE CONCLUSION
THE IMPACT ON MOST WANTED
FUGITIVES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. NECK WEEK A
DEADLINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS RICK MAN WERE
FROM CHIU NOW AND- WE WILL SEND
YOU COM NEXT WEEK ON OF THE-
BUT TODAY WE TO ****
SPECIFICALLY ON OF EARLY- IN
THE EDUCATION BUDGET-
SPECIFICALLY ONE OF THE ISSUES
EARLY ACTION IS FUNDING
DEFERRALS- WHILE THE BUDGET
PROPOSES SEVEN POINT THREE
BILLION- TO ADDRESS THE COLD IT
CAN WAIT UNTIL NEXT YEAR TO DO
THAT- THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES AVAILABLE IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE. UP
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. WHICH THERE
SHOULD BE EARLY ACTION TAKEN SO
THE DISTRICT DON'T FACE
DEFERRALS STARTING NEXT MONTH
RIGHT NOW THE CURRENT PLAN
WOULD BE TO DEFER PAYMENTS FROM
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR. TELL THE
FALL COME NOVEMBER- WE THINK
THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED IN THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE AND ONE OF
THE REASONS TO THOSE DEFERRALS
FALL DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
DISTRICTS SERVING THE STUDENTS
OF GREATEST NAMES- WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO- TO THE CONVERSATION
AROUND RE OPENING SCHOOLS AND
LEARNING LINES. ARE ENCOURAGED
BY SOME OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS IN THIS AREA
INCLUDING AB TEN WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE RE OPENING OF
SCHOOLS WHEN A COMMUNITY
REACHES A CERTAIN COLOR
CATEGORY AND AB ONE OH FOUR
WHICH ADDRESSES BURNING
OPTICIANS. FINALLY WE WANTED
TO- SO JERRY OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS OF ONE OF OUR ENGLISH
LEARNER COLLEAGUES. ADVOCATE
CALLING TO THE SUGGESTED THAT
ENGLISH LEARNERS SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY GROUP- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RE OPENING PROPOSAL
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE.
ACCESS TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION-
IF I STILL TIME I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO APPROACH- THE- ON THE-
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PARTNERS.
AND FOR TO WORK WITH
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
COUNTIES ARE PREPARED. AND HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR LOCAL PLAN. THANKS SO
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FORTY THREE LINES OPEN. OKAY
MOVING ON ONLINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY ONE THANK
YOU FOR TAKING MY CALL THIS IS
ANDREW CALLING FROM NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THAT'S WHAT
I THINK THE MOMENT YOU KNOW I
THINK THE GOVERNOR JEAN FOR
QUOTING OTHER CRITICAL STATE IN
THIS PROGRAM BUT WANTED TO ECHO
WHAT SO MANY OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED HERE TODAY. ABOUT ITS
NEED TO BE MODIFIED THAT
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDES EXERCISE
JAPAN'S- THANK YOU FOR THE
POINT OUT THAT ASSEMBLY PINTER.
NOT JUST MADE UP OF- OLDER
POPULATION BUT A
DISPROPORTIONATE LOW INCOME AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR- IN OUR HIGHEST
RISK FOR SERIOUS ILLNESS THAT
CAN COME GOOD- I KNOW THIS IS
MENTIONED MULTIPLE TIMES IN THE
AFTERNOON- BUT WE CANNOT STRESS
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
THANKS TO THE TO LINE UP TO ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
LINDA WAY WITH LESSONS AND
NOMAAN POVERTY APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR AND MINISTRATIONS
RECOGNITION OF THE GROWING
INEQUALITY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE
THE BUDGET PROTECT FOR
CALIFORNIANS. WHILE WE SUPPORT
THE SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR GOLDEN
STATE IN THE LAST SIMILAR TO
OTHERS WE WANT TO EXPAND IT TO
ALL LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IT'S ALSO CRITICAL TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO ALL
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS SENATOR TORONTO NOTE AND
REDUCE BARRIERS TO ENROLLING IN
MEDICARE HOW. TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE HARMFUL
ACIDS YEAH THANK YOU. NEXEO TO
LINE SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JUSTIN
ROSE ON BEHALF OF WORKER OWNED
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA. THE NEW
COALITION FORMED BY STATE AND
NATIONAL EXPERTS WORKER OWNED
COMPANIES AND LABOR UNIONS
WORKING FOR YEARS TO ADVANCE
WORKER OWNERSHIP IN COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED BY SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES. WHICH IS
WHY WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY
AROUND THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSE
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION INCREASE TO THE COVETED
RELIEF GRANT AND THE OVERALL
PROPOSED FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION- BUT HE PACKAGE FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. WE APPRECIATE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
AROUND JUST WHO ARE THESE FUNDS
ACTUALLY BENEFITING ARE THEY
BEING DISTRIBUTED OR GRANTED
OUT IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER THAT
BENEFITS THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
THOSE HARDEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC SO OUR COALITION IS
PROPOSING THAT. RATHER THAN
CLOSING FOR GOOD OR SELLING TO
LARGE OUT OF STATE BUYERS SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS CAN FIND
WILLING BUYERS AND THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK ALONGSIDE THEM EVERY
DAY THEIR WORKERS AND WE
DEFINITELY SUPPORT JOB CREATION
AND I'M SURE AS ALL OF YOU HAVE
HEARD FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS
JOB RETENTION IS ALSO A BIG KEY
AND WE SEE- WORKER OWNERSHIP
CONVERSIONS AS- A VALID. PATH
TOWARDS THAT DIRECTION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO BOB LANE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BABY HEY GIRL HOW AGENCIES. WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AROUND
TO THEM HOW HOMELESSNESS AGING
AND OTHER IMPORTANT POLICY
FOCUS AREA. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE CONTINUED FOCUS AND
INVESTMENT AND HELP BUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN PARTICULAR.
WE AT C. B. H. A. LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO CRAFT
A BUDGET THAT ACCOUNTS FOR THE
NEEDS OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS AND CLIENTS. THANK
YOU. LIKE TO GO TO LINE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KEVIN AND CO DIRECTOR
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO EXPAND
EMERGENCY PAID SICK DAYS. WHICH
WE BELIEVE ARE ESSENTIAL TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF COLD AT
NIGHT SHE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXEO TO LINE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TERRY MEMBERS CONNIE TALCOTT ON
BEHALF OF COLLECTED MEDICAL
CARE COORDINATION TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM AND YOU FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY A HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION MENTION AN
ACOUSTIC MODEL FOR HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE BY
REFERENCING THE NETWORK OF
EXCHANGES. THIS LEADS
COMMUNITIES WORK WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY'VE ALREADY
BUILT IN WAYS THAT WORK BEST
FOR REGIONAL STAKEHOLDERS
HOSPITALS AND PATIENTS. WE HOPE
THAT THE STATE WILL ADOPT THE
FEDERAL DEFINITION OF H. I. E.
WHICH IS INCLUSIVE AND ALLOW
HOSPITAL EXCUSE FOR PROFIT NOT
FOR PROFIT CHANGE. OF THEIR
CHOICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEXICO TO LINE SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS SERRA LOWEST WITH PETE. I
FIRST WANTED TO HIT MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS FROM CHILDREN NOW
AROUND FOCUSING ON ADDRESSING
THE DEFERRALS IN THE CURRENT IN
RIGHT NOW RATHER THAN WAITING
FOR THAT BUDGET YEAR AND ALSO
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES FROM-
COMPANIES TOGETHER IN TOPPING
ABOUT MAKING ENGLISH LEARNERS A
PRIORITY GROUP IN THE RE
OPENING PLAN. IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE WANTED TO APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS ON INVESTING IN
EXTENDED LEARNING- WE JUST
WANNA BE CLEAR THAT THOSE FUNDS
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED BASED ON
THE CONCENTRATION OF HIGH NEED
STUDENTS AND- SHOULD REALLY
FOCUS ON RESTORATIVE RETURN TO
SCHOOL- ALSO REALLY BE AT IN
COURAGE ABILITY FROM PROVIDE
KILLER SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
TO- REDRESS- COOLEY TRAUMA AS
WELL AS THE TRAUMA. OF THE
RECKONING WITH OUR OUR OUR
RATIONS STRUCTURES THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE DEALING WITH- AND
ENCOURAGE UGLY REPORTING ON HOW
THOSE FUNDS ARE SPENT BOTH FOR
THAT PROGRAM AND. FOR THE RE
OPENING PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICHARD
DEGREE MERICAN CHALCONE
COALITION. BOMB WE HAVE A BIG
PROBLEM EVERYBODY'S HAVING THIS
MASSIVE YEARS NEWLY PROMOTED BY
THE MEDIA. TECHNOLOGY IS NOT A
GUY SO STOP IN DOCTORS ARE NOT
PRODUCTS SO WE GOT. PAGE
PRIVACY ISSUES. TRACINGS OF
ALLOCATION OF PRIVACY. AND
CENSORSHIP. THEY'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW IT'S GOING TO BE ON THE TO
SCHOOL TO GET OUT THERE. SENATE
BILL YOU WILL BE AT HOME UNTIL
YOU ARE NOT DOCTORS DOCTOR
TEAMS OF SAUDIS LIVING IS KEY
RIGHT NOW. TO TRY TO PREVENT
CONTENT EVIDENCE THE SIMPSONS.
BECAUSE PEOPLE TRY TO STAND UP
TO THE TRUTH I'LL BE AGENCIES
ACTIONS ARE BECAUSE TRADERS IN
CALLS AND. CARERS DR T. AND IT
WAS AROUND SANTA NGUYEN HAS. SO
ACTION. AN EXTRA IF YOU ALL YOU
CONSIDERING IT BECAUSE OF THE
IS THAT YOU ARE ACTION.
ACTUALLY TO BE. THEY DON'T TO
WORRY ABOUT ME. SO LITTLE CHEER
IT BUT YOU KNOW ME THE ACTUALLY
SPECIAL SINCE YOU WERE OKAY
COME ON. WELL- WE CAN HOLD. BIG
PHARMA. THERE WAS MEASURE FOR
THEY MAY NO WE CAN HOME CAN TO
IF IT'S- HARD TO ONE WOULD YOU
CAN. BECAUSE WHAT CHOICE DO WE
HAVE. TO RESPECT IS VERY DANGER.
NON WANT TO PRINT YOU GUYS GOT
CAN GUYS BLATANT THE EVER OF A
LOBBYIST THINGS BUT REALLY NOT
TRYING TO PROVE HE'S NOT WHAT
FORTY SEVEN PERSON. ON THE
MONEY ISSUE ABOUT THE BUDGET.
IF WE DOING WHAT WE'RE DOING
THINGS DOWN OUT. AGAIN KNOW
SOME REAL IS ALWAYS A MANY
YEARS. ALBEIT ABOUT BACK. A
LITTLE WILL BE- FIVE DOLLAR
LOOKS. ONLY PROBLEMS GO DOWN.
PLEASE WAKE UP TO SAY HEY. THIS
IS NOT HOW WE WORK IN AMERICA.
IS NOT HOW WE WERE. WE THE
PEOPLE TAKE CARE OF ONE ANOTHER
WE HAVE A GOVERNOR'S. THANKED
ME A LOT OF UNIQUE THINGS IF
YOU COULD READ. THANK YOU YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. KOK NEXT THE
LAST ONE COMIC STREAMLINED ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR BY WOULD SEE A TWO
YEAR THAT YOU CLASS. OLD STOCK
WERE BEING CHAIRED THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. ARE LOOKING FOR
WORKING WITH AND THE REST THE
MEMBERS THIS DAY. THANK THE
BUDGET THAT ALLOCATES MORE
DOLLARS FOR EDUCATION THAN EVER
BEFORE HOWEVER GIVEN OUR
CURRENT SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES IN
THE RESEARCH OF THE SPREAD OF
COVERAGE FOR STUDENTS IN THE
RISE OF INFECTION RATES PROJECT
FOR EDUCATION STAFF SAYING THAT
IN TEXAS AND NEW YORK.
WINDSCREENS RESUMED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WE HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS REGARDING THE LACK OF
A COORDINATED PLAN BETWEEN THE
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION DOLLARS
AND VACCINATIONS AND- THANK
SENATOR LAYER COULD BRING THAT
POINT UP EARLIER TODAY. WE
ADVOCATE FOR THE BUDGET
PRIORITIES THAT FOCUSED ON
BRINGING DOLLARS TO ENSURING
ACCESS TO THOSE VACCINES- FOR
EDUCATION WORKERS AND OF COURSE
IMPORTANTLY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL TARGETED
INTERVENTION FOR STRUGGLING
STUDENTS. UNDERSTAND NOT
EVERYONE CAN DRIVING DISTANCE
LEARNING AND WE SHOULD STEP IN
TO HELP THOSE THAT ARE NOT.
PART WE ARE NOT MEETING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS WE ALSO CONCERNS
REGARDING THE INEQUITY- THE
INCENTIVE GRANTS THAT PROVIDE
FUNDS TO SOME DISTRICTS AND NOT
OTHERS WE KNOW THERE'S A FINITE
NUMBER FIVE NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS. AND OF COURSE THIS IS
ALSO IMPACTING THE SAME FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO. ONCE AGAIN WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND- THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON ALL
THESE PROPOSALS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANKS SO MUCH. THE NOTE
FOR THE COMMON IN Q. X. SIR I
THINK. THAT IS. THE END OF OUR-
PUBLIC COMMENT HAVE FUN I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FROM FOR
PARTICIPATING THEIR MEMBERS THE
GREAT QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ARE ELADIO STAFF FOR
ASSISTING US THESE HEARINGS ARE
A LITTLE HARDER WHEN WE HAVE TO
DO. MUCH OF IT REMOTELY AND MY
REMOTE COLLEAGUES WHO
PARTICIPATED THANK YOU ALSO AND
CLEARLY AGAIN FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WANT TO SPECIFICALLY TO- BE
ABLE TO PAY ATTENTION TO YOUR
PARTICULAR- REQUESTS AROUND THE
BUDGET PLEASE SUBMIT THEM TO
THE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE IN WRITING WHAT YOU
CAN DO THROUGH OUR WEBSITE SO
THANKS SO MUCH WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. AND WE ARE NOW.
ADJOURN.